HE WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
MORNING AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
SOME PRECAUTIONS THE MEASURE ON
GOING COVER NINETEEN REST THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WORK OF THE
PUBLIC TO OUR HEARINGS AS
PROVIDE ACCESS. BOTH IN PERSON
TELECONFERENCE PARTICIPATION FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING REVIVED
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPATION
TOLL FREE NUMBER ACCESS CODES
POSTAR COMMITTEE WEBSITE WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN-
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR
ZERO. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO TELL COVER SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WEBSITES I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING IS CUSTOMER IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAYBE REMOVE THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE'RE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING HERE HERE
IN THE- STREET BUILDING ALSO
REFERRED TO AS THE SWING SPACE I
ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
COME TO THE ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A CORPSMAN
BEGINNER HEARING. FOUR WOULD BE
IN THE HEARING- WE WILL WAIT ONE
MOMENT TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM- WE
HAVE. WE NEED ONE MORE MEMBER
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
TO FORM A QUORUM- THIS MORNING
WE'RE TAKING UP AB THIRTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES. AND UP
IN ME. FOR THIS BILL SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL EACH GET FOUR
WITNESSES WHO WILL HAVE A TOTAL
OF FOUR MINUTES TO SPEAK. ALL
OTHER BILLS WILL BE LIMITED TO
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH IN OTHER WORDS.
FOUR MINUTES FOR THE SUPPORT
FOUR MINUTES FOR THE OPPOSITION
TO BE DIVIDED BETWEEN TWO
WITNESSES. ALL THOSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. WILL BE A TIME LIMIT OF
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR CALLS IN
SUPPORT ANOTHER WORDS THOSE ARE
CALLING IN FOR WHAT WE REFER TO
AS ME TO. CALLS IN SUPPORT FIFTY
MINUTES FOR CALLS IN OPPOSITION.
LET ME REITERATE FOR THOSE
CALLING IN- YOU MAY GIVE YOUR
NAME. YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. WE HAVE
FOUR ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DAY THE ITEMS OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ARE AS FOLLOWS
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S. B. ONE
FOUR ZERO FIVE BY CENTER- CHILL
BOOK. FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE S.
B. ONE ZERO TWO FOUR BY SENATOR
JONES FOUNDER THIRTEEN S. B. ONE
ONE FIVE NINE BY SENATOR JONES
AND FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE NUMBER
FOURTEEN S. B. ONE THREE EIGHT
ZERO BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY WITH AMENDMENTS-
SENATE JONES YOU'VE- GOT. 50%
THE CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY ALL
RIGHT. I WILL TAKE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AS SOON AS
WE HAVE A QUORUM- ONCE AGAIN
URGING MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TOO UP ERE
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP- A. B.
THIRTY FIVE HERE AS THE FIRST
ORDER OF BUSINESS. I'M A TURN OF
THE GAVEL TO CENTER BOARD JUST
VICE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU I HAVE MY PROVERBIAL GAVEL
REYES HERE'S CHAIR. LARA AT
THANK YOU KINDLY FOR HELLO. WITH
THE ARRIVAL OF CENTER WHAT- WE
WOULD LIKE- TAKE ROLL CALL TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM- BURKE- BURKE HERE BORJAS
VISIT FOR JUST PRESENT ZERO. THE
RUSSELL GONZALEZ HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HERE JONES JONES HERE
LAYARD HERE WHERE'D HERE STERN
WHAT KASKY WHITE HOUSE SKI HERE
WIENER YOU HAVE A SIX PRESENT TO
HAVE A QUORUM. MISTER CHAIR
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO MOVE
CONSENT AT THIS TIME. YES YES
SOME OF THE L. MAKE MOTION FOR
CONSENT WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR JONES- TO APPROVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- CLERKING CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. AMBERG NUMBER GUY
BURGESS HI FOR JUST I CARRY IT
ALL THE RUSSELL GONZALEZ
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG AYE JONES.
JONES I LAYERED ON A LAYERED AYE
STERN. BY CAL SKI ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR LAKE COUNTY AYE WIENER-
SO FAR YOU HAVE SIX TWO ZERO
WITH MEMBERS MISSING KEEP THE
OPEN ALL RIGHT- WE WILL NOT GO.
TO A MEDIA AFFECT OPEN IT BACK
UP LET'S GO AHEAD IN A LAW
CENTER DRAWS SO TO BE PART OF
THE TEAM OKAY TO OPEN UP OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR COVER YET- THAT ALSO.
THERE ARE SO I GONZALEZ. STERN
WIENER. GIVE SEVENTIES THERE
WITH MY MISS. I WILL KEEP THAT
OPEN ALL RIGHT WE'RE MOVING ON-
TO. AB THIRTY FIVE ON WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES IN
SENATOR- BURKE- THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. I AM SO
PLEASED TO BRING BEFORE YOU AB
THIRTY FIVE WHICH REPRESENTS.
LONG OVERDUE REFORMS TO THE
MEDICARE MEDICAL INJURY
COMPENSATION REFORM ACT KNOWN AS
MICRO. CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAL
MALPRACTICE STATUTE HAS BEEN
UNCHANGED FOR NEARLY FIVE
DECADES AND IN THAT TIME
MAGNIFIED AND EXACERBATED
POLITICAL DIFFERENCES. AB THIRTY
FIVE IS A COMPROMISE THAT
SETTLES THESE DISPUTES MOVING
FORWARD THE PROVIDE A BALANCED
AND EQUITABLE SOLUTION FOR
PATIENTS AND MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS. CURRENT LAW
LIMITS THE PLAINTIFFS NON
ECONOMIC RECOVERY TWO TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS REGARDLESS OF THE NUMBER
OF DEFENDANTS REGARDLESS OF THE
PAIN AND SUFFERING OF THE
INJURED PATIENT. OR OF THE
FAMILY WHOSE LOVED ONES DIED
FROM MALPRACTICE. IN SUMMARY
THIS HISTORIC AGREEMENT. DOES
THREE THINGS. IT INCREASES THE
CAP FOR NON DEATH CASES FROM
200-500-0023 HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND ON JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND CONTINUES TO
INCREASE INCREMENTALLY UNTIL WE
GET TO SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TEN YEARS.
THE CAP FOR WRONGFUL DEATH THE
CASE FOR WRONGFUL DEATH CASES
WOULD INCREASE FROM 200-500-0025
HUNDRED THOUSAND THE FIRST YEAR
AND CONTINUES TO INCREASE
INCREMENTALLY TO ONE MILLION
DOLLARS AFTER TEN YEARS.
SUBSEQUENT TO THE FINAL
STATUTORY CAP IN TWENTY THIRTY
THREE. 10% COLA WILL KICK IN
STARTING ON JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY THIRTY FOUR AND WILL
ADJUST THE CAPS ANNUALLY. AB
THIRTY FIVE CREATES THREE
SEPARATE CATEGORIES OF
DEFENDANTS FOUR THREE POSSIBLE
CAPS. ONE CAP FOR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS. ONE CAP FOR HEALTH
CARE INSTITUTIONS AND ONE CAP
FOR UNAFFILIATED HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS OR HEALTH CARE
INSTITUTIONS THAT COMMIT A
SEPARATE NEGLIGENT ACT. THIS
BILL REPRESENTS THE TIRELESS
WORK OF STAKEHOLDERS
REPRESENTING PATIENTS AND
MEDICAL PROVIDERS THAT CAME
TOGETHER FOR THIS MONUMENTAL
AGREEMENT. I WOULD NOW LIKE TO
HAND IT OVER TO OUR JOINT AUTHOR
OF AB THIRTY FIVE. SENATOR AND
CHAIR. MR UMBERG WHO WILL ALSO
INTRODUCE OUR WITNESSES- THANK
YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE- LET ME
BEGIN BY. THANKING SEVERAL FOLKS
I CAME THE LEGISLATURE THIRTY
TWO YEARS AGO THIRTY TWO YEARS
AGO THIS IS A BIG DEAL THIRTY
TWO YEARS AGO- I KNOW MANY OF
YOU WONDERING KILEY G. THEY LET
PEOPLE IN HIGH SCHOOL ACTUALLY
COME TO THE ASSEMBLY- I WASN'T
QUITE HIGH SCHOOL BUT BUT- IT'S
BEEN. SUCH A LONG TIME SUCH A
DIVISIVE ISSUE AND I AM SO
GRATEFUL FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WORK SO HARD TO REACH THIS
COMPROMISE AND I KNOW WASN'T
EASY HE DID SO IN A WAY THAT
THAT REALLY- ELEVATES THE
PROCESS YOU DID SO IN A WAY THAT
EXEMPLIFIES WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT NOW I THINK TO HAVE A
MECHANISM FOR THE LEGISLATURE
ACTUALLY TO. INTERVENE WHEN
THERE IS A BALLOT PROPOSAL TO
RALEIGH I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FLEXIBILITY AND FOR YOUR
CATALYST TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION IN STILL- THIS IS A
THIS IS A FAIR COMPROMISE THIS
IS A LONG TERM SOLUTION THAT
ADDS PREDICTABILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY FOR MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL LIABILITY
INSURANCE- AND IT KEEPS HEALTH
CARE ACCESSIBLE AND AFFORDABLE
WHILE BALANCING APPROPRIATE
COMPENSATION FOR CALIFORNIANS.
EXPERIENCING HEALTH CARE RELATED
INJURY OR DEATH- THE RIGHTS OF
PATIENTS ARE PROTECTED WHILE
MICROCENTER GUARD RAILS REMAIN
IN PLACE THEREBY ENSURING BROAD
BASED HEALTH ACCESS- I'M PLEASE
. TO BE ABLE TO INTRODUCE A
WITNESSES EACH OF WHOM WILL
TESTIFY FOR ONE MINUTE- MISTER
CHARLES JOHNSON FIRST FOLLOWED
BY DR ROBERT WELLS MISTER NICK
RALEIGH OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA AND-
MISS LISA MAAS SO- MR JOHNSON IF
YOU APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
YOUR. ALL RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS CHARLES JOHNSON I AM
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE FAIRNESS FOR
INJURED PATIENTS ACT. MY WIFE
CURE JOHNSON WHO GAVE THE
ULTIMATE SACRIFICE GIVING THE
GIFT OF LIFE. AFTER THE BIRTH OF
OUR SON MAKES ISSUES LED TO
BLEED FOR TEN HOURS BY MYSELF IN
MY FAMILY BAGS FOR THE STAFF AT
CEDARS SINAI MEDICAL TO JUST
TAKE ACTION. THERE'S NEVER BEEN
A QUESTION ABOUT WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR MY WIFE'S DEATH
. THE ONLY QUESTION UNDER MY CAR
WAS WHETHER OR NOT MY FAMILY
WOULD RECEIVE THE JUSTICE THAT
WE DESERVE. I'M PROUD TO STAND
HERE TODAY IN SOLIDARITY. WITH
THIS GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS. TO
MAKE SURE THAT FAMILIES LIKE
MINE WILL RECEIVE ACCESS TO THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. NEXT WEEK MY
CASE AGAINST YOUR SON I WILL GO
TO TRIAL. THIS BILL WILL NOT
AFFECT MY CASE HOWEVER IT BRINGS
MY HEART JOY. AND I'M PROUD THAT
IT'S A PART OF MY WIFE'S LEGACY.
THAT OTHER FAMILIES WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO THE JUSTICE THAT WE'VE
BEEN DENIED. ON BEHALF OF MYSELF
ON BEHALF OF MY FRIEND. SCOTT
AND STEVEN OLSON ON BEHALF OF MY
FRIEND ME MARINO. WE'RE HONORED
TO STAND HERE IN SOLITARY WITH
YOU AND WHEN THIS BILL BECOMES
REALITY WE WILL GLADLY WITH FOR
OUR BALLOT MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JOHNSON- NOW
MOVING ON TO DOCTOR ROBERT OILS
FOR ONE MINUTE AS WELL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I
AM BOB WHALES I'M PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. AND REPRESENTING
AND ON BEHALF OF NEARLY FIFTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS I AM HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
FIVE. THIS MICROMANAGES ASIAN
LEGISLATION IS AN IMPORTANT
COMPROMISE THAT WILL EXTEND THE
LONG TERM PREDICTABILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY OF MEDICAL
LIABILITY INSURANCE. WHILE
PROVIDING FAIR COMPENSATION TO
INJURED PATIENTS. AMONG OTHER
ATTRIBUTES AB THIRTY FIVE
ESTABLISHES A NEW EVIDENTIARY
PROTECTION FOR PRE LITIGATION
EXPRESSIONS OF SYMPATHY REGRET
FOR NEVER ONCE AND EVEN
INCLUDING. A EXPRESSIONS OF
FAULT. INCLUDING THE BY A HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER THIS WILL MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR PHYSICIANS AND
PATIENTS TO HAVE A FULL AND OPEN
CONVERSATION AFTER AN UNFORESEEN
OUTCOME AND WILL LEAD TO GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY PATIENT SAFETY
AND TRUST. OFTEN A PATIENT'S
DECISION TO FILE A MEDICAL
MALPRACTICE LAWSUIT IS TRIGGERED
BY A FAILURE OF COMMUNICATION.
NOT NEGLIGENCE IN THIS BILL WILL
FACILITATE THE IMPORTANT
CONVERSATIONS PATIENTS AND
PROVIDERS WANT TO HAVE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU DR WELLS-
NEXTTO BE NICK RALLY FOR ONE
MINUTE AS WELL. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. I'M NICHOLAS
ROWLEY AND I'M KNOWN TO YOU AS A
TRIAL LAWYER AND THE PROPONENT
AND BACKER OF THE FAIRNESS FOR
INJURED PATIENTS ACT BUT WHAT I
ALSO MET M. AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
IS IT IS A FATHER. WHO LOST A
SON TO MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE. I AM
A HUMAN BEING A PERSON WHO'S
SEEN VICTIM AFTER VICTIM FAMILY
AFTER FAMILY OVER MY TWENTY YEAR
CAREER. EXPERIENCE THE
CONSEQUENCES. OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE LAW THAT HASN'T
CHANGED TO THE TUNE OF ONE
DOLLAR. TODAY WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT HIS HISTORIC
CHANGE. AND WHAT WE'VE WHAT
WE'VE DONE. IN THIS WORK THROUGH
CHAU SEE AND I MEAN MANY OF YOU
IT IT IS IT'S TAKEN THIS LONG
BUT WHAT WHAT WE'VE DONE AND
WHAT WE'RE DOING. IS WE'RE
TAKING DOWN A BERLIN WALL THAT'S
EXISTED IN CALIFORNIA FOR ALMOST
FIFTY YEARS. THOSE WHO OUR
ENEMIES ARE NOW GOING TO BE
ALLIES AND I'M PROUD OF THAT I
AM PROUD OF THAT THERE'S SO MUCH
WORK. THAT WE CAN DO TOGETHER
MEAN ROE VERSUS WADE IS BEING
OVERTURNED THERE'S- NO A WAR ON
WOMEN'S RIGHTS THEIR THEIR STUFF
WE CAN DO TOGETHER. THERE'S SO
MUCH WE CAN DO TOGETHER. AND
THIS IS A GREAT BEGINNING. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND WE WILL WITHDRAW
THE BALLOT MEASURE WHEN THIS
BILL IS PASSED. THANK YOU THIS
MONTH'S. I'M LISA MAAS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIANS ALLIED
FOR PATIENT PROTECTION WE'RE A
DIVERSE COALITION OF MORE THAN
ONE THOUSAND ORGANIZATIONS
DEDICATED TO PRESERVING AND
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE THROUGH
MICRO. BEFORE MICRO THE COST OF
PRACTICING MEDICINE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH SKYROCKETING
CAUSING HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS TO
LIMIT THEIR SERVICES OR PERHAPS
MOVE OUT OF STATE. MICRA HELPED
ESTABLISH GUARDRAILS THAT
CONTROLLED COSTS AND KEPT
HEALTHCARE ACCESSIBLE WHICH IS
WHY CALIFORNIA DOCTORS NURSES
HOSPITALS COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS AND MANY OTHERS JOINED
TOGETHER TO PROTECT MICRA. THIS
PROPOSAL WILL END A DECADES LONG
CONFLICT AND AVOID A COSTLY
BALLOT MEASURE THAT WOULD HAVE
SEVERELY DAMAGED OUR SAFETY NET
PROVIDERS AND COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS TO SERVE CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE PATIENTS. OUR
COALITION IS A PROUD SPONSOR OF
AB THIRTY FIVE BECAUSE IT WILL
KEEP HEALTHCARE ACCESSIBLE AND
AFFORDABLE WHILE ENSURING THAT
PATIENTS AND FAMILIES ARE CARED
FOR AND SUPPORTED I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON A. B.
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR-
PROPONENTS AND WITH SPEAKING
ROLES NOW MOVING ON TO FOLKS IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED WISHING TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT IF YOU COULD
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR- EXPRESSIONS
TO YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION PLEASE. YOU CAN LINE UP
BEFORE. AND THEN AS A STEP
FORWARD. CRAIG PETERS I'M
PRESIDENT OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU. I AM TRAVELING WITH TRITON
PRICE REPRESENTING BLACK WOMEN
FOR WELLNESS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ROBERT CARRILLO WITH THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THIS
COMPROMISE. JEFF RAN OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. JENNIFER SNYDER BEHALF
FOR THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH FACILITIES IN
SUPPORT IS COMPROMISED THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANYONE ANYONE ELSE- IN
ROOM TWO HUNDRED WISHING TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT. SEE NOW MOVING
ON TO THE TELEPHONE LINES-
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE QUEUE FOR THOSE WISHING TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT ON A. B. THIRTY
FIVE. AND ONCE YOU HAVE A TALLY
OF THOSE IN Q. CAN LET'S KNOW
WHAT THAT IS AS WE REMIND OUR
FOLKS. THAT THEY'RE ONLY ALLOWED
TO IDENTIFY THEMSELVES BY NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. THEM
MODERATE CAN YOU ALSO SET THE Q.
CLOCK FOR FIFTEEN MINUTES. IF
YOU AND IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. BERMAN HE. LOOKS LIKE
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TWENTY FIVE IN
Q. AND IF YOU'RE READY I'LL GO
WITH THE FIRST PERSON. YES
PLEASE IF THAT'S LINE ONE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY MY
FIFTEEN YEAR OPEN. BERMAN THE
LINE OF ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
WHEN THE GOING TO THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND SUPPORT YOU.
IF YOU WERE MOVED TO LINE. ONE
NINE- COMPARTMENT ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER PROTECTION POLICY
CENTER AT UFC FOUR O'CLOCK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WILL LIVE TO ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN SPECIALTY
CARE COALITION AND SUPPORT EACH
YEAR. THE LINE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE FIVE. FIVE BELIEVE THE
CALIFORNIA WORKED THE COURT. TWO
NINE SEVENTY TWO. RIGHT SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. STONE STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WHAT THE TICKET THIS
SEASON IN FORT. THANK YOU LINE.
FIFTY SIX FIVE. WILLIFORD CHANGE
FOR SOMEONE AND WILL SUPPORT.
AND LINE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHARE WASH THE EXAT
DIRECTOR OF CHANGE FOR SEAN AND
I BELIEVE THE POOR EIGHTY THIRTY
FIVE. THANK YOU LINE. PLEASE
DON'T HANG. MICHELLE MONTARA
RAMU FROM A CONSUMER WATCHDOG
STRONG SUPPORT AB THIRTY FIVE
ALONG WITH THE FAMILY THANK YOU
. THANK YOU LINE EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
TAMMY ETHNIC THE CONSUMER
WATCHDOG IN MEMORY OF MY SON
ALEX THANK I FULLY SUPPORT AB
THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU. EIGHTY
NINE ONE TWENTY NINE FEET THE
HEAD. HELLO MISTER CRYPTOGRAM
PURCHASES DON'T WANT TO BE
CALLED ON BEHALF DOCTORS COMPANY
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
IT'S NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. TRICIA MCMILLAN A PATIENT
BLINDED BY MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE
AND AFFILIATED WITH CONSUMER
WATCHDOG AND FULL SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU AND
ACTIVISM EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHEN HE- YES I'M LAURA
ALEXANDER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
BILLIONS LEGACY AND I COMPLETELY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
LINE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AN ECONOMY CONSUMER
WATCHDOG YES I SUPPORT AB THIRTY
FIVE. IF YOU ADELINE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY AIRY
. NOW AND THEN HERE TO CONTINUE
WATCHED IN HONOR OF MY ASSURE
THEORY WHO AWAY UNITED
CONNECTION EXTRA SUPPORT AB
THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME ALICE MORGAN I'M
ON THE FOR CHANGE SOME. ARE
STRONG COOLEY COOPER. EIGHT
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU LINE
NINETY PLEASE GO. HI MY IS
LYNETTE ROMERO I IT WAS CONSUMER
. I WOULD WATER MEDICAL NETWORK
AND THEN NOW EIGHT AUDIENCE WILL
. I STRONGLY THE FIVE. ITS
RECORD ITS NECK THANK YOU
AIRLINE A ONE PLEASE GUIDE. MY
NAME IS SELL. MY PRESS MOTHER
RAIN BECAUSE WITH THEM NOT THE-
SHE DIED A DIRECT RESULT OF
ORANGE. I STAND FIRM BUT CAN
WHAT IN FULL OF TWO FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LINE FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES MA'AM YES MA'AM
YEAH OKAY THANK YOU MY NAME IS
DR DARLENE WILLIS. AND IN HONOR
OF MY NEPHEW SEAN IT WOULD
WASHINGTON THE SECOND WHO DIED
DUE TO MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE THE
SYSTEMIC RACISM HEALTHCARE I
BELIEVE THE PORT ALONG WITH OUR
FAMILIES. EIGHTY THIRTY FIVE AND
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING IT. IF
YOU WANT ONE THIRTY. OKAY I AM
SORRY GLOVE I HAVE WORKED THE
LAST TEN YEARS WITH THE CONSUMER
WATCHDOG AND IN MEMORY OF MY SON
ADAM GLOVER WHO IS TWELVE I
FULLY SUPPORT AB THIRTY FIVE.
THANK YOU I NINETY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CLAIRE MCCORMACK ON
BEHALF OF MY DAUGHTER NORA
BOSTROM WHO DIED FROM MEDICAL.
THANK YOU LINE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
DEBORAH YOUNG AND I AM ON THE
BOARD CHANGE PERCHERON I HIGHLY
SUPPORT- SB THIRTY FIVE. AND
MEMORY OF MY NEPHEWS JOHN
WASHINGTON. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND OUR NEXT LINE IS SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MASON BY POLICE
. NO I WITH CONSUMERS MUCH ON
HERE OFF WATCH. REPORT THIS IN
MEMORY OF MY MOTHER WHO DIED OF
MEDICAL ANIMALS. AT IN HONOR OF
THE TOWN. PAID MILLION FOR ME TO
BE ABLE TO. MEDICAL YOUR. I AM.
SO I'M I'M VERY HAPPY THAT IS
COME THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS DIANA WORKING AND THIS IS IN
- MY SHOT IT WILL WORKING TO
COULD BACK AND WHO DID NOT GET
SAME. TRAINING IN THE BACK I'M
SO. POLICE OF. FORTY FIVE. THANK
YOU SOME- LINE ONE- OH ONE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JOHNSON OF
WHILE WITH YOU CAN SIMMER WATCH
OR- HELLO MY RICHER CANNELLA
NECK. AND I STRONGLY A B- FIVE.
THANK YOU THINK. THANK YOU AIR
THIRTY NINE PLEASE AHEAD. YOU'RE
BORN REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
DIVISION OF THE ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS ONE STRONG. THANK YOU
LINE FIFTY THREE PUT GO AHEAD.
THANK. THREE WILL MOVE TO LINE
ONE FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M VALERIE
MCGINTY THE FOUNDER OF FUND HER
AND WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO
ONE I THINK YOU. THAT ONE FINAL
SHOT OUT MODERATOR PLEASE. YES
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. OKAY HE WHAT. LINE EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT. NINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
. I'M SORRY THERE WAS AN ERROR
FOR FIFTY SIX OKAY THANK YOU THE
BLIND AT ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M THIRTY NINE YEAR
OPEN. FORMAL TO LINE ONE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO AND I
AM RETURNING FROM SAY THE MOM
SAID THE FAMILY YEAH ME AND
MALACHITE FOUNDATION AND I AM
FULLY SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FIVE
THANK YOU IN HONOR OF THEM THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND THAT WAS THE
LAST THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR. I BELIEVE THERE
IS NO OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON
FILE HAS THAT CHANGED. ALL
RIGHTS NOW MOVING INTO THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED- PLEASE-
COME FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF BY NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION. ALL RIGHT. MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
TELEPHONE LINES DO WE HAVE ANY
FOLKS IN THE QUEUE WISHING TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY
FIVE. THANK YOU THEIR POSTS. THE
AB THIRTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO. NO ONE ISSUE AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WITH
THAT BEING CONDUCTED- WE ARE NOW
MOVING IN THIS MATTER BRING IT
BEFORE THE DAIS CENTER LAYERED
AND INCINERATES BURKE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR. ACTUALLY IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR I WAS
HIRED TO BE THE HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SERVICES ANALYST FOR THE
COUNTY ADMINISTRATOR IN SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY AT THE TIME SENATOR-
BURKE REALLY WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL
. AND THE INTERESTING THING WAS
AS WE FACED RIGHT AWAY THE FACT
THAT. DOCTORS WERE GOING THEIR-
OWN INSURANCE THAT WERE OBGYN
SAYS A. COUNTY WE WERE HIRING
NURSE MIDWIVES TO TRY TO
CONTINUE THE SERVICES THE CRISIS
THAT MICROCOSM FROM. WHETHER
THEY'RE STILL DEBATE ABOUT
WHETHER WAS MANIPULATED IN SOME
WAY BUT WAS REAL. AND YET WHEN
THE CAP WAS ENACTED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE THE PURCHASING
POWER IS NOW SOMETHING LIKE 25%
OF WHAT THAT SAME AMOUNT WAS. IN
THAT YEAR AND FOR THOSE OF US
HERE ARE WE'VE EXPERIENCED THIS
AS A POLITICAL FAULT LINE IT TOO
WHEN I RAN FOR THE LEGISLATURE
IN TWENTY TEN THERE WAS A MAJOR
INDEPENDENT EXPENDITURE AGAINST
ME BECAUSE I ADVOCATED INDEXING
THIS JUST INDEXING GET. BEEN IN
TWENTY TWENTY MY POSITION WAS
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE AT THE TABLE
TO DISCUSS THIS AND GET TO A
SOLUTION AND THAT IS WHAT
HAPPENED THAT IS WHAT HAS
HAPPENED HERE. AND IT IS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT THIS IS A
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE AND IT IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK ALL OF US
HAD ALWAYS HOPED FOR BUT NEVER
THOUGHT WAS TRUE IMPOSSIBLE.
THEN SO I REALLY SALUTE EVERYONE
BECAUSE- HEY YOU COULD NEVER
KEEP A SECRET IN SACRAMENTO AND
THIS WAS FOR SOME REASON CAPT
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME. BUT
THERE WAS A LOT OF RISK TAKING
HERE. MY SUSPICION IS IF THIS
PROPOSAL HAD BEEN LEAKED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PROCESS. ARE
THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN A NUMBER
OF GROUPS THAT TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT THAT WOULD HAD A REAL
TOUGH TIME HOLDING THEIR
CONSTITUENTS TOGETHER FOR IT.
AND I THINK WHEN THERE WAS A
GIVE AND TAKE THAT WAS REALLY
GOOD AND REALLY EVERYBODY GOT
SOMETHING OUT OF IT AND IT WAS
ENOUGH FOR THE INITIATIVE NOT TO
GO. TO NOVEMBER IT IS A MASSIVE
VICTORY AND IT IS SOMETHING THAT
HI HOPE BECAUSE THERE IS SOME
FLEXIBILITY AND HOW THIS WILL.
WILL INDEX GOING FORWARD THAT
THIS REMOVED SAYS AN ISSUE EVEN
AND YEARS OR FURTHER ALTHOUGH OF
COURSE THE LEGISLATURE ALWAYS
HAS THE RIGHT. TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE AND
SEE IF THEY WARRANT. ANY
CONSIDERATION. AND I WAS ALL SET
AT THIS MOMENT. TO SPEAK TO
THOSE THAT OPPOSED TO THE
MEASURE. OF WHICH THERE WERE
NONE. BECAUSE I WAS PREPARED TO
SAY AND EVEN IF THERE'S ONE OUT
THERE LISTENING. IS THAT
BASICALLY. WHATEVER THE POSITION
WAS THAT PEOPLE HAD SO STRONGLY
THAT THEY WOULD OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE IS THE REASON THERE
NEVER BEEN A SOLUTION SINCE IT
WAS ENACTED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE. THAT IT REALLY TOOK SOME
GIVE AND TAKE IT RALLY TOOK
EVERYBODY PROTECTING THEIR OWN
INTERESTS SO THAT. THE PROVIDERS
FEEL SOME LEVEL OF PROTECTION
BUT CONSUMERS ABSOLUTELY GET A
LEVEL OF PROTECTION AND
EVERYBODY ELSE THAT'S A
STAKEHOLDER WAS INVOLVED IN
THIS. SO I JUST I AM PROUD TO BE
A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF THIS.
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU. THAT
WONDER WHY. IN THE NEXT WEEK I
WILL BE PRESENTING A BILL ON THE
SENATE FLOOR THAT IS ABOUT. TWO
DIFFERENT FONTS OF THE PENAL
CODE IT'S BECAUSE I WAS HOLDING
IT FOR THIS PURPOSE IT AND SO I
THINK IT WILL. IT WILL- MAYBE
CENTER DRAWS SO WE'LL GET HER
LABOR BILL ON CLIMATE OUT OF THE
PHONE BILLS OR SOMETHING WILL
HAPPEN BUT I JUST WANT TO SALUTE
EVERYBODY THERE IT IS AMAZING
AND- AND IT FOR ANYONE THAT
SAYS. SACRAMENTO DOESN'T WORK.
AFTER WE PASS THIS BILL AND
SIGNED INTO LAW WE SHOULD POINT
EVERYBODY TO THIS BECAUSE OF THE
COMPROMISE THAT WAS MADE AND
EVERYBODY'S HANDS IN. IN THE
FACT THAT IT WAS DONE IN A WAY
THAT NOT A PERSONAL POSTED IT IN
THIS HEARING SO AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. ASSEMBLY
WILLING TO MOVE THIS I'M PROUD
TO BE A PRINCIPAL CALL THANK YOU
CENTER LAYERED AND I WAS
PREPARED TO PAY FOR YOUR PHONE
BILL. AS A BILL THROUGH
COMMITTEE. MOVING ON TO CENTER
HERTZBERG CONSIDER WHAT CASK. I
WANT TO JUST IF I COULD THE- SAN
LAYERED TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
SECOND WORKING. IN OUR
GOVERNMENT WORKING I DO AGREE
WITH THE HISTORY BECAUSE WHEN
YOU'RE AT A POINT IN HISTORY ONE
REFLECT ON THOSE WHO WERE HERE
BEFORE AND WITH THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS WERE BUT I THINK.
ONE OF THE IMPORTANT ASPECTS
THAT ISN'T INFORMED BY. THE
SUBJECT MATTER WE HAVE BEFORE US
BUT IS FUNDAMENTAL TO MAKING
GOVERNMENT WORK. IS THIS EFFORT
BY SENATOR STEINBERG CENTER
VIDEO CENTER DELEON SOME YEARS
AGO IN COORDINATION WITH JUSTICE
ROSSO INJURED CHIEF JUSTICE
STRONG GEORGIAN OTHERS. IT
BROUGHT BACK THIS INDIRECT
INITIATIVE WHEN MR RALLY FAR
FOOTBALLER NICK FULL OF FILED
THIS MEASURE UNDER THE LAW
BEFORE THE WOULD HAVE BEEN NO
OPPORTUNITY FOR THERE TO BE
DISCUSSION BECAUSE ONCE THOSE
BOXES OF SIGNATURES WHEN ACROSS
THE DESK- THEY THEY WERE- HE WAS
ON THE MEASURE WAS ON THE BALLOT
THAT WAS THE LAW. CURRENTLY
BEING USED TO ALWAYS BE LONG
CALIFORNIA AND SO I THINK THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR A MOMENT TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF THAT
PROCESS SO THAT IT ALLOWS FOR
DISCUSSION BETWEEN A PROPONENT.
OF A AND THE ADVOCATES THE
LEGISLATURE THE PROCESS TO TRY
TO GET THE LAW RIGHT BUT I THINK
THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT THING
TO RECOGNIZE IN THAT LARGER
DYNAMIC. ALSO THIS YOU KNOW THE
POINT THAT WAS MADE ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED SEVENTY FOUR CERTAINLY
WE CAN'T FORGET HELEN THOMPSON
WHO IS A MEMBER OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE YOU CHANGE YOURSELF TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK SOME YEARS
AGO AND SEVENTY FIVE. DOLLARS
AND REPORTER ONE TROUBLE PASSED
AWAY RECENTLY AND OTHERS WHO
WERE PART OF THAT WOULD BE
BROWN'S G. THOMPSON AND OTHERS
WERE PART OF THE HISTORY- THAT
IT FOR THIS AND THAT IS BEING
BEFORE TODAY. AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO TAKE A MOMENT AGAIN
ALSO PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE. REALLY REALLY PROUD OF
THE WORK THAT THE ALL THE
ADVOCATES CAME TOGETHER THE
CATALYST THANK YOU PROVIDE TO
MAKE THIS HAPPEN TO YOU YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND HOW GIGANTIC OF THE
ROLE YOU PLAYED IN ALL OF THE
STUFF. YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF HOW
THIS DISPLACED WORKS AND SO YOU
KNOW HE'S GOING TO GIVE CREDIT
TO OTHERS AND I WANT TO A ONE OH
TO THE EXTENT SEND A MESSAGE TO
FUTURE LEGISLATORS. THAT THINK
ABOUT THE PROCESS- THINK
CIVILITY TO REMOTE TO CREATE
THIS INDIRECT INITIATIVE AS A
TOOL LIKE WE DID WITH- BUDGETS
THAT WE WANT 250% PLUS ONE WHAT
WE DID ON TERM LIMITS- CENTER
DRIVE SO AND OTHER THINGS THAT
WERE DONE. A RAINY DAY FUNDS.
AND THINGS LIKE THAT IN THE
OFFICE THE BIG GUY. COM FOR THE
CHOIR. ON EXCITING STUFF THAT
DOESN'T YOU ON THE PHONE PAGE
THE NEWSPAPER. PUT THAT IN FOR.
THE LET'S. AND GOVERNMENT
PROCESS IN A WAY. THAT ALLOWS
THINGS TO HAPPEN LIKE WHAT'S
HAPPENED HERE TODAY IS THE
RESULT OF THE HARD WORK. OF
FANCY TRAVELLING THE ENTRAPMENT
IS. LISA MARSHALL OTHERS THAT
ARE HERE THAT FELT REALLY GOT
INTO INTO THE PROCESS AND- SO I
JUST WANNA THANK EVERYBODY AND-
YOU KNOW TO NOT FORGET THE
HISTORY FROM WHERE WE COME. AND
THE LESSON ABOUT GOVERNMENT
REFORM HAS VALUE BECAUSE EVEN
THOUGH IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE IT'S
A BIG DEAL WHEN IT HAPPENS IT
MANIFESTS ITSELF. IN IN DAYS
LIKE TODAY SO THAT TO ALSO
PARTICIPATES THE AUTHORS BOTH
HOUSES. I APPRECIATE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THE HAVE THE
TIME TO ESPECIALLY OPINION THANK
YOU. SIR WHAT BECAUSE HE THEN
SENATOR ALSO. BROUGH TOLD
PROPONENTS PROBABLY TO THE
PROCESS. BRAVO TO THE BALLOT
HOLDER I THOUGHT THE STAFF
REPORT WHISKEY. WHEN WE WHEN YOU
BACK TO JURY ONE FIRST THE
SECOND DAY OF SESSION HE HAS
SENDS A NINE POINT- EXTRA A
REQUEST FOR AN EXTRAORDINARY
SESSION TO COME IN AND- PEOPLE
FORGET HOW THINGS WORK IN THE-
IN THE SEVENTIES. AS FAR AS
GETTING IT DONE MY QUESTION GOES
TO TWO QUESTIONS FIRST IS TO THE
FEES. WE GOT A BUNCH OF LAWYERS
HAVE ALREADY SIGNED CONTRACTS
FOR PEOPLE THERE IN SOME OF SOME
OF THESE CASES TAKE. TWO THREE
TEN YEARS. THIS THEY GET TO STAY
GET TO JUDGMENT THEY GO TO TRIAL
THEY GO THERE THEY'VE GOT A FEW
GREEN WHICH IS INCONSISTENT WITH
WHAT THE NEW LAW WOULD BE WHAT
HAPPENS PRACTICALLY. DESCRIPTION
THE DESCRIPTION. I'D LIKE TO
ELLSBERG I'D LIKE TO L. SHOULD
ONLY ASSUME WAGNER THE GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR CMA. GOOD AFTERNOON
NDER AB THIRTY FIVE THE
ATTORNEYS FEES CHANGES WILL GO
INTO EFFECT ON JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. SO THEY
WOULD IMPACT EXISTING CASES D.
THAT CHANGES TO THE CAP ON NON
ECONOMIC DAMAGES WILL ONLY APPLY
TO CASES FILED ON OR AFTER
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY THREE
. EXCELLENT THAT CAN ANSWER THAT
QUESTION BUT SHE SAID RIGHT AND
THEN THE THREE CATEGORIES THE
THREE CARE CATEGORIES- AS FAR AS
A CAUSE OF ACTION. BASICALLY
SAME QUESTION YOU HAVE CASES
THAT ARE GOING ON NOW THAT YOU
HAVE ONE MATT MEDICAL
MALPRACTICE JUDGMENT FOR AN
INSTITUTION A NOT IN. AN
INDIVIDUAL PLAN OF. AND LET'S
SAY YOU'RE STILL IN TRIAL CAN
YOU AMEND YOUR COMPLAINT- ON
JANUARY SECOND TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. NO THE AB THIRTY FIVE-
STATES EXPRESSLY THAT THE NEW
CAP STRUCTURE ONLY APPLIES TO A
CIVIL ACTIONS FILED IN DEMAND
FOR ARBITRATION MADE ON OR AFTER
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
SO IT'S IT DOESN'T APPLY TO
CASES THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
PIPELINE IF YOU WELL. AND THAT
IS. INTENDED TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE BUILD UP THE TEN YEAR
WALK UP STRUCTURE IT WAS A KEY
COMPONENT OF THIS NEGOTIATION.
SO THAT FOR THE A PRACTITIONER
THE ONLY THING THAT WOULD.
TEMPER THAT IS WHEN YOUR ONE
YEAR BECAUSE OF ACTION EXPIRES
THAT YOU HAVE TO FILE YOUR CASE
RIGHT. I MEAN I WOULD IMAGINE IF
SOMEBODY'S INJURED RIGHT NOW HE
WOULD HAVE THAT THERE BE
MOTIVATION TO WAIT TILL. TWENTY
TWENTY THREE OBVIOUSLY. OKAY IS
PRESUMABLY A- PRISON. THANK YOU.
THOSE ARE ALL MY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU SENATOR OTHER THAN CENTER
JONES. I JUST WANT TO SAY
CONGRATULATIONS TO EVERYONE WHO
PUT THE TIME AND THE ENERGY INTO
IT. AND IT'S A IT'S A LESSON TO
THAT NOT ALL OF THE BEST
SOLUTIONS COME THROUGH
GOVERNMENT. OF DOING THIS
PROCESS THAT- FROM THAT KIND OF
PRIVATE CONVERSATION AMONGST
THE- NON GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES
WHO HAVE THE MOST. AT STAKE- ARE
IN THE BEST POSITION TO COME UP
WITH SOMETHING THAT. CAN BE
MOVED FORWARD SO CONGRATULATIONS
. THANK YOU SIR JONES ACTUALLY
CENTER DRAWS ARE TOOK MY
COMMENTS SO I WILL- A SECOND HER
COMMENTS AND THEN ALSO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES BUT-
SCENARIOS. SYNDROME BURKE
CONGRADULATIONS SUMMARIES WE
SPOKE ABOUT BEING ADDED ON AS A
CO AUTHOR LAST WEEK SO- UNLESS I
HAD BEEN DONE YET I STILL WOULD
LIKE TO BE ADDED ON AS A CO
AUTHOR. AFTER THIS GREAT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I THINK THERE'S OTHER-
SENATORS THAT WANT TO BE ADDED
ON TO THAT THING A CHANCE TO BE
A- CENTER WINNER. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- FOR SO I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE STAKEHOLDERS TO-
AFTER DECADES OF A TRENCH
WARFARE CAME TOGETHER AND
DECIDED TO RESOLVE- TO RESOLVE
THIS ISSUE AND- I. THESE FIGHTS
CAN BECOME BECOME PERSONAL- I
DON'T KNOW THIS ONE IN
PARTICULAR HAS JUST BEEN SO
INTENSEFOR SO LONG BUT I
WONDERED IF IT WAS EVER GOING TO
BE RESOLVED I THINK ALL OF US
WHO GAVE ANY THOUGHT TO THIS
COMPRISED THINKING TWENTY
DIFFERENT WAYS TO COMPROMISE ON
MY GROUND I ALWAYS. WONDERED WHY
THERE WASN'T A COMPROMISE LIKE
FROM THE TIME I STARTED RUNNING
FOR THE SENATE AND REALLY
STARTED FOCUSING MORE ON MY CRY
WAS ALWAYS LIKELY TO SEEMS LIKE
SO RIGHT FOR A COMPROMISE BUT
THE WAR WAS JUST SO INTENSE AND
SO I REALLY WANT TO COMMEND
EVERYONE WHO PUT ALL OF THAT
HISTORY ASIDE AND ALL THE PAIN
RIGHT BECAUSE MANY THINKWHAT MY
CREDIT IS IT'S ABOUT SITUATIONS
WHERE SOMEONE CAUSES SOMEONE
ELSE FORM- OFTEN. DEADLY HARM OR
THE MOST SEVERE LIKE LIFE
PERMANENT LIFE ALTERING HARMS
AND VERY VERY PERSONAL- FOR
EVERYONE. AND SO I'M JUST REALLY
GRATEFUL THAT EVERYONE PUT THAT
TO THE SIDE AS PAINFUL AND HARD
AS IT WAS IN CAME TOGETHER. SO
LET'S DO SOMETHING FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. TO TAKE
THIS ALMOST FIFTY YEAR OLD LOG
MODERNIZE IT AND ALL UP TO YOU
TO. MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE HARMED- CAN ACTUALLY GET
REASONABLE- COMPENSATION AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT- WE ACTUALLY ARE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO FULLY
PROVIDE. HEALTH CARE SERVICES AT
ALL INCOME LEVELS IN THE STATE
I'M SORRY JUST ONE AGAIN SAID
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO BE A
CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE WISH TO COMMENT. I
HAVE NOT DONE SO PRIOR. SEEING
NONE- SYNDROME BURKE SIMMER
REYES- FINAL COMMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU AGAIN SOME IN THE RACE
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE- A COUPLE OF BRIEF
THOUGHTS BEFORE SAID WHITE HOUSE
USING OF THE QUESTIONS. WE WANT
TO DELAY THINGS. THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE OF GOVERNMENT WORKING
AND I'M PROUD TO BE PART OF THAT
EXAMPLE GOVERNMENT WORKING- IN
THIS IS A SPECIAL THANK YOU TO
MR JOHNSON. FOR COMING FORWARD
ANDUSING YOUR GRIEF. AS A TOOL
TO BRING FOLKS TOGETHER SO THANK
YOU TO YOU AND ALL THOSE WHO
CALLED IN WHO. DISCUSSED AND
REVEALED AND USE THAT GRIEF TO
MOVE THIS PROCESS FORWARD SO
THANK YOU TO ALL- IN WITH THAT
ALLERGEN I VOTE. ALL RIGHTY WE
HAVE A MOTION EARLIER MADE BY
CENTER LAYER TO MOVE THE
APOLOGIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK
YOU I DIDN'T WANT CENTER ON
BURKE TO GIVE HIS CLOTHES FIRST
I ALSO WANT TO THANK. ALL THOSE
WHO PARTICIPATED WAS A LOT OF
WORK. AND IT WAS WORK THAT YOU
ALL DID BECAUSE YOU KNEW HOW
IMPORTANT THE ISSUE WAS YOU KNEW
THAT THERE WAS NO MORE REASON
FOR THERE TO BE. ENEMIES SO TO
SPEAK. WE ALL NEED TO BE ON THE
SAME ON THE SAME PAGE AND I AM
EVER SO GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU ALL PUT IN- SENATOR OR
WHAT WIENER WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE PAIN THAT IT TOOK. AND NOW
YOU'RE PROVIDING FOR THAT PAIN
AND SUFFERING FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
FOR SO LONG NOT BEEN ABLE TO BE
COMPENSATED. AB THIRTY FIVE.
REFLECTS THE HISTORIC AGREEMENT
THAT SERVES AS A REMINDER. AND
AS A MODEL. THAT WE CAN OVERCOME
WHAT WAS ONCE. INSURMOUNTABLE
DISAGREEMENTS. IN ORDER TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS. AND WITH THAT I
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT- CENTER LAYERED HAVING
MOVED TO THE BILL- IN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS CHIEF COUNSEL TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL- THIS IS AB
THIRTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES AND SENATOR UMBERG OF WITH
THE MOTION BY SENATOR IT LAYERED
THE MOTION IS TO PASS- BURKE. I
REMEMBER I BURGESS HI PORTICI
CABALLERO W. AT ALL I THE
RUSSELL THE RUSSELL I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE JONES I JONES I LAYERED AYE
LAYERED AYE STERN AYE STERN AYE
WHITE HOUSE HE- CASKEY I WE-
WIENER AYE THAT ELEVEN TWO ZERO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THAT BILL IS
OUT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT AWAY TO COME BACK
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH IS
CURRENTLY ON CALL SO- AND SHE
COUNTS OF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR GO YET- ON
THE CONTRARY CALENDAR. ZERO
COPYRIGHT. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
STERN HI STERN AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE YOU HAVE ELEVEN TWO
ZERO ALL MEMBERS VOTING. ALL
RIGHT CONSENT COUNTERS BEEN
ADOPTED ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
TAKE THINGS A LITTLE BIT OUT OF
ORDER HERE- CENTREBOARD JUST
SORT OF TAKE UP CENTER BOARD
THIS IS BILL NEXT. WHICH IS S.
B. ONE ONE. ONE EIGHT FILE
NUMBER NUMBER- NINE CENTREBOARD
JUST GO AHEAD THANK YOU. OKAY
THERE WE GO GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT S. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN A BILL THAT
SEEKS TO CODIFY LANGUAGE FROM
THE KERNEL OR JUST JUST BEFORE
YOU GET TOO FAR AS YOUR DID YOU
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AB
ABSOLUTELY ALL RIGHT THANK ITEM
AS WELL OKAY. ALL RIGHT SO
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN IS A BILL THAT
SEEKS TO CODIFY LANGUAGE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT'S
DECISION IN NEIGHBORS FOR SMART
RAIL VERSUS EXPOSITION METROLINE
CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY. FIRST I
WANT TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR
PROFUSELY. OUR WORK WORKING WITH
ME TO GET THIS MEASURE TO WHERE
IT IS TODAY. THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON PAGES
ELEVEN TWELVE OF THE ANALYSIS
WHICH I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT WILL
FURTHER CLARIFY OR ADD CLARITY
TO THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT. THROUGH
CONVERSATIONS WITH COMMITTEE AND
STAFF ELEVEN EIGHTEEN CODIFIES
LANGUAGE FROM THE SUPREME COURT
CASE. IN WHICH THE SUPREME COURT
UPHELD THE PRINCIPLE THAT
INSUBSTANTIAL OR MERELY
TECHNICAL VIOLATIONS. ARE NOT
GROUNDS FOR RELIEF. THIS CHANGE
WILL MAKE IT CLEAR TO STATE
AGENCIES AND THE COURTS THAT
MINOR INCONSEQUENTIAL VIOLATIONS
OF SYKORA WILL NOT BE GROUNDS
FOR RELIEF AND THAT ABSOLUTE
PERFECTION IN PREPARING AN
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENT IS NOT A
REQUIREMENT UNDER SEQUEL. THE
CALIFORNIA BAR MIDDLE QUALITY
ACT WAS ENACTED OVER FIFTY YEARS
AGO TO ENSURE THAT STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES CONSIDER THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF THEIR
DECISIONS WHEN APPROVING PUBLIC
OR PRIVATE PROJECTS. AND WHILE
THIS LAW HAS UNDOUBTEDLY DONE AN
EXCELLENT JOB IN PROTECTING AND
CONSERVING THE STATE'S NATURAL
RESOURCES IT IS ALSO BEEN USED
TO FACILITATE COSTLY IN NEEDLESS
LITIGATION- FOR. ENVIRONMENTALLY
ON RELATED TECHNICAL MISTAKES.
AS OTHERS HAVE SAID THIS IS NOT
AN EARTH SHATTERING BILL WE KNOW
THAT ELEVEN EIGHTEEN SIX TO
BRING HARMONY TO CALIFORNIA'S
COURTS AND UPHOLD THE CRUCIAL
PRINCIPLE. THAT INSTANCE
INSUBSTANTIAL WERE TECHNICAL
VIOLATIONS ARE NOT THEMSELVES
GROUND FOR RELIEF UNDER SEQUEL.
IN TODAY'S ENVIRONMENT IS
CRITICAL WE FIND THE BALANCE
BETWEEN PROTECTING OUR STATE AND
MANAGE THE ONGOING HOUSING
CHALLENGES WE ARE CURRENTLY
FACING- WE HAVE NO BY
INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL BE SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT- TODAY- SO WE COULD
JUST OPEN IT UP IF IT SECURES
DESIRE TO THE PUBLIC OUR- THE
THIRD- PRINCIPAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT. IT- THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED IF YOU APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. SIX ALL RIGHT A
SINGLE ONE IN THE CHAMBER- THOSE
ON THE PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT IF
YOU WOULD QUEUE THEM UP
MODERATOR. IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. MAMA
MAINLY HAVE ONE WITH AN AXE. WE
HAVE TO TAKE IT UP THE FIRST ONE
IS LINE ONE FOURTEEN B. O. S.
HELLO HI EXACTLY YEAH PLEASE GO
AHEAD FIVE. A YEAR I AM VERY
MARKET ON DIANA I AM PROUD FIRST
. MY FINANCIAL IS WHAT. NEGATIVE
ENDED UP PLEADING OUT- CAL
WATCHING THE SENATE IN THE GET
TO SEE A BABY GIRL WHO. A THREE
LATER I'M VERY VERY MUCH
ACCORDING TO. THAT HAS A
DIFFERENT VIEW OFTEN MUCH DENTAL
OKAY. FOURTEEN HELLO WE'RE ON
FILE I NINE S. B. ONE ONE EIGHT
BY FORTUS TO SECEDE FOR. A AS
AMEND. ARE THERE OTHERS ON THE
PHONE LINE THAT HAVE COMMON OR-
BUT TO SIX COMMITTEE ON S. B.
ONE ONE. ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU
AND ONE MOMENT. WE HAVE A LINE
OF FOUR FIVE PLEASE OKAY. HELLO
MY NAME IS THE ID I AM FROM ANTI
COULD CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT AB
THREE FIVE OR WITH A CHAIN FOR
SHAUNA NONPROFIT IT STARTED EVER
SHOW MUCH IN THE SECOND HE DIED
UNDER. MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE THE
SYSTEMATIC RACISM HEALTHCARE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OKAY. AUDIO
ARE PEOPLE ON THE LINE THIS IS
THIS IS A SEQUEL. BILL S. B. ONE
ONE EIGHT WE HAVE ALREADY VOTED
ON ELEVEN ZERO ON AB THIRTY FIVE
SO NO MORE AB THIRTY FIVE. NEXT
CALLER. THERE'S NO ONE I THINK
YOU THERE OKAY LET'S TURN
OPPOSITION I HAVE NO FORMAL
OPPOSITION TO- AB. R. S. B. ONE
ONE ONE EIGHT- OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT ARE HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY. WE HAVE
WHAT WE HAVE OPPOSITION SORRY I
DON'T SEE ANY PARTY WHO
SCHEDULED TO SPEAK OTHER OTHERS
IN THE- IN A ROOM HERE. BRUNNER
TELEPHONE TELEPHONE REYES AND- I
AM SCHEDULED TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION THIS IS TONYA
COLLECTOR AND ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL VERY GOOD PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MANY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TIME
UTILITARIAN ON BEHALF OF STATE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION TO
SB ONE ONE ONE EIGHT- SB ONE ONE
ONE EIGHT SEVEN THREE. SENATOR
PER VIEW THAT WAS NOT CREATED BY
THE COURTS IN NEIGHBORS FIRST
MORRELL UNDER SEPA INCREASING
INTERNALLY IN THE STATE STATUTE
. I CAN'T THE BILL IS BASED ON
LANGUAGE AND NEIGHBORS FIRST
PART RAIL CONCERNING AN OMISSION
IN NPR. SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ANALYSIS BUT THE BUILT OVER
BROADLY APPLIES THE LANGUAGE TO
ALL SECRET DECISIONS. FOR SB ONE
ONE ONE EIGHT IS THAT EIGHT AGES
TO DISCRETIONARY MAKING UNDER C.
CLASS HI REQUIRED INSTEAD OF
COURT ISSUE FINDING. I REQUIRE
UNITS FINDING INCLUDES WITH.
THANK SB ONE ONE EIGHT ON. THE
CONCEPT THAT NEARLY TEN
EMISSIONS ARE NOT FOUND FOR
RELIEF RT OF THE PLAN. WE HAVE A
FEW. ON THE IT COMMITTEE. FIRST
BILL LANGUAGE IS OVER PROP
RECORDS IN NEIGHBORS SMART RAIL
DISCUSSED TECHNICAL VITAL. IN N.
P. I. R. COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO
DECREE. THAT THE- APPLIES TO IRS
AND TO AN DOT. WE URGE THE
ADDRESS OF THE WORDS IN MANY. IN
AMENDMENTS AND IN. THREE-
THROUGHOUT. COM INCONSISTENT
WITH SEEK TO ADD THE WORD SHOULD
STAND. BEFORE THE WORD RELEVANT
INFORMATION WHEN WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT EMISSIONS AND THEN P. I.
ARE SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ANALYSIS
BEING PREJUDICIAL IF IT DEPRIVED
REPUBLICAN DECISION MAKERS OF
RELEVANT INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PROJECTS LIKELY AND ADVERSE
IMPACTS. I'M GOING TO NOTE THAT
DEFINITIVA BILLS PREMISED ON THE
ABUSE OF DISCRETION STANDARD
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED IN THAT WAS
DISCUSSED IN NEIGHBORS FIRST
MORRELL HOWEVER BUT NO TWO OF
THE SUPREME COURT DECISION STATE
SPECIFICALLY THAT THE ABUSE OF
DISCRETION INSPECTION OF THE
DECISION DOES NOT REFLECT THE
MAJORITY. AT THE OPINION OF THE
COURT. SECOND POINT IS THAT THEY
WEREN'T CANCEL RT FOR GO WRAP IT
PLEASE. SURE AND THE WORD
POTENTIAL INCLUDES WITH THE
SECRET GUIDELINE. AND ALSO FOR
SUSPICIONS THAT NEARLY REFERS
RELEVANT INFORMATION. IN GROUNDS
. OVER TWO IS IT TOO HUNDRED
HERE THANK YOU HAVE A HE WON
ONE. OUR THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. OVER THE. ON THE PHONE LINE.
THANK YOU. AT LEAST I'M SORRY
MODERATE BEFORE WE GET TO THAT
WHY DON'T WE HAVE THOSE WHO ARE
PRESENT IN THE CHAMBER IN TWELVE
HUNDRED IF THEY APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. SINGH KNOWN
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE ALL
RIGHT. BACK TO THE PHONE LINE
FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU AFTER THE TEN AB SB ONE ONE
ONE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS IN LONDON
ZERO. THERE'S NO ONE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME.
PODERIA IF THERE'S ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION TO S.
B. ONE ONE ONE EIGHT. THERE'S NO
ONE EIGHTY WITH ALREADY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE-
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SEEING IN MANY- THE FIRST LET'S
START WITH SENATOR LATER THAN
CENTER WHAT CAL SKI. MY QUESTION
IS IF THE AUTHOR OR POSSIBLY THE
CHAIR. COULD DETAILS THE
AMENDMENTS AND WHAT THEY DID TO
THIS. BECAUSE I CAME IN VERY
SKEPTICAL OF THIS BILL AND I
WANT TO KNOW IF THE AMENDMENTS
CHANGE THAT IT AND I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND CLEARLY WHAT THEIR M.
IMPACT WAS. ORGAN TO ARTICULATE
OUT THE SPECIFIC MINISTER GO
AHEAD. YES IN WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF IN JUDICIARY IN
THE EQ COMMITTEE THERE IS NEVER
CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
PREVIOUS VERSIONS OF THIS BILL
CREATED SOME- INCONSISTENCIES
WITHIN SEQUOIA AND SO. THOSE
INCONSISTENCIES WE BELIEVE HAVE
BEEN WORKED OUT AND WHAT THESE
AMENDMENTS DO NOW IS SIMPLY
STATE THAT. IN INTERPRETING
SEQUEL IT IS IN THE INTENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE. THAT
INSUBSTANTIAL VIOLATIONS ARE
TECHNICAL MISSIONS NOT BE
GROUNDS FOR RELIEF AND- THAT'S
THE BIG PART OF WHAT THESE
AMENDMENTS TO IT JUST SIMPLY
STATES. IN IN TENT THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THE COURTS
INTERPRET SYKORA IN THIS WAY AND
THEN THERE'S ALSO- I MEANT- ONE
OF THE AMENDMENTS SIMPLY STATES
THAT IT IS. THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THIS LANGUAGE
FROM THE SMART REAL CASE BE
CODIFIED. AND SO THAT'S THAT'S
THE AMENDMENTS IN A NUTSHELL
pVERY SIMPLE BILL NOW. BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY WILL DOWN ALTHOUGH
I'M ALWAYS SCARED OF THE ONES
THAT ARE THE MOST SIMPLE BILLS
BUT A FOLLOW UP QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR. IF YOU COULD RESPOND TO
THE OPPOSITIONAL STATEMENT AND
THE- ANALYSIS FROM ONE OF THE
OPPONENTS THAT SAID- THIS WAS A
SOLUTION IN SEARCH OF A PROBLEM
SO COULD YOU ADDRESS THAT POINT.
HI I AM NOT CERTAIN I COULD
DISAGREE MORE RESPECTFULLY BUT
WITH CERTAINTY- THAT SECRET WE
JUST WENT THROUGH A VERY AMAZING
DISCUSSION ON- ON MICHAEL. RIGHT
WE HAD TO FLY TO NEW YORK
COUNTERVAILING FORCES COMING
TOGETHER. I THINK THIS IS
NOWHERE NEAR NEAR NEAR THAT LEAK
BUT ANYTIME YOU WANT TO ADDRESS
SEQUEL IMMEDIATELY THE PARTY ARE
MOVING INTO THEIR RESPECTIVE
POSITIONS. AND I THINK WHAT
WE'VE SEEN HERE IN THE PAST IS
THAT. INDIVIDUALS MIGHT BE
WISHING TO OPPOSE ANY
IMPROVEMENT TO SEE WHAT. AND FOR
EXAMPLE I USED TO BE THE-
CHAIRMAN OF THE- SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER CONSERVANCY FOR MANY
YEARS. SO I HAVE A- IN
ENVIRONMENTAL BENT. SICK WHAT IS
A DOCUMENT THAT CAN DO WITH SOME
IMPROVEMENT AND I THINK EVEN THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HAS
IDENTIFIED THAT ONE AREA THAT
WON'T OBVIATE ANY EXISTING
RIGHTS SUPPORT LEGAL PROTECTIONS
IS SIMPLY TO IDENTIFY. THAT IF
THERE ARE TECHNICAL- BIOLASE. OR
TECHNICAL ERRORS. THAT ARE NON
PREJUDICIAL THAT WE'D BE IN THIS
POSITION TO ALLOW FOR A
DOCUMENT- TO BE REVIEWED AND
ENVIRONMENTAL MATTER TO BE
REVIEWED- IN THAT LIGHT. IN NOT
STOPPAGE SIMPLY BECAUSE MAYBE
SOMEONE DIDN'T HAVE A COMMON THE
RIGHT SPOT. WELL IF I CAN MAKE A
COMMENT MISTER CHAIR UP YOU
MIGHT HAVE PICKED THE WRONG
EXAMPLE. BECAUSE I WAS A MEMBER
OF THAT CONSERVANCY BOARD FOR
EIGHT YEARS AND SENT SOMEBODY
AND WITH SECURITATE ID ONE SICK
WHAT WAS IGNORED- ON A
PARTICULAR ISSUE THAT WAS IN THE
CENTER OF THAT CONSERVANCY FOR A
LONG TIME. WE SPOKE WEEKS WE
SPONSORED AND SUPPORTED- ON THE
SECRET ROCESS- WITH UTMOST
VILLAGE ON- VISUAL ANSWER IN OUR
IN OUR COMMUNITY. BECAUSE YOU DO
SEE WHAT HAS BEEN A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY YOU CAN'T
HAVE DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
WITHOUT. IDENTIFYING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS IT'S THAT
SIMPLE. AND THAT IS CLEAR THE
IDEAS WHETHER NOT IT'S USED IN
WAYS THAT. YOU BETTER- TERRIER I
THANK YOU FOR THAT COMMENT I
LOOK FORWARD THE QUOTE IN THE
FIRST HALF OF IT REGULARLY.
THANK YOU FOR THE PLAN IS A IS A
FOLLOW ON TO YOUR QUESTION THE.
AMENDMENTS- CLOSELY ALONG. THE
WITH THE HOLD IN NEIGHBORS FOR
SMART REAL VERSUS EXPOSITION.
METROLINE THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT TO DO THAT'S WE WANT TO DO
IS TO BASICALLY CODIFIED THAT
DID MINOR- MINISTERIAL ISSUES
WOULD NOT BE REASON. TO
INVALIDATE THE E. I. R. SO. ARE
CENTER WHAT HOUSE HE. I DID
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE IN-
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY I WISH I
WOULD HAVE READ THIS ANALYSIS
BEFORE IT WOULD HAVE JUMPED OFF
THAT BOAT BACK IN THE QUEUE BUT-
I LEFT FILE MY VOTES MY QUESTION
IS THAT. IT SEEMS THAT THERE'S A
DISTINCTION TO BE MADE WITH
CODIFYING NEIGHBOR I GET THAT
FOR THESE MINOR BITS BUT THIS IS
EXTENDING IT TO ALL
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS WHAT IS
A NOTICE OF DEFAULT OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS AND NOT
USE. THE GRAND ENCHILADA D. E.
I. R. WHICH IS THE HIGHEST LEVEL
CAN YOU COMMENT ON THAT BECAUSE
SOME OF THESE OTHER DOCUMENTS
THAT ARE YOU KNOW NOT A FULL E.
I. R. WOULD BE SWEPT UP IN THE-
THIS BILL AS AMENDED. WELL IN
ALL IN ALL LEAVE OPEN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MORGAN TO
COMMENT FURTHER- THAT I. IN THE
IR IS GOING TO HAVE A COMPANY
DOCUMENTS IN SO WHAT'S IT WHAT
HAPPENS I THINK OVER TIME. IS
THAT CERTAIN OTHER PARALLEL-
SUBMISSIONS- FEDERAL PART OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW OR THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY THAT IS
REVIEWING THE MATTERS BEFORE IT
OR REGULATORY ENTITY. THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE A VERY SIMILAR. N
OUR EXPECTATION THROUGH THIS
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
DECISION THAT A MERE TECHNICAL
VIOLATIONS SHOULDN'T OBVIATE-
THE- THE FUNCTIONALITY OF THE
ER. OR DEFEAT FOR THE PERIL
DOCUMENTATION THAT COULD GO
ALONG WITH THAT. I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS THAT THAT PROCESS
YOU GO THROUGH AND THE SEQUEL
THAT RELEVANT INFORMATION IS THE
PUBLIC COULD BE DEPRIVED OF THAT
ARE NOT DEPRIVED OF THAT IF
THERE. IF THESE OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS TO
DETERMINE TO BE MERE TECHNICAL
ERRORS I MEAN IF YOU KNOW IN AS
WE MOVE THROUGH THE PROCESS- IF
THAT IS AN ISSUE THAT IS OF
CONCERN- TO YOU SENATOR HI. I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO LOOK FURTHER
INTO THAT AND IF FOR FURTHER
REFINEMENT IS APPROPRIATE AND
NECESSARY- I GIVE YOU MY WORD
THAT- I WILL I WILL MAKE
CORRESPONDING CHANGES. JUST AS
I'VE MADE THE- THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE
HAVE RECOMMENDED BE MADE IN
ORDER TO MOVE THIS PROCESS
FORWARD. I'LL BE HAPPY TO DO SO
AS WELL. OKAY THE OTHER OF
OBJECTION OR THE OTHER CONCERN
IS FOOTNOTES TO SO I APOLOGIZE I
DID NOT READ FOOTNOTE TO ON THIS
I THINK THIS DECISION BUT TALKS
ABOUT THE MERCH MAJORITY OF THE
SUPREME COURT DIDN'T. DIDN'T
COME TOGETHER MORALITY AND WHAT
IS THE- ABUSE OF DISCRETION
THAT'S USED ON THAT. AND WHETHER
IT'S- SUBSTANTIAL MOSTLY
SUBSTANTIAL AND SIGNIFICANT AS A
WHOLE. RAINBOW OF DIFFERENT- HI
DECISIONS THAT THEY CAN BE FULL
PICKING FOUR ONE N. I'M
WONDERING THAT'S STILL IN THE
BILL. RIGHT. AND I'M I'M
WONDERING- IT SEEMS AS THOUGH.
THIS NEW DEFINITION WHY DO WE
NEED THIS NEW DEFINITION IF
PRACTITIONERS COULD RELY ON
NEIGHBOR NEIGHBOR TO NEIGHBOR
DECISION ANYWAY. WELL THIS
LANGUAGE FROM THE NEIGHBORS
DECISION IS PERSUASIVE BUT IS
STRICTLY SPEAKING NOT BINDING ON
LOWER COURTS BECAUSE IT WAS FROM
A PLURALITY OPINION IN THIS
DECISION SO THERE WAS NO
MAJORITY THE COURT THAT SIGNED
ON TO THIS LANGUAGE AND
PRACTITIONERS IN THIS FIELD.
HAVE POINTED TO THIS LANGUAGE
AND SAID IT WOULD ACTUALLY BE
HELPFUL IF WAS. IF IT WAS
BINDING- THERE HAVE BEEN CASES
THERE HAVE BEEN PUBLISHED
DECISIONS AND SOME- PUBLISHED
DECISIONS THAT HAVE RELIED ON
THE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE ABOUT FIVE
PUBLISHED DECISIONS FIVE ON
PUBLISHERS SESSION SO THEY HAVE
USED IT BUT IT'S- STRICTLY
SPEAKING NOT BINDING ON THE
LOWER COURTS BECAUSE AGAIN IT IT
WAS A PLURALITY OPINION SO
THAT'S- PART OF THE REASON WHY-
WE- BROUGHT THIS BUT WE WORK ON
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT JUST. SEEMS
HELPFUL TO ELEVATE THIS LANGUAGE
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
APPLICABLE TO ALL PROJECTS AND
ALL COURTS LOOKING AT THIS BUT
DOESN'T THAT DROP OUT SOME OF
THE CLAIMS THAT PEOPLE CAN MAKE
ON WHETHER THE IT SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS. ON THE ENVIRONMENT
VERSUS. I GUESS MERELY LACK OF-
BY SHOWING A LACK OF. USE OF
DISCRETION. YOU SEE WHAT I'M
SAYING IS THAT. YOU WANT TO SEE
THE CONCERNED ABOUT THE PROCESS
AND WHETHER IT HAS A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT BECAUSE PROPONENTS WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THAT DISCUSS FIRST
IS WHETHER THE- TRIER OF. HIS
ABUSING THEIR DISCRETION OR
ALLEGED OF ABUSING THEIR
DISCRETION RIGHT. WELL THERE'S
LANGUAGE IN THE DECISION AND I
THINK THIS IS THE IT GOES INTO
THE BILL TO THAT LANGUAGE FROM-
THE CASE THAT TALKS ABOUT. WHAT
IS A AND IT'S SUBSTANTIAL. OR
TECHNICAL VIOLATIONS THEY SPEAK
TO WHETHER YOU KNOW IT. IT IT
DEPRIVES THE PUBLIC OF
SUBSTANTIAL RELEVANT INFORMATION
ARE PROJECTS SO THAT IS THE
DETERMINATION THAT THE COURTS
WOULD LIKELY MAKE. IN
DETERMINING IN IN DECIDING
WHETHER OR NOT TO ISSUE RELIEF
THEY WOULDN'T YOU KNOW
NECESSARILY. DENY SOMEONE THE
CHANCE TO MAKE THEIR CASE THEY
WOULD. YOU KNOW LET BOTH SIDES.
PRESENT THEIR SIDE AND THEN THEY
WOULD MAKE THAT DETERMINATION
WHAT WAS THERE. WAS A
SUBSTANTIAL VIOLATION OR A
TECHNICAL VIOLATION OF THE
SENATE SO I GUESS I GUESS THE
OPPOSITION THIS IS SAYING THAT
THESE THIS IS ANOTHER LAYER
THAT'S PART PUTTING INTO THIS-
SUBJECTIVE STANDARDS FOR THESE
FAKE STANDARDS. IN DETERMINING A
SEQUEL VIOLATIONS WHO IS
PREJUDICIAL MAY HAVE. ADD MORE
CONFUSION RATHER THAN
CLARIFICATION THAT'S OPPOSITION.
I'M AND I'M I THINK A AS WE'VE
SEEN THIS THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD
AND WE'VE SEEN OTHER- BILLS-
THERE IS A THERE'S A LITTLE BIT
OF A REFLEX THAT OCCURS- WHERE
MATTERS CAN BE- CONFUSED- BUT IN
REAL TERMS- ARE NOT CONFUSING I
THINK THIS IS PROBABLY ABOUT AS
CLEAR. A SITUATION AS YOU CAN
HAVE WHERE THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT DECISION HAS
LANGUAGE THAT WE ARE SEEKING TO
CODIFY THAT IS INSTRUCTIVE IN
NATURE. AND I THINK THE YOU KNOW
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL AND WHY
IT HAS ACHIEVED SUCCESS IS
BECAUSE INDIVIDUALS EVEN THOSE
WHO ARE NATURAL PROPONENTS OF
PROTECTING THE SANK WITH
SANCTITY OF SYKORA. UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE A DEGREE
OF COMMON SENSE AND
REASONABLENESS WHEN IT COMES TO
INSUBSTANTIAL OR TECHNICAL ODD
OUTSIDE ISSUES THAT COULD
DERAIL. A PROCESS FOR MOVING
FORWARD. THANK YOU MISTER.
ALREADY THANK YOU. OTHER
QUESTIONS SIX I'M SORRY CENTER
STERN. I APOLOGIZE IF YOU YOU'VE
ALREADY GONE THROUGH THIS MISTER
CHAIR OR MEMBERS BUT- WHAT WHAT
WHAT IN YOUR MIND IS A MERELY
TECHNICAL VIOLATION. WHAT'S ON
THIS REALLY FOR ME TO DECIDE OF
COURSE THAT IS FOR- JURISTE GUY
IN THE AND THOSE INVOLVED IN THE
PROCESS- TO- JUDICATA- THE OR
REVIEW AT LEAST- SO LEAVE IT UP
TO THEM TO THEM BUT I THINK FROM
A COMMON. FROM A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH APPROACH IN
APPRECIATION THIS ISSUE IS THAT
ANY I. R. IS A HIGHLY
SOPHISTICATED DOCUMENT REVIEWING
IT COULD BE WINDISCH USER COULD
BE WATER ISSUES A COULD BE-
GROUND RELATED ISSUES HIGHLY
HIGHLY TECHNICAL IN NATURE SO IF
THERE MIGHT BE A TECHNICAL
VIOLATION. OF A OF HELP
PARTICULAR STUDY WAS CONDUCTED
OR THE OUTCOME OF THAT STUDY BUT
IT DOESN'T IT'S NOT GERMANE TO
THE ISSUE AT HAND. THAT COULD
POPS POSSIBLY PERHAPS BE A
TECHNICAL ISSUE THAT IT OFFERS
NO PREJUDICIAL EFFECT. SO TECH A
TECHNICAL VIOLATION THAT'S NOT
GERMANE TO THE ISSUE IT. WHEN
YOU THINK OF A TECH LIKE IF
THERE'S A MISTAKE IN THE AIR
QUALITY ANALYSIS AROUND A MAJOR
PROJECT THAT SAYS IT'LL HAVE X.
AMOUNT OF IMPACT ON THE
COMMUNITY BUT IT REALLY WILL
HAVE Y. THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU MEAN
BY THAT WOULD THAT WOULD BE A
DIRECT THAT WOULD THAT THAT
WOULD BE A DIRECT A DIRECT
ISSUE. BUT IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW-
TECHNICAL PET CAPACITIES AND
PROCESSES THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW D. I THINK
THE VERY IDEA IS YOU KNOW WAS
THIS PARTICULAR SECTION- LOCATED
IN THE DOCUMENT APPROPRIATELY.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A NUMBER BUT
ONCE AGAIN IT'S UP TO DATE IT'S
UP TO THE JUDGE- IN THOSE
INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS TO MAKE
CERTAINLY SPECULATE ALL DAY LONG
ALL DAY LONG BUT THERE'S NO
DOUBT ACOMMON SENSE AND
REASONABLE STANDARD THAT IS
INHERENT IN THE LANGUAGE OF THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT WRITTEN
OPINION. LET ME INTERVENE FOR
JUST A SECOND AND DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE ANALYSIS PAGE
TWELVE OF FIFTEEN IF YOU LOOK AT
AMENDMENT THREE- SUB V. THERE'S
FURTHER DEFINITION HERE SO FOR
EXAMPLE WELL- LET'S READ IT
IT'S- IS FOR THE INTENT THE
LEGISLATURE THAT IN UNDERTAKING
JUDICIAL REVIEW PURSUANT TO
SECTIONS. 211-682-1168 POINT
FIVE COURT SHALL FIND. THAT
INSUBSTANTIAL OR MERELY
TECHNICAL MISSIONS ARE NOT
GROUNDS. FOR LEAVE THAT IN A
MISSION. BASICALLY NEW PHRASE.
AND OUR MISSION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORTS
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS ANALYSIS IS
PRESIDENT PREJUDICIAL IF IT
DEPRIVE THE PUBLIC. AND DECISION
MAKERS OF SUBSTANTIAL RELEVANT
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PROJECTS
LIKELY ADVERSE IMPACTS SO AND IF
THAT HELPS YOU SENATOR STERN
TERMS OF. CREATING GUIDANCE FOR
COURT AS TO WHAT'S TECHNICAL WAS
NOT TECHNICAL AND WHAT ASPECTS
OF THE REVIEW- ARE REVIEWED FOR
EXAMPLE- SUBSTANTIAL RELEVANT
INFORMATION BEING OMITTED VERSUS
MERELY- TECHNICAL MISSIONS. BUT
MY CONCERN AND MY HANG UP WITH
THE BILL REMAINS THAT IT FOR
TRYING TO PROVIDE MORE CLARITY
IN LAW BY CODIFYING DECISION BUT
THEN THERE'S THIS VAGUENESS
AROUND IT THAT IT'S OPEN ENDED
AND GOING TO BE SUBJECT TO
JUDICIAL DISCRETION AND WE'RE
GETTING NO FURTHER CLARITY AT
THE LAW I DON'T KNOW WHY. WOULD
BE PASSING A BILL TO FURTHER ADD
VAGARIES TO AN ALREADY. SORT OF
ALREADY PRETTY OPEN ENDED
STANDARD THAT THOSE BRIGHTLY
ALLOW COURTS SOME DISCRETION
THAT REGARD I APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION MR CHER BUT I
EIGHT. FROM THE AUTHORS
DESCRIPTION. YET MERE TECHNICAL
VIOLATIONS SEEMS DIDN'T INDICATE
THERE'S A DIFFERENT
CLASSIFICATION OF TECHNICAL
VIOLATION LIKE THERE'S TWO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF TECHNICAL
VIOLATIONS WHEN THE- SUBSTANTIAL
IN THAT OR NOT SO. I CAN'T
SUPPORT THE MEASURE AGAIN TODAY
BUT I APPRECIATE THE WORK THE
COMMITTEES DOWN IN THE BILL.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS SAYING
NONE IS THERE MOTION. SENATE
JONES MOST THE BILL ALL RIGHT.
SURFBOARDS CARE CLOSE- YES AND
NO I WILL BE BRIEF- I DO WANT TO
WOULD TO LET CENTER STERN KNOW
THAT- IF HE HAS RECOMMENDATIONS
ON HOW TO IMPROVE- OF A BILL
LIKE THIS I WOULD ACTUALLY LOVE
TO WORK WELL WITH YOU AND EARN
YOUR SUPPORT IN IN IN THIS
PROCESS- AS I MENTIONED IN OF
OUR MENTAL QUALITY WHEN IT
PASSED OUT OF INVERNAL QUALITY.
IT WAS THAT THERE IS A BALANCE
HERE THAT IS THAT PROTECTS THE
SANCTITY OF SEACOR AND ADDS A
DEGREE OF REASONABLENESS SO
THAT- THAT THE COURT CAN RELY
UPON THE PRESIDENT- IN THE
SUPREME COURT CASE IN A MORE
CLEAR AND- DIRECTIONAL WAY AND-
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PERCENT THIS BILL
TODAY I KNOW THAT- IF SHOULD TO
PASS HERE I WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE
TO WORK WITH THAT CENTER WHAT
CAL SKI. ON ANY- RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT HE HAS TO IMPROVE THE BILL
AND LASTLY I WANT TO THANK OF
COURSE THE CHAIR IN HIS TEAM-
FOR WORKING WITH US IMPROVING
THE BILL IN MAKING IT INTO A
DRAFT THAT ARE I BELIEVE THAT-
VIRTUALLY EVERYONE WOULD FIND
APPROPRIATE UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE. FIND
OURSELVES ESPECIALLY IN THE
HOUSING CONTEXT. RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL ALREADY- SPIN MOBAS
JOHN MANAGING YOU THE ROLL. YES
THIS IS THE S. B. ONE ONE EIGHT
BY SENATOR BOARD YES. WHAT THE
MOTION BY SENATOR JOHNSON MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
UMBERG. NUMBER GUY BURGESS. HI
FORGES I CARRY IT- VERY AT ALL I
DID AWESOME. TESSA NOT VOTING
GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG JONES JONES
BY LAYERED. LAYERED I STERN.
STERN NOT VOTING Y. CASKEY.
WIENER WIENER I CAN GO BACK
THROUGH RIGHT NOW WE HAVE SIX OR
GO BACK THROUGH THE HIDDEN
CULTURAL MARTIN DID US ALL. NOT
VOTING GONZALEZ NOT VOTING
HERTZBERG NOT VOTING. STERN NOT
VOTING Y. CASKEY WHITE HOUSE
CANNOT VOTING EVERYONE'S HERE
EVERYONE'S VOTED. SIX TWO ONE
TWO THREE FOUR SIX TWO ZERO ALL
RIGHT BILLS OUT- I. DON'T YOU
BECAUSE YOU'RE LOOKING AT ME.
WITH LOOKS LIKE BEWILDERMENT
SORRY CHANGE I CAN. THE LEVEL
MEMBERS. I'M NOT GOOD AT MATH
BUT I'M BUT THAT MIGHT BE MORE
PASSED RIGHT BY THE BY THE BILLS
OUT ALL RIGHT NEXT. SEVEN CENTER
ARCH ALETTA. SEARCH A LETTER
ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. ONE THREE
TWO THREE. THANKS RICHER AND-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH TODAY I'M PRESENTING
SENATE BILL ONE THREE TWO THREE
TO REQUIRED LENDERS IN
FORECLOSURE PROCEEDINGS TO HIRE
A REALTOR AND SELL THE SECURED
PROPERTY FOR AN APPRAISED VALUE
ON MULTIPLE MULTIPLE LISTING
SERVICE THIS WOULD ALLOW THE
DEFAULTED HOMEOWNER TO BE PAID
OUT THEIR FULL SAVINGS IN HOME
EQUITY IN EVERY APPLICABLES
FORECLOSURE. FORECLOSED
HOMEOWNERS ARE LOW INCOME OFTEN
ELDERLY IMMIGRANT OR DISABLED
MEMBERS OF CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. FOR
MEMBERS OF THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE HOME IS OFTEN THEIR
ONLY ASSET AND HOME EQUITY IS
OUR ONLY LIFETIME SAVINGS THE
LOSS OF EVEN A SINGLE DOLLAR. OF
THIS ACTIVITY IT'S A REPLACEABLE
PUTTING THE FOR CLOSE HOMEOWNER
AT INCREASED RISK OF POVERTY AND
HOMELESSNESS. HOMEOWNERSHIP IS A
PRIMARY SAVINGS VEHICLE FOR LOW
AND MODERATE AND MIDDLE CLASS
HOMEOWNERS. IN THE UNITED STATES
FOR A FAMILY WITHOUT LIQUID AT
BAT FUNDS TO PAY THEIR MORTGAGE
THERE A CURE TO HOME EQUITY IN
THEIR PROPERTY MAY BE THE ONLY
SAVINGS THEY HAVE. ADDITIONALLY
THE LOSS OF HOME IS ALREADY ONE
OF THE MOST DRAMATIC EVENTS THAT
CAN HAPPEN TO AN INDIVIDUAL AND
THEIR FAMILIES. IN THE
UNFORTUNATE EVENT THAT A HOUSE
DOES GO INTO FORECLOSURE THE
HOMEOWNER SHOULD NOT BE PUNISHED
FURTHER BY A LENDER SELLING THE
HOUSE. WELL UNDER ITS VALUE THIS
LOST EQUITY POTENTIALLY MEANS
THAT THE HOMEOWNER WILL NEVER BE
ABLE TO AFFORD TO PURCHASE
ANOTHER HOME AND CAN. LEAVE THEM
WITHOUT NOTHING VIRTUALLY
NOTHING. AN ESTIMATE OF LOST
EQUITY PER FORECLOSURE SALE IN
CALIFORNIA IS A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
REPRESENTED AN AVERAGE OF 22%
DISCOUNT OFF THE MARKET PRICE
FOR THE AVERAGE HOME SOLD IN
FORECLOSURE AUCTIONS. ORDER FOR
CLOSE UP CALIFORNIA HOMES HAVE
THEIR PROPERTY SOLD AT AUCTION
FOR OVER 30% LESS THAN ACTUAL
MARKET VALUE OF THE PROPERTY A
TENTH ARE SOLD UNDER 52% OF THE
MARKET VALUE. WANTED TWENTY FOUR
CLOSED- CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS
HAVE THEIR PROPERTY SOLD AT
AUCTION FOR OVER 70% LESS THAN
THE ACTUAL MARKET VALUE OF THE
PROPERTY THIS NUMBER REPRESENTS
AN AVERAGE OF OVER THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THIS IS COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE. AGGREGATING THIS
DATA APPROXIMATELY SEVEN POINT
FOUR BILLION IN A GROUP HOME
EQUITY WAS TAKEN FROM FOR CLOSE
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS OVER THE-
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY PERIOD SO ON AVERAGE
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT FIVE
EIGHT FIVE BILLION IN THE
CURRENT HOME. FORECLOSURE AND
THE PROCESS EACH AND EVERY YEAR
IT IS NOTEWORTHY THAT WHEN A
BANK ACQUIRED A FORECLOSED
PROPERTY BY A CREDIT BID. THEY
WILL THEN HIRE A REALTOR AND
SELL THE PROPERTY ON MULTIPLE
LISTING SERVICE WHEN THE LENDERS
OWN FINANCIAL INTEREST IS AT
STAKE IT CONDUCTS THE SALE BY A
LISTING NOT BY AUCTION ISN'T
THAT IRONIC. THIS IS IMPORTANT
TO NOTE BECAUSE IT DEMONSTRATES
THAT BANKS ARE AWARE THAT
AUCTIONS LEAD TO LOWER SALE
PRICES AND THE BANKS AND LENDERS
ALREADY HAVE THE NECESSARY
MECHANISMIN PLACE TO ADOPT. A
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
THREE TO REQUIREMENT OF HIRING A
REALTOR AND SELLING THE HOMES IT
FOR CLOSURE ON THE LISTING
SERVICE IN EQUITY SCENARIOS. AND
PUT TO PROTECT THE HOMEOWNER
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WOULD
RECAST FORECLOSURE PROVISIONS TO
REQUIRE THAT AN EQUITY SALE OF
PROPERTY UNDER POWER OF SALE. OF
THE MORTGAGE A DEED OF TRUST BE
MADE BY A LICENSED REALTOR AND
BY PUBLICLY LISTING THE PROPERTY
FOR SALE ON THE CALIFORNIA
MULTIPLE LISTING SERVICE WITH
INITIAL LISTING PRICE AT THE
PROPERTY'S APPRAISED VALUE. IF
THE HOUSE IS UNDER TO BE SOLD AT
AN APPRAISED VALUE THE BILL
WOULD AUTHORIZE A TRUST DEED TO
PROGRESSIVELY REDUCE THE LISTED
PRICE AS TIME GOES ON. OF THE
PROPERTY THE TRUSTEE DOES NOT
RECEIVE THE QUALIFYING OFFER
THERE IS A MECHANISM THIS BILL
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE TRUSTEE TO
SELL THE PROPERTY BY PUBLIC
AUCTION AS THEY CURRENTLY DO.
THE TRUSTEE DOES NOT RECEIVE A
QUALIFYING OFFER AFTER THE PRICE
REDUCTIONS OR IF THE PRICE
DECREASE WILL RESULT IN THE
PROPERTIES LISTED PRICE FALLING
BEFORE THE EQUITY THRESHOLD.
BECAUSE OF THIS LENDERS WILL
ALWAYS BE ABLE TO MADE WHOLE.
THE BANK WILL NEVER SUFFER.
LENDERS WILL ALWAYS BE WHOLE
UNDER THIS BILL I AM AWARE THAT
THE OPPOSITION HAD RAISED
CONCERNS REGARDING THIS BILL AND
HOW IT WOULD IMPACT THE
FORECLOSURE PROCESS. TO THAT END
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
DISCUSSION ON SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY THREE TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES AND I'M WILLING TO
WORK WITH THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
TO MAKE THE BILL EVEN STRONGER.
AND WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF THE IMPORTANT BILL IS
CIVIL BALTER A LAWYER AND
EXPERT. ON FORECLOSURE FIELD AND
HIS CLIENT TO RESET PROBATE WHO
HAD HER HOME IN SAN FRANCISCO
SOLD AT AUCTION AND ONLY
RECEIVED FIFTY DOLLARS AFTER THE
TRANSACTION. I RESPECTFULLY
AFTER RIVAL. THANK YOU SEYARTO
ALL RIGHT THOSE WHICH TESTAMENT
SUPPORT I THINK WE'LL GET TO IN
SUPPORT SO FOSLER AND- TO
RECEIVE THE PUBLIC YES YES-
MISTER FOSTER. WOULD LIKE TO GO
FIRST. MISS POBREZA ALL RIGHT
LET'S PULL OVER IF YOU WOULD
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE- ISSUE
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT. IN THIS WITHOUT
TURNING TO EVERYBODY. MY NAME IS
THE RECEIPTS FOR GRABS I AM HERE
TO SUPPORT ISRAEL. I BOTH AGE
SAN FRANCISCO HOME IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR. READ MORE GAUGE LOS
FARGO MY HALF MINE ARE DAMIEL.
SET UP OUR LARA GATES AND HE
PLANTS AWAY. AND THE NEXT YEAR.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE. BEFORE HE
DIED HE TOLD ME. THESE HOUSE. IS
MIGHT GIVE DO YOU I WANTED VERY
HARD AS A TEACHER'S AIDE. AND
INSIDE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN I DID
NOT MANY IS IT'S SINGLE MORTGAGE
. AND FOR ALL TWENTY YEARS. BUT
AFTER I RETIRED I STRUGGLED
FINANCIALLY I MEAN MY FIRST
PAYMENT. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WITH
SEVENTY SEVEN YEARS OLD. IN
THREE DAYS A DAY IN MY HOME
WHAT'S THE WORD. EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND. BUT THE WELLS FARGO
SOLD IT INCORPORATION FOURTH
CLOSE YOUR EYES- ALL HUMAN FOR
ONLY FIFTY ONE THOUSAND. I HAD
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
AND SAY THE WHOLE MAKE COMMITTEE
IT WAS WHEN THEY ONLY SAY
LIFESAVING. IN THE PORT GROCERY
OR THEY THOUGHT THAT FROM ME
THEY THOUGHT MY HOME. FOR ME AND
FOR WAS. LETTING ME. AND MY
DAUGHTER. THE GET UP FROM THE
HOUSE ALL DAY NEEDS GAVE ME
WHAT'S A CHECK OF ONE PENNY.
THAT SAID WE HAVE NOTHING LEFT.
A TORN ACL ROASTER MY GAZE AND
FOUGHT TO GET MY HOME BACK WE
SEATS OUT OF THIS CASE WHICH
WILL SPARKLE OUTSIDE THE COURT.
AND WELLS FARGO'S IS STILL
SAYING THEY NEED NOT DOING WRONG
. PLEASE A YES WITH THIS MEAL
AND THE WILL NOT LET THIS HAPPEN
TO ANYBODY. ELLIS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISSPOKE RAMPS ARE FOR
LOSS OF YOUR HUSBAND THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT- MR BOSSERT YOU HAVE
ONE MINUTE AND TWENTY SECONDS
THANK YOU- MY NAME IS SYLVESTER
ON THE FOUNDER OF THE BUS THEIR
LAW FIRM AND I REPRESENT
CONSUMERS AND FORECLOSURE
LAWSUITS. I'M WORKING WITH THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA THE SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. THIS PROGRAM WAS MY CLIENT
AND WELLS FARGO SOLD HER SAN
FRANCISCO BAYVIEW SAN FRANCISCO
HOME 47% OF ITS MARKET VALUE.
AND GAVE HER ONE PENNY AFTER THE
SALE THAT WAS ALL SHE WAS
ENTITLED TO SHE'S NOT MY ONLY
CLIENT HAS BEEN THROUGH THIS
TYPE ANOTHER CLIENT RIGHT NOW
WHO HAD. ONE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF PROPERTY
BUNDLED AND SOLD AT A
FORECLOSURE AUCTION FOR TWO
HUNDRED AND FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS THIS PROBLEM. IS NOT AND
THESE ARE NOT ISOLATED INCIDENTS
WHILE THEIR EXTREME CASES
THEY'RE NOT ISOLATED OVER SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND FORECLOSURES TOOK
PLACE IN CALIFORNIA FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY AND
ON AVERAGE THEY'RE SOLD AT A
TWENTY THESE PROPERTIES ARE SOLD
AT A TWENTY TWO PERCENT. COUNTED
AUCTION AN ESTIMATE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
CONSUMER THAT IS DATA FROM UC
BERKELEY AND THE NATIONAL BUREAU
OF ECONOMIC RESEARCH I'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH. THANKS
INVITE US TO DO AS THEY SAY NOT
AS THEY DO. WHEN THE BANKS ON
FINANCIAL INTEREST IS AT STAKE
WHEN THEY ACQUIRE THESE
PROPERTIES THEY TAKE THEY HIRE A
REALTOR AND SELL THE PROPERTY.
ON THE MLS WITH THE HELP OF A
REALTOR. BUT WHEN THE CONSUMERS
INTEREST IS AT STAKE THEY SELL
THE AUCTION THE PROPERTIES AT
AUCTION FOR WHATEVER THEY CAN
GET. HOMEOWNERSHIP IS THE
PRIMARY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU MISS RUSSELL. ALL
RIGHT- OTHERS WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
IF YOU APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR FILIATION
AND YOUR POSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I'M ROBERT FOR ALL THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE THE SPONSORS
OF THIS MEASURE I WAS HAPPY TO
SEE MY TWO MINUTES OF THE ALL
COULD HEAR THE STORY OF MISS
POVERTY. PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
BILL ALL RIGHT. AFTERNOON CHURCH
MEMBERS MY NAME SERRA KERRISON
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. HELLO DANNY CANDLE
BECAUSE OUR ON BEHALF OF BOTH
THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION AND NATIONAL
CONSUMER LAW CENTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT NO ONE ELSE
HERE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED IF
WE GO TO THE PHONES PLEASE QUEUE
UP THOSE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY THREE. IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEY'RE ALL. IT IN PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEIR APPEARANCE SUPPORT
. THIS PERMANENT. ONE OF. YEAH.
RIGHT AND I HAVE NO ONE AQ AT
THE FAX ALL RIGHT- TURNING NOW
TO OPPOSITION- WE HAVE. IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE MISTER MIKE
BLOAT AND MISTER KEVIN GOULD
MIKE BELOW MR BLOOD IS HERE GO
AHEAD MR BLOW THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM MIKE BELOW
ARE MEMBERS OF THE UNITED
TRUSTEES ASSOCIATION ARE
FORECLOSURE TRUSTEES WHO HANDLE
THESE FORECLOSURES THEY ARE NOT
GENERAL TRUSTEES. AS IN A
CONSERVATORSHIP WE'RE VERY
SYMPATHETIC TO THE PROBLEM WE DO
WITH NO ONE WANTS ANY PERSON TO
LOSE EQUITY PARTICULARLY ELDERLY
HOMEOWNERS AND WE'VE HAD
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR AND WILL CONTINUE TO
DO THAT I THINK THERE ARE SOME
PRACTICAL AND LEGAL PROBLEMS IN
THE BILL IT IS CREATIVE IT IS
WELL INTENTIONED BUT I THINK
THERE ARE PROBLEMS IN THE
BIGGEST ONE. IS THAT THE
HOMEOWNER HIM OR HERSELF IS NOT
INVOLVED IN THIS PROCESS THERE'S
AN ACTUAL HOME OWNER OF THE
HOUSE BUT THE TRUSTEE IS
SUPPOSED TO SELECT AN APPRAISER
WHO IS NOT LIKELY TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE HOUSE AND THEY'RE GOING
TO TRY AND MAKE AN INFORMED
EVALUATION TO ESTABLISH THIS
FAIR MARKET VALUE. THEY ARE THEN
SUPPOSED TO HIRE A REALTOR AND
GO THROUGH OFFERS ON THE HOUSE
AGAIN WITH NO INVOLVEMENT OF THE
HOMEOWNER SO THAT IS IT THAT
RAISES A WHOLE BUNCH OF
PRACTICAL PROBLEMS OF LIABILITY
SOMEBODY WILL SAY WE HAVE
SELECTED THE WRONG APPRAISER YOU
SELECTED THE WRONG REALTOR YOU
SELECTED THE WRONG OFFER ON THE
HOUSE. BECAUSE THE HOMEOWNERS
COMPLETELY ON INVOLVED IN THIS
PROCESS LEGALLY TRUSTEES HAVE NO
ABILITY UNDER THE DEED OF TRUST
TO ENGAGE IN THIS ACTIVITY
SOMEBODY OWNS THE HOUSE AND THEY
HAVE A SERIES OF RIGHTS
INCLUDING TO REFI. TO SEEK HELP
FROM A RELATIVE PERHAPS TO
DECLARE BANKRUPTCY AND PUT A
STOP TO THE FORECLOSURE
PROCEEDINGS SO THERE ARE LEGAL
PROBLEMS AND PRACTICAL PROBLEMS
BUT WE DO AGREE THAT EVERYONE
SHOULD GET THE MAXIMUM EQUITY
OUT OF THEIR HOUSE AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
SENATOR ARCHULETA. TO FIND OF UP
THAT A WAY TO GET MEANINGFUL.
COMMUNICATION OF THE HOMEOWNER
TO SAY LOOK. YOU GOTTA SELL THE
HOUSE HERE YOU HAVE THE EQUITY
THAT IS ALMOST ALWAYS THE RIGHT
ANSWER AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH SENATOR ARCH ALETTA
ON THAT. AGAIN CREATIVE WELL
INTENTIONED BUT PRACTICALLY AND
LEGALLY PROP PROBLEMATIC THANK.
THANK YOU OTHERS HERE IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED WAS TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION SAYING KNOWN APPROACH
TO MICROPHONE- LET'S TURN TO THE
PHONES- MISTER. KEVIN GOLD ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO SCHOOL HERE AND
SENATORS. MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS COMMINGLED WITH
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION. VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS WE
HAVE HALF OF THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR WE ARE ALIGNED WITH THE
OVERALL GOAL OF MAXIMIZING THE
PROPERTY SALE PRICE AT THE MEANS
FOR THEIR EQUITY. HOWEVER WE ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL FOR CONCEPTUAL AND
MECHANICAL REASONS CONCEPTUALLY
WE STRUGGLE WITH THE IDEA OF
TAKING A BORROWER MOST OF THE
WAY THROUGH THE NON JUDICIAL
FORECLOSURE PROCESS FOR TRYING
TO SELL THE PROPERTY ON THE OPEN
MARKET. INSTEAD HE PROPOSES THE
MEASURE FOCUSED ON ENHANCE
NOTICED EARLIER IN THE PROCESS.
TO RETURN TO RAISE THE
HOMEOWNERS AWARENESS THAT IF
THEY HAVE THAT WOULD BE IN THE
PROPERTY. BUT THEY MAY WISH TO
SELL THE PROPERTY UNDER THEIR
TERMS AND THEIR DIRECT. I CAN'T
BELIEVE THIS MEASURE RAISES A
SERIES OF QUESTIONS THAT FLOW
FROM THE CLIENT RELATIONSHIP SET
FORTH IN THIS PROPOSAL. WHAT
TRUSTEE HIRES THE REALTOR. IN
THIS SCENARIO THE TRUSTEE IS THE
REALTORS CLIENTS NOT THE
HOMEOWNER. LET ME SAY THAT
AGAIN. UNDER THIS MATTER THE
REAL ESTATE AGENT IS NOT
REPRESENTING THE HOMEOWNER
RELATIVE TO THE SALE OF THE
HOUSE THEY LIVE IN. BUT IT IS
INSTEAD OF REPRESENTING THE
TRUSTEE. FURTHER RULES TRENDS
REQUIRES THE SELLER TO SIGN
DOCUMENTS AND MAKE
REPRESENTATIONS ABOUT THE
PROPERTY. IF ENACTED IS IT THE
TRUSTEE RATHER THAN THE
HOMEOWNERS WITH CHINESE
DOCUMENTS AND MAKE THESE
REPRESENTATIONS. WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO CAREFULLY CONSIDER
TH NOTION OF A REALTOR
REPRESENTING A TRUSTEE. IN THE
OPEN MARKET SALE OF A HOME THAT
THE HOMEOWNER STILL POSSESSES.
AS PREVIOUSLY STATED. BETTER
APPROACHES TO PRO ACTIVELY
INTERVENE EARLIER IN THE
PROCESS. THAT MEANS TO BETTER
INFORM THE HOMEOWNER OF. PEOPLE
PLAN TO DRAFT LANGUAGE THAT
ACCOMPLISHES THIS GOAL AND HOPE
THIS WILL YIELD PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS. FRIEDMAN STATED
WE ARE CLOSED TODAY BUT ARE
HOPEFUL THAT OUR DISCUSSIONS
WILL LEAD US IN THE FUTURE
COMPROMISED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR GOLD ALL RIGHT- OTHERS HERE
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
SAYING KNOWN APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE LET'S TURN THE PHONE
LINES MATTER IF YOU WOULD. QUEUE
UP THOSE ON THE PHONE LINES IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIRTEEN TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU AND IF YOU'RE
AN APPLE. OF THEY'RE TWENTY
THREE FOR PRESS AND SAY. AND AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE TO IN Q. AND
A- FIRST LINE IS ONE OH NINE
PLEASE HEY. THIS BILL DOWN THIS
AFTERNOON THIS IS ONE OF THE
FOLLOWING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BANKING NETWORK
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU
AND ONE MOMENT THE NEXT PERSON
AT LINE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON CARE MEMBERS
ROBERT WILSON THE CALIFORNIA
BRADY LEAGUE HERE OPPOSITIONAL
AS THE THIRTEEN TWENTY THREE
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHTY LET'S
BRING IT BACK I'M SORRY GO AHEAD
MODERATE OR ANYONE ELSE. I'M
SORRY WE DO HAVE ONE WITH AN
APPARATUS TO BE JUST A MOMENT
ALL RIGHT. AND THAT IS NINE ONE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER MEMBERS ANTHONY
HELTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA LAND
TITLE ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
LET'S BRING IT BACK HERE TO THE
CHAMBER QUESTIONS COME CENTER
MICHALSKI YEAH I GOT PROBLEMS
WITH THIS BILL HOW TO SAVE LIKE
THAT AND I KNOW ALL MY FRIENDS
ARE THERE ON SUPPORT MEMMOTT
BANKRUPTCY ATTORNEY. HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOMES HAVE BEEN
SAVED FROM FORECLOSURE BY FILING
A CHAPTER THIRTEEN BANKRUPTCY I
WANT EVERYBODY TO HEAR THAT YOU
SAVE YOUR HOME FROM FOR CLOSURE
BY FILING A CHAPTER THIRTEEN
BANKRUPTCY THEN YOU HAVE THEN
THAT ALL THE PROBLEMS THAT THE
OPPOSITION IS TALKING ABOUT THE-
PERSON STILL OWNS THE HOME.
THEY'RE STILL IN THEIR HOUSE AND
THEY COME UP WITH A PLAN TO
EITHER PAY BACK THE ARREARS THAT
THEY OWN BECAUSE IT'S NOT ALL
DOOM OR THE COURTS TYPICALLY
WILL GIVE YOU A YEAR TO SALAD SO
BAD NEWS IS GOT TO GET OUT THAT
YOU CAN FILE THE DAY BEFORE THE
FORECLOSURE SALE. BECAUSE THESE
TRUSTEES OF ARE ACTUALLY DOING
WHAT THE LAW SAYS THEY'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO MAXIMIZE THE SALE
THAT'S THE MISNOMER BY ADVOCATES
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO SELL THE
HOUSE. THAT'S IT THEY OWN THEY
REPRESENT THE BANK THEY DON'T
HAVE ANY WIGGLE ROOM ALL WE GET
TO DO IS SAY HERE'S A BID FOR
WHAT WE'RE OWED ON OUR LOAN. AND
THERE'S OVER BIDDING IN CRAZY
TIMESBUT THERE'S NOT THAT MANY
CRAZY TIMES BUT THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO. THE WAY
YOU HAVE IT STRUCTURED RATHER
THAN. ADDING CHANGING THE NOTICE
OF TRUSTEE SALE IN DEALING WITH
THAT AFTER THE DEFAULT PERIOD
HIS AND AFTER THE NINETY DAYS.
THEY HAVE TWENTY ONE DAYS TO
NOTICES SALE. THERE PROP ALL THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT YOU HAVE SEEM
TO ME THAT THAT WOULD BE THE
TIME THAT YOU WOULD GIVE PEOPLE
NOTICE. THAT THEY THAT THEY
WOULD THAT THEY WOULD SELL
BECAUSE YOU STILL HAVE THE
INNOCENT HOMEOWNER THAT'S THERE
SO THEY CAN SIGN DOCUMENTS. BUT
THESE ARE REAL PROBLEMS ABOUT.
HAVING SOMEBODY YOU CALL A
TRUSTEE'S SEAT SALE ONLY DO SAY
ANYBODY OVER BIT THAT'S IT DATE
AND THEN THEY RECORD. THE
TRANSFER DOCUMENTS SO- NOBODY
LIKES A FORFEITURE SO WE GET
THAT AND I GET THAT I KNOW WHERE
THIS IS COMING FROM BUT BUT THE
WAY IT'S SET UP IT'S A REAL BIG
PROBLEM AFTER THE FORECLOSURE
SALES BECAUSE YOU'RE A LIMBO
YOUR AVAILABLE IN THE AND THESE
ARE REAL PROBLEMS THAT YES YOU
COULD I MEAN I'M DOING A FOR
CLOSURE IN THE CIVIL ACTION IS
AN UNBELIEVABLE TASKIN. WHO DOES
TRYING TO TRYING TO DO THAT BUT
BUT NOBODY'S BREAKING THE LAW
HERE THAT'S WHAT THE LAW IS AND
THAT WAS THE DEAL A NON JUDICIAL
FORECLOSURES SO. I'M I GUESS I'M
VENTING ASSEMBLY I'M VENTING
GUIDE BUT I. WANT TO CUT
BANKRUPTCY LAWYER TWO MINUTES UP
THE PHILLIES. AT AFTER THE
DEFAULT PERIOD BECAUSE THEN YOU
STILL HAVE TWENTY ONE DAYS TO
SELL IT THERE'S SOME WAYS THAT
YOU CAN GET SOME PRETTY.
PROTECTIONS THERE BECAUSE THAT
THE WHOLE. LOAN IS. IS SUPPOSED
TO ANYWAY BUT- THIS AFTER THE
SALE OR FOUR OR BURKE SENDING IT
I DON'T I'M AFRAID AT THAT
BECAUSE THESE ARE. WELL I DON'T
KNOW WHO'S IN CHARGE. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SIR WHITE HOUSE GATHER
COMMENTS- LET'S SEE SENATOR
HERTZBERG. YEAH YEAH I ALSO
HAVE. I MEAN OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
TWO KINDS OF WAYS TO FOR CLOSE
ONES CALL THE POWER OF SALE.
UNDER FIVE AB IN THE OTHER ONE
IS A JUDICIAL FORECLOSURE UNDER
JUDICIAL FORECLOSURE HAVE A
RIGHT OF REDEMPTION. SO YOU
COULD ACTUALLY GET THE HOUSE
BACK FOR A YEAR YOU HAVE A RIGHT
EVEN THOUGH IT'S BEEN
TRANSFERRED RIGHT TO THAT DOES
EXIST IN A LOT NUMBER ONE. THE
OTHER ISSUE IS. WE'RE TRYING TO
FROM A PUBLIC POLICY PERSPECTIVE
WAY- CENTER A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES ONE OF THE WILL
IS WE WANT TO PRESERVE PEOPLE'S
EQUITY AND MAKE SURE THEY'RE
TREATED FAIRLY. ON THE OTHER
HAND WE HAVE THIS MASSIVE
CONSUMER 8% WE'VE GOT THIS
MASSIVE CONSUMER PROTECTION
WHERE WHEN YOU BUY HOUSES YOU
KNOW AS A RULER. YOU HAVE HOME
INSPECTIONS YOU HAVE LIABILITY
FOR THINGS YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE
YOUR- DEALS WITH THE WTH THE
SMOKE DETECTORS AND THE AND THE
BUT WHAT SHOULD WE CALL IT THE-
THE DEALS FOR THE SMALL DEALS OR
WHATEVER THE- STUFF. THERE'S SO
MUCH TO DO THERE AND SO ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES IS AS YOU'RE
TRYING TO PROTECT PEOPLE'S
EQUITY. IF YOU'RE ACTUALLY GOING
TO SELL IT YOU HAVE TO THEN
PROTECT THE CONSUMER WHO'S
BUYING THE HOUSE YOU KNOW THE
WHOLE ISSUE OF TITLE INSURANCE
AND HOW THE WHOLE SYSTEM WORKS
SO WHAT YOU'RE DOING IN THIS
DYNAMIC. IS YES YOU'RE
INTRODUCING A CONSUMER INTO A
PROCESS IT'S A HOST CELL PROCESS
THESE PEOPLE THAT BY COMING WITH
TWENTY OR THIRTY COOK CASHIERS
CHECKS THEY BUY FOR CASH THE
PULLING TOGETHER WHAT THEY NEED
IF THERE'S AN OVER BID. AND THEN
THEY TAKE THE RISK RIGHT AND
THEN THEY SELL IT AND PROVIDE
THE PROTECTIONS TO THE NEXT
WHETHER IT'S THEIR BANK THAT
DOESN'T QUITE OFTEN IN MANY
CASES THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF
FOLKS THAT RUN AROUND YOU
PROBABLY HAVE SEEN I HAVE. IN
PRIVATE LIFE WITH THE RUN AROUND
THEY JUST GO FROM AUCTION TO
AUCTION TO BUY STUFF BECAUSE
THEY LOOK AT A REPORT TO RIP YOU
OFF AND BY YOUR HOUSE FOR FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS THIS WOULD A
HER THOUSAND DOLLARS MAKE A
PROFIT RIGHT. BUT THEY DON'T
HAVE TITLE INSURANCE THEY HAVE
NO CONSUMER PROTECTION AND THEN
THEY PUT IN THE MARKET WITH A
REALTOR TO DO THAT. HURTING THE
CONSUMER WHO WHO'S BEEN TAKING
WHETHER EQUITY SO I'M SUGGESTING
IS YOU. THINK THIS THING THROUGH
MAY BE. THERE'S PROVISION OF WAY
YOU CAN- THE- TO. TRAVEL HOME.
SO THAT ANYBODY WHO BUYS IT
WOULD HAVE NOTICE OF WHAT THE
PROBLEMS WERE IF THERE'S
TERMITES OR- WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE THE KINDS OF THINGS TO
GET THROUGH HOME INSPECTION. TO
SOMEONE BUYS THIS. THERE'S SOME
LEVEL OF CONSUMER PROTECTION I'M
A SUPPORT THIS TODAY. FOR SERIES
OF REASONS BUT I DO THINK. I
APOLOGIZE YOU JUST TALKED TO
BEFORE THIS- AND THE SPRING THIS
ON YOU. BUT I DO THINK IS WE
THINK THROUGH. THIS DIAGNOSTIC
ABOUT WHAT THE CURRENT LAW IS
HOW IT'S UNFAIR. TO TWO PEOPLE
AND WE SEE. WE SEE THESE
HORRIBLE STORIES. BUT CAO THEN
YOU PROTECT THE CONSUMER ON THE
FLIP SIDE. WITH THE JUST MARRIED
OF THINGS THAT YOU KNOW AS A
REALTOR. THAT YOU HAVE TO FILL
OUT AND ALL THE REPRESENTATION
JEFF TO MAKE AND THE LIKE. AND
SO NOW YOU'VE GOT. A BUYER WHO'S
GOING TO PAY. THAT EXTRA MONEY
BUT YOU ALSO HAVE THE REST OF
COASTAL JUST THINK ABOUT IT I'LL
HELP YOU AND GIVE YOU SOME PART
OF IT I JUST WANT TO ISSUE SPOT
THAT FOR YOU. OKAY AND MIXTURE
IF I MAY- AMENDMENTS ARE
FORTHCOMING NO DOUBT. IN FURTHER
MEETINGS ARE FORTHCOMING. AND
I'VE SAID THAT TO THE OPPOSITION
THEY'VE AGREED- THERE'S NO DOUBT
WE'RE GOING TO MEET MORE TO.
CLEAN THINGS UP BUT- IF I CAN
HAVE OF THE ATTORNEY COME UP IN
ADDRESS- WHAT- CENTER WOULD COST
YOU HAD TO SAY. AND THE CENTER
I'M I'LL TELL YOU THAT. GRANTED
THERE'S THINGS AT THE OTHER END.
BUT WE'RE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SUFFERED. LIKE
TO WITNESS TODAY. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. THOSE THINGS AND WE'RE
ALSO TALKING ABOUT- THAT NEEDS
TO BE CLEANED UP THERE'S NO
DOUBT IN THIS IS OUR FIRST STEP-
IN THIS IS WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO GO FORWARD WITH THIS BILL.
BUT IF THE ATTORNEY WOULD LIKE
TO. ADDRESS THE THAT MR MAKOWSKI
THE BILL'S SLIGHTLY RESUME I'M
STRIDES OKAY THE REST OF OSTLER
GO AHEAD- YEAH THE FIRST TO THE
BANKRUPTCY ISSUE ON. THE WEATHER
THIS PROPERTY IS LAW STOOD ON
THE MLS. OR CONDUCT BY OCT. AT
THE COURTHOUSE- IT WILL BE IF.
THE CONSUMERS ABILITY TO FILE
BANKRUPTCY IN STATE THE ACTION.
OUT THERE STILL BE ABLE TO FILE
BANKRUPTCY AND STATE THE ACTION.
AT THE SAME WAY ONE OR THE OTHER
THIS DOESN'T REALLY AFFECT THAT-
AND- WHETHER THE TRUSTEE IS- THE
REALTORS ACTING ON BEHALF OF THE
TRUSTEE. FOR THE HOMEOWNER.
CURRENTLY UNDER LAW YOU KNOW THE
POWER OF SALE CONFERRED ON THE
LENDER- THROUGH THE MORTGAGE TO.
CONDUCT THE SALE SO. WHEN THEY
TAKE THE PROPERTY TO AUCTION
RIGHT THE AUCTIONEER IS NOT
ACTING ON BEHALF OF THE
HOMEOWNER. THEY'RE ACTING ON
BEHALF OF THE BANK AND SO IT
WOULD BE THAT IT WOULD BE THE
SAME SITUATION RIGHT THIS IS A
DIFFERENT FORM. OF TRUSTEE'S
SALE TRUSTEE SALE ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER- AND CENTER IF YOU CAN-
ART. CAN I MR YES GO AHEAD OF ME
LOU COMMISSION HERE IS THAT.
THESE TRANSACTIONS ARE WHOLESALE
TRANSACTIONS WHERE THERE'S NO
CONSUMER PROTECTION SO LET'S
ASSUME THAT YOU'VE YOU'VE GOT
SOMEBODY WHO'S A BUYER. THE
HOUSES HAS A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR MORTGAGE ON IT IT'S WORTH
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND. THE
HOMEOWNER HAS FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS THAT COULD BE. YOU KNOW
LYING ARGUMENT IS WELL BY
PUTTING IT ON THAT LISTING
SERVICE. THE ODDS ARE THAT
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO JUST GET ONE
OF THAT WHICH WE CALL ON THE
BUSINESS THE FORTY THIEVES. ARE
GOING TO COME AND TAKE IT AND
BUY IT JUST FOR THE UNDERLYING
MORTGAGE A PAYOFF THAT THE
BLENDER. WITH A SO THEY CAN MAKE
THE PROFIT AND SO NOW YOU'VE
CREATED SOME COMPETITION IN THE
MARKETPLACE. WHAT YOU'RE DOING
NOW INCLUDING COMPETITION IF YOU
BRING THE CONSUMER. THAT'S RIGHT
PROPRIA. BUT WHEN YOU BRING THE
CONSUMER AND- THERE'S NOW A
SERIES OF APPROPRIATE AND BE
IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS IN THE
LAW. ON YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
DOING YOU'RE NOW GONNA LISTED
BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE INSPECTION.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE YOU KNOW ALL
THE OF THE REQUIREMENTS THAT THE
REALTOR HAS. THE AMOUNT OF
HOMEWORK TO THE REALTOR HAS TO
DO IF YOU'VE BEEN IN THIS
BUSINESS FOR TWENTY THIRTY
YEARS. AND YOU'VE SEEN THE LAST
HOW BIG THOSE. FILES GET
COMPARED WITH THE USED TO BE
THIRTY YEARS GO. CONSUMER
CONSERVE. YOU'VE CHIU UP OUR NOT
TO. THAT NOT YOU SHOULD BE DOING
I'M JUST. IT NEEDS MORE. IN THAT
REGARD I UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERN- WHAT I BELIEVE IS THE
RESPONSE AND THE WAY THAT THIS
CONCERN IS ADDRESSED THROUGH
THIS PROPOSAL. IS THAT THE BUYER
IS ABLE TO SUBMIT. OFFERS FOR
THE PROPERTY WITH CONTINGENCIES
. WITH INSPECTION CONTINGENCIES
WITH THE PRESIDENT AND WITH THE
WITH THE WITH THE WHOLE THING
AND SO IF THE CONTINGENCIES
AREN'T LIFTED LIFTED IF THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO INSPECT THE PROPERTY
IF THE PROPERTY IS NOT A
CONDITION. IF THE HOMEOWNER
WON'T COOPERATE WITH THE SALE.
THEN THE CONTINGENCY WON'T BE
LISTED IN THE SALE WON'T GO
THROUGH. I'M IN THAT WAY THE
CONSUMER WILL BE PROTECTED
THROUGH THE SALES PROCESS.
UNLIKE THE AUCTION SYSTEM NOW.
RIGHT BECAUSE THESE THESE
BIDDERS TO GO TO THE AUCTION.
AND THEY DON'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK INSIDE THE
PROPERTY THEY DON'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THERE. THEY DON'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE OFFERS WITH
CONTINGENCIES. AND SO THERE'S A
LOT OF BIG DIDN'T RISK THERE
THAT DRIVES DOWN THE AUCTION
PRICE. OR THE PRICE MIGHT BE
HIGHER IF THERE'S AN MLS OFFER
WITH A CONTINGENCY ADDED AT
LEAST IN THEORY. BUT CAGES
MISTER ONE OF THEM. NUMBER ONE
YEAH BUT YOU'RE MISSING THE
POINT WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IS
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE LITIGATION.
LEFT AND RIGHT THERE IS AN
INSPECTION DATA ON THESE THINGS
I'VE SEEN IT I KNOW HOW THIS
WORKS. AND BUT THE INSPECTION IS
FROM SOPHISTICATED PEOPLE WHO
ARE LOOKING TO BOTTOM FISH
RIGHT. NOW YOU CAN ALL OF A
SUDDEN INTERJECTED CONSUMERS AND
THEY NEED TO BE PROTECTED. NO
BID UP THOUGH TAKES A HOUSES
THEY SEE ON THE MARKET WITH FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND IS A HUNDRED
THOUSAND. FIRST TRUST DEED AND
THEY'LL BUY IT FOR FOUR THOUSAND
BUT THEN WITH THAT COMES ON
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF SO YOU WANT
TO PROTECT THE EQUITY IN THE
HOUSE NO QUESTION. I JUST I'M
JUST TELLING YOU YOUR CAR IS A
LITTLE BIT MORE HOMEWORK TO
FIGURE OUT THAT BALANCE BETWEEN
THE TWO FOR HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION. THE SHERIFF I
MAKE. UP I'D LIKE TO BRING THAT
DISCUSSION BACK. TO THE PEOPLE
THAT. WE JUST HEARD WITNESSED-
TO THOSE WHO BEEN SUFFERED- THE
LADY FROM SAN FRANCISCO HER
STORY. THIS IS WHAT I'D LIKE TO
BRING IT BACK TO. WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THOSE INVESTORS.
WHO WRITE THOSE. MULTITUDE OF
CHECKS SHOULDN'T AND SO ON. THEY
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING THEY
KNOW WHAT THE GAMBLE IS- AND
THAT'S TO DO DIFFERENT SEPARATE
ISSUE. IT IN AND I WANTED AYE
AYE. AND OF COURSE WHEN THEY DO
SELL THE PROPERTY THEY THEY FIX
IT AND SELL IT FOR A PROFIT.
THEY'LL HAVE SOME DISCLOSURES
THAT THE BUYER WILL RECEIVE. SO
AT THE OTHER END THE BUYER WILL
BE TAKEN CARE OF THAT PARTICULAR
BUYER. THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. IS SAID- THAT
THAT YOU'RE A HOMEOWNER. WHO
COME FROM NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ARE
ARE TOUGH THE BLUE COLLAR DAY
SAVED ALL THEIR LIVES. THERE ARE
THEY'VE LOST THEIR HOMES AND
THEY WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
THIS IS WHAT THIS BILL ABOUT.
AND THIS. IS WHERE I MATCHING
FOR THE AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHTY-
OTHER QUESTIONS CONSIDERABLY.
I'M GONNA SAY SINCE IT'S ALL
RIGHT CABALLERO DID YOU OBVIOUS
I COULD JUST GOT CHOKED UP JUST
THINKING ABOUT THIS WHOLE ISSUE
OF SELF ALL RIGHT THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANTED TO THANK- THE- THE
WOMAN FOR HER TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY I'M SORRY I FORGOT HER
NAME BUT- IT WAS VERY
COMPELLING- I. UNDERSTAND THE
ISSUES RELATED TO HOW
COMPLICATED IT IS TO CHANGE A
SYSTEM RIGHT NOW THAT IS SET UP
TO DISPOSE OF PROPERTY VERY
QUICKLY I THINK THAT'S THE WHOLE
POINT OF. OF HER TESTIMONY IS
THAT IT WAS IT WAS UNFAIR AND
FUNDAMENTALLY TO BE PAYING FOR
YOUR HOUSE FOR TWENTY YEARS AND
THEN TO GET IT- STOLEN FROM FOR
IT FROM YOU AND SOLD IN THE
SEVENTH. THE PRICE OF WHAT IT'S
WORTH IS JUST OUTRAGEOUS AND IN
THE STATE AND SO- I REALLY AM
GLAD TO HEAR THAT THERE'S AN
INTEREST IN SITTING DOWN AND
FIGURING OUT WHAT THE SOLUTION
IS GOING TO BE- I'M NOT SURE
YOU'RE YOU'RE THERE YET BUT I'M
GONNA SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY
BECAUSE WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO
STOP THIS IT. AND THERE THERE
ARE THERE ARE WAYS TO BE ABLE TO
HELP PEOPLE BUT IF YOU THEY
DON'T KNOW ABOUT HIM THEN IT
DOESN'T DO THEM ANY GOOD AND
WILL CONTINUE TO SEE THIS HAPPEN
SO. I'LL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
IT'S GOING TO HAVE TO CHANGE IN
ORDER FOR IT FOR ME TO SUPPORT
IT ON THE FLOOR BUT I REALLY
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE- AND- AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW THAT I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS. BUT
THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK TO BE
DONE NO DOUBT THANK YOU CYNICAL
YOUR OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SAYING NONE. WHAT SHE SAID
SENATOR LAYERED SAID. ALL RIGHT
. IS THERE MOTION. MOVED CLOSER
HERTZBERG MOVES THE BILL ALL
RIGHT. SURGERY CARE CLOSEYES
THANK YOU MISS SHARED I THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH ME AND-
YOUR COMMITTEE AND OF COURSE
I'LL BE WORKING WITH EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU BECAUSE I THINK
WE DISCOVERED THERE DEFINITELY
IS AN ISSUE HERE THERE'S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT ALL
OUR CONSTITUENTS IN SOMETIME OR
ANOTHER MAY BE FACED WITH THIS.
AND IT IS OUR TIME TO ADDRESS
IT- WHETHER IT- IT'S FUNDAMENTAL
WHETHER IT'S SAID CHANGING
SOMETHING I WILL WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION DO WHAT WE CAN SO
WHEN WE DID THE SENATE FLOOR WE
CAN ALL SUPPORT IT. AND TAKE
CARE OF OUR CONSTITUENTS IN
THOSE. WHO HAVE LOST THEIR HOMES
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU BEFORE
WE GO TO A VOTE- SEARCH THAT
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION THIS IS
A CHALLENGING QUESTION A
CHALLENGING ISSUE NO DOUBT
THERE'S BEEN. SOME THAT AVE
BEEN HARMED YOU KNOW THE
QUESTION IS HOW DO WE RESOLVE IT
AND WHO RESOLVES AND WHOSE
RESPONSIBILITY IS IT TO RESOLVE-
IN THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES TO WORK OUT. I
THINK THAT SEVERAL OF US AND ALL
INCLUDE MYSELF IN THAT GROUP ARE
GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL. BUT
WANT TO SEE WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE
BEFORE IT HITS THE FLOOR BECAUSE
THERE'S SOME. I THINK SOME REAL
PROCEDURAL CHALLENGES STILL
REMAIN SO HAVING SAID THAT
MANAGE TO COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL. YES THIS IS THAT
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
THREE BY SENATOR ARE TO LET THAT
WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
ON BURKE I. AM BURKE AYE BURGESS
. BARBERO GUERRERO I WRESTLE
WRESTLE I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG BY JONES
JONES NO LAYERED LAYERED I STERN. WHAT KASKY. WIENER AYE WIENER
AYE- YOU HAVE SOME MEMBERS
MISSING BUT THE VOTE IS SEVEN TO
ONE SO FAR ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT
ON CALL. RIGHT NEXT WE HAVE-
ITEM NUMBER THREE SP ONE ZERO
THREE FIVE BY SEN CENTER EGGMAN
WE FEEL SLIGHTED THIS WEEK YOU
ONLY HAVE ONE BILL BEFORE US
RIGHT- WERE WONDERING YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT COULD HAVE POSSIBLY
HAPPENED ONLY ONE BILL. IN FRONT
OF US. I SEE OKAY THE CARD OKAY
BUT BUT I'M HERE I'M HERE NOW I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HEARING
THIS TODAY. THIS IS A ANOTHER
BILL IN MY APRIL PACKAGE AND WE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HEARING
THIS TODAY. SB TEN THIRTY FIVE
WILL ENCOURAGE MEDICATION
COMPLIANCE BY THOSE RECEIVING
TREATMENT THROUGH AN S. ASSISTED
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT PROGRAM
OTHERWISE KNOWN SOMETIMES AS
LAURA'S LAW IF MEDIC CATION IS
PRESCRIBED AS PART OF THAT
TREATMENT PLAN. THIS BILL WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE COURTS TO CONDUCT
STATUS HEARINGS. WITH AN
INDIVIDUAL AND THE TREATMENT
TEAM TO RECEIVE UPDATED
INFORMATION HOW IS THAT PATIENT
DOING HOW WAS THE COMPLAINTS
GOING ON A PART OF THE REGULAR
FILING OF AFFIDAVITS TO THE
COURT ESTABLISHING. AN
INDIVIDUAL'S CONTINUED
ELIGIBILITY TO THE OUTSET THAT.
BUT TREATMENT PROGRAM- IS THAT
IN THE END IT IS TO BE ABLE TO
ADHERE TO THAT TREATMENT PLAN.
DISSLY TO MEDICATION. COMPLIANCE
THIS IS THE BEST PRACTICES
IDENTIFIED BY EXPERIENCED AND
KNOWLEDGEABLE A. O. T. JUDGES.
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES REPORTING ON A. O. T. A
PLANTATION THEY NOTE THAT.
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS TO
ENCOURAGE AND ENSURE TREATMENT
PLANTS COMPLAINTS MAY INCLUDE.
BUT ARE NOT LIMITED TO INCREASE
NUMBER OF UPDATED HEARINGS
MEDICATION OUT REACH AND
ENGAGEMENT TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
AND OR ASSESSMENT. HENSCHEL
HOSPITALS. WE KNOW THAT
MEDICATIONS BEING PRESCRIBED WE
KNOW IT'S PART PEOPLE STRIPPING
PLANTER HAS BEEN SUB HESITANCY
FOR US TO SAY IT'S PART OF THE
PLAN- BUT WE KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA
SAY IS IT IS CAN BE PART OF THE
PLAN WE KNOW WHAT'S DONE IN
OTHER STATES. BUT WE'RE NOT
SAYING THIS WILL BE FORCED
MEDICATION FOR ANYBODY BUT JUST
THEM COMING BEFORE TO BE ABLE TO
TALK ABOUT THEIR COMPLIANCE OR
LACK THERE OF COMPLIANCE IN OF
COURSE ASSEMBLY WITH CONTINUED
NON COMPLIANCE CAN THEN BE
REFERRED TO A HIGHER LEVEL OF
CARE. THIS IS NOT SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT BUT JUST- CONTINUES
TO MONITOR I HAVE MORE FREQUENT
UPDATES POSSIBLY- AND REALLY BE
ABLE TO ENGAGE WITH FOLKS AROUND
THEIR COMPLIANCE. WE WERE GOING
TO HAVE TODAY THE HONORABLE
THOMAS M. ANDERSON- THE JUDGE IN
NEVADA COUNTY WERE OF THIS LAW
WAS FIRST IMPLEMENTED IN
CALIFORNIA- DUE TO OUR TIMING IS
NOW NO NOT ABLE TO ATTEND. BUT
RANDALL HAGAR THE LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH THE PSYCHIC
PSYCHIATRIC POSITIONS. ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA IS ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU MISTER HAGAR. IF
YOU'RE HERE PLEASE ANNOUNCE
YOURSELF. MISTER CHAIRMAN I AM
HERE. GO AHEAD. RICHARD SHERMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
BEHALF OF- JUDGE ANDERSON I JUST
WANT TO DELIVER A FEW REMARKS
BASED ON NOTES HE MADE I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF- HE SAID THAT SINCE I
ISSUE THE FIRST ORDER ON AN A.
O. T. ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT THE PATIENT RECORDS AS
ORDERED COMPLIANCE- WITH THE
TREATMENT PLANS INCLUDED THE
ORDER TAKE MEDICATIONS AS
PRESCRIBED AS WELL AS THE ORDER
MAY CALL WITNESS WITH YOUR
THERAPIST DR THIS IS AN
ESSENTIAL FIRST STEP. IN THAT
DIRECTION I HOLD STATUS
CONFERENCES GETTING THE
PARTICIPANT AND THE TREATMENT
TEAM IN FRONT OF THE JUDGE EVERY
TWO WEEKS OR MORE OFTEN IF
NEEDED FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
PARTICIPANTS I STRONGLY FEEL
THAT THE COURT'S ROLE OF
SUPERVISION IN THIS MANNER
CREATES A BOND OF TRUST WITH
PARTICIPANTS AND INSURERS- IS
SUCCESS IN THE PROGRAM HAVING A
PARTICIPANT STAND IN FRONT OF
THE JUDGE IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TO THE SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES NOT JUST
SUPERVISION. OF BOTH THE
PARTICIPANT IN THE TREATMENT
PROVIDER BUT IT ALSO REASSURES
THAT A PARTICIPANT AT THE
PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
AND ENCOURAGE THEM AND GIVE THEM
AN OPPORTUNITY TO VOICE THEIR
CONCERNS OR NEEDS- HAVING THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE- IN THIS BILL-
SB TEN THIRTY FIVE TO THE STATUE
WILL HELP JUDGES FOCUS ON THE
WHOLE TREATMENT APPROACH AND THE
NEED TO STAY AWARE OF THE
PARTICIPANTS PROGRESS AND
ENCOURAGE. THEIR SUCCESS THANK
YOU. THANK OTHERS IN SOME OF S.
B. TENDER FIVE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM SINGLE APPROACH IN
MY PHONE LET'S GO THE PHONES
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
THIRTY FIVE MATER IF YOU TO THEM
UP. NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. THANK YOU AND IF
YOU'RE IN PART PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. IT ADDED THAT WE HAVE
THREE IN Q. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY FIVE.
TENSIONING CARE MEMBERS ARE
SELECTED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS CROWD CO SPONSORED
THE BILL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AMBER MOVED TO
LINE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES YOU'RE A ROCK ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF STOCKTON
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND THERE'S ONE WITH
AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT. THAT
LINE IS ONE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MEMBERS THE STOCK IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
. YEAH NO ONE ON THE PHONE LINE
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION
A MR MAT GALLAGHER MR GALLAGHER
I BELIEVE YOU ARE HERE IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED IF YOU APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE. WALKING DOWN THE
STREET THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MATTHEW GALLAGHER ON THE
ACT AT B. HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S-
RESPECTFULLY WE STILL OPPOSE THE
BILL HOWEVER WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE COMMITTEE
MEASUREMENTS AND THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED BY SENATOR REGNANS
OFFICE. AND WE DO APPRECIATE
THEM WORKING WITH US TO DO THAT-
JUST ONE PRIMARY POINT OF
CLARIFICATION. MEDICATION CANNOT
BE ORDERED IN THE ORIGINAL
TREATMENT PLAN I WANNA
SUBDIVISION FIFTY THREE FORTY
EIGHT CITIES COMPLIED WITH.
DATES THERE THERE'S TWO
DIFFERENT SO WE GO STANDARD TO
THE COURT CAN ORDER TREATMENT
FOR THE COURT ORDER MEDICATION
THERE IS A WHOLE NEW PROVISION.
THAT HAS TO BE COMPLIED WITH.
LUCKILY THAT THE CURRENT VERSION
THE BILL ADDRESSES THAT. BUT
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE CURRENT BILL
WE HAVE SWITCHED UP THE
REMAINING CONCERNS FIRST IS. ONE
THE JUDGE CAN ALWAYS GET THAT
HOLD STATUS CONFERENCES FOR
WHETHER NON INDIVIDUALS
MEDICATION COMPLIANT WHETHER
IT'S PRESCRIBER IN THE TREATMENT
PLANT AND WE SEE NO REAL ADDED
VALUE INCLUDING THAT IN THE
STATUTE. SECOND THE AFFIDAVIT
COULD ALWAYS MAKE THAT
RECOMMENDATION AS WELL AND SO
UNFORTUNATELY UNABLE TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY WE DO APPRECIATE
YOUR EFFORTS AND THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US. SORRY THANK
YOU.OTHERS IN OPPOSITION SAYING
NO ONE HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED ON THE PHONE LINE THOSE
IN OPPOSITION S. B. TEN THIRTY
FIVE MODERATE IF YOU WOULD QUEUE
THEM UP. THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. OUR A LIST
FOR YOU BACK COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING
NONE- IS THERE A MOTION. SO
MOVED CENTER HERTZBERG MOST THE
BILL ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SIR I
MEAN YOU COULD CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- TODAY THE FOURTEENTH
BACK ANOTHER TIME ALL RIGHT WILL
AWAIT YOUR NEXT APPEARANCE ALL
RIGHT. THE USER EGGMAN MANATEE
COUNTS OF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS AT SENATE BILL TEN
THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR AG MAN
WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS TO PASS
ON BURKE HI I'M BURKE AYE
BURGESS. BURGESS I CAN BE IT'LL-
BE IT'LL I. DID ALSO. THE REST
SO I GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I.
HERTZBERG JOE. JONES I LAYERED
LAYERED HI STERN. WHITE HOUSE
SKI WINNER WINNER I HAVE NINE
TWO ZERO WITH A MEMBER MISSING
WHO WILL BE BACK ALL RIGHT WE'LL
PUT ON CALL ALL RIGHT NEXT WE
HAVE- I BELIEVE SENATOR ALSO IS
GOING TO BE PRESENTING CENTER
COM LOGGERS BILL- SO- CEREMONY
BOATSWAIN LIMÓN IS HERE. SHE HAS
BEEN VERY PATIENT SURVIVAL. SAN
RAMON ON NUMBER S. B. TWELVE
FIFTY I SAW THAT LOOK SHE WAS
EXASPERATED. AND JUST REALLY
RIGHT REALLY SAD SO FAR I THINK
YOU DON'T CARE FOR MAKING ME
SMILE AND MUTKO. SB TWELVE FIFTY
REQUIRES A RENTAL CAR COMPANYTO
PROVIDE A DISCLOSURE STATING HOW
MUCH A CONSUMER WILL BE CHARGING
CONVENIENCE FEE FOR USING A
WHOLE ORE BRIDGE IN A RENTAL CAR
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS MORE AND
MORE TOLL ROADS AND BRIDGES HAVE
MOVED AWAY FROM OFFERING CASH
OPTIONS. WHEN DRIVING YOUR OWN
CAR THERE ARE SEVERAL WAYS TO
PAY THAT FOR THE TOLL BEFORE OR
AFTER WITH RENTAL CARS THAT'S
DEFINITELY MORE DIFFICULT THESE
CONVENIENCE CHARGES CAN RANGE
FROM FOUR DOLLARS A DAY TO TEN
DOLLARS PER CALL CROSSING THE
CONSUMER MAY NOT FULLY BE AWARE
OF THE CHARGES UNTIL AFTER THEY
GET THEIR BILL. THE BILL WILL
ALLOW FOR MORE TRANSPARENCY FOR
THE CONSUMER AND WILL ENSURE
THAT THERE THAT THEY ARE AWARE
OF THE CHARGES AND THAT ANY
ALTERNATIVES TO PAID WITHOUT
INCURRING CHANGES CONVENIENCE
CHARGES. SO WE HAVE SOME
SUPPORTERS BELIEVE HERE NO AND-
YES ALL RIGHT. SOMEWHERE BUT
THERE NO THAT'S OKAY FIRST LET
US GO TO SUPPORT- A PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT CENTER MALL
NONE ALL RIGHT- ANYONE HERE IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED WAS
TESTIFYING SUPPORT SAYING KNOWN
APPROACH AND MY PHONE WAS TURNED
THE PHONE LINES THOSE IN SUPPORT
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF. SB TWELVE
FIFTY BY CENTRAL MALL. THANK YOU
HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AGAIN IF YOU'RE A SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
NO ONE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
LISTEN UP POSITION THOSE IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE LISTENED
PRIMARY OPPOSITION ANYONE HERE
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
OPPOSITION SB TWELVE FIFTY KNOWN
APPROACH AND MY PHONE BATTERY IF
YOU WOULD QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION SB.
TWELVE FIFTY. IF YOU AND IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF TWELVE
FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
. THE NEXT ONE THEN ZERO FEAR
THAT OPPOSITION. WHEN YOU HAVE
ONE Q. ONE UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE
ALL RIGHT.
THAT WOULD COME FROM- NINE ONE
THIRTY SEVEN FEET AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JOHN MOFFETT ON BEHALF
OF ENTERPRISE HOLDINGS- WHEN IT
THANK THE AUTHOR AND I THINK I
SPEAK FOR THE ENTIRE RENTAL CAR
INDUSTRY WHEN I SAY THANK YOU
THE AUTHOR FOR THE PREVIOUS
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE ON GOING
CONVERSATIONS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK ON
THE BILL TO MOVE FORWARD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT- NO
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS VOICED BY THE COMMITTEE
SALAMONE- WELL I'M SORRY LET'S
FINISH THE OPPOSITION ANYONE
ELSE OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
LINE. NO THERE THERE ALL RIGHT
THE BRING COMMITTEE SINGLE.
COMMONSENSE LIMÓN WHICH LIKE
CLOSER TO MOTION YES CENTER
HERTZBERG MOVES THE BILL. I
REQUEST FOR AN IRA ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THIS IS US
SENATE BILL TWELVE FIFTY BY
SENATOR LEE MON WITH THE MOTION
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION NUMBER NUMBER AYE
BURGESS BURGESS I CARRY AT ALL.
I THAT ARE SO. THE REST SO I
EGGMAN. ONCE I HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE JONES. JONES I
LAYERED LAYERED ICE STERN. WHITE
HOUSE SKI WINNER WINNER I HAVE
NINETY ZERO SO FAR WITH THE
MEMBER MISSING HE WILL BE BACK.
THANK YOU PUT THAT ON CALL-
NEXT- SENATOR THE ROSSO'S GOING
TO PRESENT. THE THERE ALSO WILL
WILL SB BUT ITEM FOUR YOU SURE
TO SPEAK AN EIGHTY- AUTHOR THE
RICH AUTHOR CENTER COM LONGER.
THANK YOU- THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
HERE TO PRESENT SB TEN EIGHTY
FIVE. ON BEHALF OF SENATOR COM
LONGER- I WANT TO BEGIN BY
AFFIRMATIVELY STATING THAT
SENATOR COM LONGER HAS AGREED TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDED BY THIS COMMITTEE.
AND WITH THAT AS WE TEN EIGHTY
FIVE SIX TO PROTECTING KEEP MORE
FAMILIES TOGETHER BY REDEFINING
QUOTE UNQUOTE NEGLECT
INDEPENDENCY COURTS WHEN
DETERMINING CHILD NEGLECT IN
JUVENILE DEPENDENCY COURT
HEARINGS. THE CURRENT OVERLY
BROAD DEFINITION CAN PUT
FAMILIES AT RISK THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE CRITICAL PROTECTION FOR
FAMILIES VULNERABLE TO
SEPARATION BASED ON FACTORS SUCH
AS POVERTY HOMELESSNESS AND THE
LACK OF ACCESS TO CERTAIN
RESOURCES. IN CASES OF ALLEGED
NEGLECT COUNTY SOCIAL WORKERS
INITIATE PETITIONS THROUGH THE
COURT THE COURT THEN RELIES ON
THE REPORT AND RECOMMENDATIONS
OF SOCIAL WORKERS. TO DETERMINE
WHETHER LEGAL ACT OF A CHILD IS
TAKING PLACE THE CURRENT BROAD
DEFINITION OF NEGLECT ALLOWS
REMOVAL TO BE INITIATED FOR
RELATIVELY MINOR SOMETIMES
TEMPORARY CIRCUMSTANCES RELATED
TO POVERTY. THE DEFINITION IN
THE WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS
CODE SHOULD BE REFINED. SO THAT
CONDITIONS SUCH AS A PARTIALLY
EMPTY REFRIGERATOR DAMAGE
FURNITURE OR TEMPORARY INABILITY
TO AFFORD CHILDCARE WHILE
WORKING A LOW WAGE JOB WILL NOT.
ALONE RESULT IN THE REMOVAL OF A
CHILD FROM THEIR PARENTS POVERTY
AND THE LACK OF ACCESS TO
RESOURCES ESPECIALLY FOR
HISTORICALLY MORE MARGINALIZED
POPULATIONS SHOULD NOT BE
FURTHER ADJUDICATED BY OUR
COURT. SEPARATING FAMILIES FOR
UNREASONABLE AND ARBITRARY
REASON. CERTAIN EXCEPTIONS
ALREADY EXIST FOR ONE LACK OF
EMERGENCY SHELTER TO THE FAILURE
PARENTS TO SEEK COURT. ORDERS
FOR CUSTODY OF THE CHILD AND
EVEN THREE I MEDICAL TREATMENT
BASED ON RELIGIOUS OR SPIRITUAL
CONSIDERATIONS SPECIFIC
EXCEPTIONS SHOULD ALSO BE
INCLUDED IT CONSIDER CONDITIONS
OF POVERTY AND A LACK OF
RESOURCES AS A PRESENT REALITY
FOR MANY PARENTS. THE STATUTES
IN PLACE AND CREATED THE
RELEVANT SECTIONS OF THE WELL
FRIENDS AND INSTITUTIONS SECTION
THREE HUNDRED. OUTLINING THE
DEFINITION OF NEGLECT WERE
CAPTURED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
SINCE THEN THERE HAVE BEEN MINOR
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES TO THE
LANGUAGE. HOWEVER NONE HAVE
ADDRESSED THE OVER ARCHING
DEFINITION OF NEGLECT. SB TEN
EIGHTY FIVE WILL ADDRESS THIS
LONG STANDING ISSUE BY BOTH
PROTECTING VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND ALLOWING SOCIAL
WORKERS TO MAKE MORE INFORMED
REPORTING OF NEGLECT WITH ME
HERE. IN SUPPORT IS AND EAT
MOZINGO AN ATTORNEY AND AN
ORRICK RIESEL RACIAL SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE FELLOW. AS WELL
AS STEPHANIE JEFFCOAT A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER AND IMPACTED
MOTHER BOTH WITH A NEW WAY OF
LIFE REENTRY PROJECT THE SPONSOR
ORGANIZATION OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALSO IF EITHER OF
YOU ON THE PHONE PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES. BUT IT'S PRESIDENT
ALL RIGHT AND WITH MISMAS
MOZINGO PLEASE PROCEED. IN ORDER
TO ROUTE THOUGH GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBER
I CAN'T EVEN THINK OF FAMILY
REUNIFICATION ATTORNEY IN ORACLE
JUST CALLING WITH A NEW WAY OF
LIFE BANTRY PROJECT AN LA BASED
NONPROFIT THAT PROVIDES HOUSING
AND SUPPORT THE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED WOMEN LOOKING FOR
COMMUNITY REENTRY AN INDIVIDUAL
HEALING WE PROVIDE HOLISTIC
FAMILY REUNIFICATION SERVICES
INCLUDING SUPPORT PERSON
ADVOCACY AND CHILD WELFARE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE NOT
DEPENDENCY COURT PROCEEDINGS. IN
OUR PRACTICE WE OBSERVE THAT IN
ALL STAGES OF DEPENDENCY CASES.
POVERTY IMPACT OUTCOMES. I WANT
TO GET OUT AND DIFFERENT WAYS
LIKE WHEN CONDITIONS OF. ARE AT
THE IN TWO WORKER. TO
SUBSTANTIATE HELD EACH RECORD.
INCLUDING RETAIN ITS FROM THEIR
- ARE PACKED IS BEING TOLD
WORKER REFERENCING. FAMILY HOMES
BEING AND- CONDITIONS A FAMILY
LIVING IN A SHELTER OR A SOBER
LIVING PROGRAM WE'RE NOT HAVING
A STABLE LIVING ARRANGEMENTS.
MOTHER RELYING ON AN OLDER
SIBLING FOR BABYSITTING. A
MOTHER NOT DRAFTING A CHILD INTO
WHETHER APPROPRIATE CLEAN
CLOTHES. TE MOTHER CONTRARY AND. ABILITY TO AFFORD DENTISTRY.
OUR HOME BEING STOCK WORKS OF TO
BE FAIR WITH MINIMAL. A HOME NOT
HAVING TO FOR AND APPLIANCES NOT
BEING IN WORKING CONDITION.
WHILE OUR PRACTICE ALSO HAVE
USURPED MANY COMMUNITY ORGS
INCLUDING OUR BOARDING PASSES
OCT BASE TO LIFT FAMILIES OUT OF
POVERTY AND KEEP THEM TOGETHE.
PARTICULARLY FAMILIES AT RISK OF
CHILD WELFARE INVOLVEMENT. THIS
IS BECAUSE THE HELPING SEPARATED
FROM OUR PRIMARY CARE GIVER HAS
PROFOUND LASTING IMPACT ON THEIR
DEVELOPMENT AND MENTAL HEALTH.
EVEN MORE RACIAL JUSTIE THE
FIRE SUPPORTING RATHER THAN
SEPARATING STRUGGLING FAMILIES.
IT OVERBROAD DEFINITION OF
NEGLECT THE FAMILIES VULNERABLE
TO IMPLICIT BIAS. IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND L. A. COUNTY THREE
QUARTERS OF CHILDREN REMOVED
FROM THEIR HOMES WORK FLAG NEXT
TO BLACK. BLACK CHILDREN WERE
FIVE TIMES MORE LIKELY THAN
WHITE CHILDREN TO BE THE SUBJECT
OF A CHILD WELFARE CASE.
REDEFINING NEGLECT WILL REDUCE
THE RISK OF ARBITRARY
DECISIONMAKING PERPETUATING
SYSTEM SYSTEMIC BIAS. YEAH WE'RE
SUPPORT FOR SB TEN EIGHTY FIVE
BECAUSE IT'S TIME TO HEAL AND
NOT AN ADMIRABLE FAMILY IN HERE
THEY GIVE US MOZINGO. OF.
MISCHIEF CODE ARE YOU AVAILABLE.
YES I AM GO AHEAD. BUT AFTER
CHERRY MEMBERS NAME FACT JEFFCO
AND I'M A COMMUNITY HERE ANYWAY
OF LIFE I'M IN SUPPORT OF TWO
EIGHTY FIVE BECAUSE POVERTY IS
NOT NEGLECT FOR OVER NINETEEN
YEARS I STRUGGLED WITH ADDICTION
AND CYCLE IN AND OUT OF
INCARCERATION I FOUND MYSELF
HOMELESS HAVE LOCKED MY CHILDREN
AND WAS THE VICTIM OF A SEXUAL
ASSAULT WHICH RESULTED IN
PREGNANCY. AT THE TIME I WAS
HOMELESS AND SLEEPING IN MY CAR
WHEN I GAVE BIRTH TO MY DAUGHTER
SHE WAS DETAINED BY CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES OF ORANGE COUNTY
FOR EXPOSURE IN THE WOMB MY
DAUGHTER WAS TAKEN RIGHT FROM MY
ARMS AT THE TIME SHE WAS NOT
SHOWING ANY SIGNS OF
MALNOURISHMENT OR ANY MEDICAL
EMERGENCY. SHE HAD BEEN BORN AND
HAVE NOT BEEN PHYSICALLY ABUSED
NOR DID HE SHOW ANY FIND ANY
EMOTIONAL DAMAGE THE ALLEGATION. TOWARDS ME REPEAT YOUR TO
PROTECT. I NEVER EVEN GIVEN THE
CHANCE TO PROVIDE HER WITH
ADEQUATE FOOD CLOTHING OR
SHELTER. THEY DIDN'T GIVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES TOOK ADVANTAGE
OF MY HOMELESSNESS AND
INCARCERATION IN A RACIALLY
BIASED MANNER. YOU THE MY
STRUGGLES AT THE CONVENIENCE. IT
WAS CONVENIENT BECAUSE LESS WORK
IF REQUIRED OF A SOCIAL WORKER
WHEN A MOTHER'S WHEREABOUTS ARE
UNKNOWN. OFTENTIMES TERMINATION
OF PARENTAL RIGHTS IN ADOPTION
HEARINGS ARE BASICALLY
UNCONTESTED IN A MOTHER AT IN.
MY CIRCUMSTANCES MADE IT EASIER
FOR THEM TO ACHIEVE ANOTHER
ADOPTION TO BOLSTER THEIR
STATISTICS. FOR THEM IT WAS THE
CONVENIENCE BUT FOR ME IT HAD
ROBBIA MY DIGNITY YOU PROCESS
AND MY CIVIL RIGHT TO
PARENTHOOD. SB TEN EIGHTY FIVE
WILL HELP BONTA BOTH FAMILIES
ARE AT RISK OF BEING SEPARATED
BY ALLOWING SOCIAL WORKERS. TO
MAKE MORE INFORMED DECISIONS
ARMY PARTY NEGLECT. IT WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT DISADVANTAGED
FAMILIES PRIMARILY FAMILY THE
COLOR. COULD NOT CONTINUE TO BE
THE SUBJECT OF THESE HARMFUL
PETITIONS. I DO THIS WORK THAT
OTHER MOTHERS OR MOTHERS LIKE ME. ARE GIVEN A CHANCE TO PROVIDE
FOR THEIR CHILDREN. BY IS THAT I
AM ABLE TO PROVIDED RESOURCE.
AND SERVICES TODAY TO. INSTEAD
OF BEING TORN APART.CONDITIONS
OF POVERTY SHOULD NOT ALONE BE
THE REASON TO PERMANENTLY
SEPARATE A PARENT FROM THEIR
CHILD. IT'S TIME FOR US TO WORK
TOGETHER TO CREATE LEGISLATION
THAT FOCUS MORE ON REUNIFICATION
AND NOT SEPARATION. THIRTY THREE
THIS TODAY I AM RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING YOUR I. ABOUT. THANK
YOU MR COAT ALL RIGHT OTHERS WAS
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT I SEE ONE
ONE PERSON HERE IN THE CHAMBER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN VERSE
CUSTOMER SCIENCES POLICY
ADVOCATE WITH LESSONS AND ALLOW
PARTY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU OTHERS THE CHAMBER SAYING NO
ONE ELSE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
MODERATE IF YOU'D- TWO OF THOSE.
ON THE PHONE LINE TO TESTIFY-
WHICH DESTROY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
TEN EIGHTY FIVE THEIR NAME THEIR
AFFILIATION THE POSITION. THANK
YOU AND IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. WE DO
HAVE LINE OF ONE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME IS IVANA GONZALEZ I AM YEAH
FROM LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND THE
COALITION FOR FAMILY UNITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TEN EIGHTY
FIVE. THANK YOU. FOR IN THE NEXT
CALLER IS ONE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE FROM ALL OF US ARE
NOT THE SACRAMENTO CHAPTER AND
HE WAS. CHILDREN AND STRONG.
WELL THANK YOU. THANKS LINE IS
ONE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HELLO THIS IS JANE TURNER ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WORDS SUPPORT
THANK YOU. IN MY MIND SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH HELLO
THIS IS CHRISTINA ROBINSON I AM
A BUDGET DIRECTOR WITH COMMUNITY
DEALERS I'M A MEMBER OF ALL OF
US AND THEN SACRAMENTO CHAPTER
AND I'M WITH NINE DONE AND- I
WANTED TO SAY THAT WE ARE
DEFINITELY IN COURT. WE AFTER I
CLOSE ON. IT THANK YOU I MEAN I
THINK THAT'S WHERE I THINK
ALREADY THANK YOU YOU KNOW AND.
FIVE SEVENTY ONE. OKAY HELLO BUT
BASIC. IN BRONX WORK THANK YOU.
MY ONE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YEAH YOU'RE YOU'RE
OPEN. OKAY AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DIANE FIGARO AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF A NEW WAY OF LIFE WE
ARE PROUD SPONSORS OF SB TEN
EIGHTY FIVE AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WANT NINE ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. C. C.
SECTION TWENTY NINE AND I AM A
FAMILY REUNIFICATION ATTORNEY
WITH A NEW WAY OF LIFE ENTRY
PROJECT IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. IN THE NEXT FIND AS ONE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
AM ALL OF THE NON FELLOW HERE
ANYWAY LIKE WE ARE ALSO CO
SPONSORED SB TEN EIGHTY FIVE AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S TURN
TO OPPOSITION- I HAVE NO ONE
LISTED IN PRINCIPLE OPPOSITION
TO S. B. TEN EIGHTY FIVE ANYONE
HERE IN THE CHAMBER WHICH
TESTIFIED. IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TEN EIGHTY FIVE SEEING KNOWN
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE LET'S
NOW TURN. AND IF YOU'RE AN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. AGAIN THAT ONE DIDN'T ZERO
IN OPPOSITION. AND NO ONE THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THAT'S PRETTY BACK
HERE TO THE CHAMBER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS- IS THERE A MOTION. OF
SET A CAREER MOVES THE BILL ALL
RIGHT- SENATOR ARE SECURE CLOSER
CENTER CALMER JUST ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR KAMLAGER READ YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU MEANT TO CANCEL YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL- YEAH. SORRY AND-
HE HAVE APPROACHING. THIS IS
THAT SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY FIVE
BY SENATOR KAMLAGER WITH THE-
MOTION BY SORRY. CABALLERO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
UMBERG HI I'M BURKE AYE BURGESS
. CABALLERO GUERRIERO I THE
RUSSELL DRESS SO I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE JONES. JONES I LAYERED
LAYERED I STERN. WHAT KASKY
WINNER WINNER HI YEAH. C. HAVE
M. EIGHT ZERO SO FAR WITH THE
MEMBER'S MISSING ALL RIGHT WE'LL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN AND I THOUGHT
I SAW SOME- CHAU BALL BUT SHE'S-
THERE SHE IS SHE'S IN THE BACK
AND IT THE RISK OF HAVING MY
RENT RAISED. I SEE THAT CENTRO
CHOI BOGUE IS GOING TO GO BEFORE
CENTER PORTANTINO'S BEEN
PATIENTLY WAITING AS A COMMAND
CENTER WHICH ABOUT. OKAY I IT'S
NOT YOUR RIGHT RIGHT- THE. THIS
TIME NO PRESSURE SHARE. WE HAVE
THREE OR THREE AT THE SAME TIME
OKAY WE GOTTA GET. ALL RIGHT OF
FILE NUMBER SIX SB TWELVE
SEVENTY NINE. FOR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR COMMITTEE STAFF AND
ALL STAKEHOLDERS FOR WORKING
WITH ME IN THIS MEASURE SB
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE WILL
STRENGTHEN AND CODE OF FIVE ZERO
TWO WHAT DO YOU DO ACCEPT
AMENDMENTS AS PROPOSED ANALYSIS
YES I AM ARLEDGE I FORGET. WE
ARE SORRY ABOUT THAT. HELLO
MICHAEL. BETTER OKAY SO- LET'S
SEE SO SB TWELVE SEVENTY I WILL
STRENGTHENING CODIFY SEVERAL
ASPECTS OF GUARDIAN AD LIGHT HIM
. ALSO REFERRED TO AS GAO
APPOINTMENTS THAT ARE OFTEN
OCCUR INFORMALLY OR WITHOUT
CLEAR GUIDANCE FOR LITIGANTS AND
THEIR LAWYERS THIS BILL WILL
RESOLVE AND AGREED EASE IN THE
STATUTE AS TO WHO IS CONSIDERED
AN INCAPACITATED PERSON FOR WHOM
THE GUARDIAN ADLAI ITEM MAY BE
APPOINTED ALTHOUGH THE PURPOSE
OF A GL IS TO ENSURE THE
INDIVIDUALS RIGHTS ARE PROTECTED
IN LITIGATION OFTEN THEY ARE
APPOINTED BY THE COURT WITHOUT
CLEAR PARAMETERS AROUND THEIR
POWERS OR WHAT THEY'RE REPORTING
RESPONSIBILITIES. ARE IN
ADDITION ALTHOUGH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL FORM REQUIRES DISCLOSURE
OF CONFLICT OF INTEREST ON
BEHALF OF THE PROPOSED JAIL IT
IS NOT CURRENTLY REQUIRED BY
STATUTE. THESE AMBIGUITIES HAVE
LED TO AN EVEN PRACTICES ACROSS
THE STATE CONFUSION AMONG
pEXISTING PROBATE CODE SECTION
ONE ZERO ZERO THREE SUBDIVISION
A AND THE CODE OF CIVIL
PROCEDURE SECTION THREE SEVENTY
TWO DO NOT SET FORTH CLEAR
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR JAILS
AND ALSO CONFLICT IN THEIR
DESIGNATION OF WHOM A GUARDIAN
ADLAI ITEM MAY BE APPOINTED FOR
. THROUGH THE CLARIFYING IN
MAKING CONSISTENT THE POWERS OF
JAIL INDIVIDUALS WE FURTHER
PROTECTED FROM ABUSE. I AM
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION. JOINING ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IS MATTHEW OWENS AND
ROBERT BARTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LOWERS ASSOCIATION
THEY'RE ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT- MISTER BYRD DEFEATED
A FOR YOURSELF. AT NOON-
TERMINAL BURKE. THANK YOU GO
AHEAD. MYSTERONS ACTUALLY BE
SPEAKING FIRST OF ALL IF BY
MYSTERONS GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US- I JUST
WANTED TO GIVE AND VERY BRIEFLY
ON A COUPLE OF POINTS HAD NEVER
MADE THAT THE BILL- SIXTY TWO-
ALLAH ABILITY SEMPRA GUARDED
LIED IN PRACTICE. IN OUR TOWARDS
A LOT OF THINGS ARE HAPPENING
INFORMALLY AND THE BILL WOULD
SORT OF FORMALIZED AND PROVIDE
STRUCTURE AROUND THE KEY POINTS
THAT IT ADDRESSES ONE OF WHICH
IS. THE SCOPE OF A GARDEN
OUTLINES OF FORTY IT IS NOT
ALWAYS CLEAR EXACTLY THE PURPOSE
FOR WHICH THE GUARDIAN ITEMS
APPOINTED AND THAT IS LEADING
THE TICKET TO SOME CONFUSION
WHERE GUARDIANS OF LIGHT ON. A
ACTUALLY- GO BEYOND WHAT THE
COURT MAY HAVE ANTICIPATED TO BE
THE SCOPE OF THEIR AUTHORITY OR
EVEN THE OPPOSITE PROBLEM WHERE
THE GUARDIAN DEADLINE- ARE TOO
RESTRICTIVE FOR CONSERVATIVE
WELL AND WHAT THEY CAN DO IN
TERMS OF THEIR FORTY. THIS BILL
IT WOULD REQUIRE THAT ANY ORDER
APPOINTING A GUARDIAN OUTLINES
AT THE SITE PACKED WITH THE
POWERS ARE THAT ARE NOT PART A
BOLD AND THEN ALSO- CLARIFIED
THAT THEIR POWERS ARE LIMITED TO
WHATEVER IS SPECIFIED IN THE
ORDER. THE OTHER THING THAT IT
IS IMPORTANT AS THOUGH IT IS A
REQUIREMENT KOMPLEKS BE
DISCLOSED AND IN A POINT OF
EMPLOYMENT IT'S NOT ALWAYS CLEAR
THE COURT OR THE PARTIES THE
NATURE OF THE RELATIONSHIPS
AMONG THE GARDEN THE PROPOSED
GUARDING AT LIGHT AND THEN THE
OTHER PARTY THE CASE. BERMAN ALL
OF. THAT THAT ANY COPY
DISCLOSURE THAT PARTY AN
OPPORTUNITY OBJECT THE
COURTHOUSE HAS NOT YET FULLY.
ANY POTENTIAL CONFLICT.
POLITICAL JUST PRACTICAL THE ONE
TO MENTION. YEAH I WILL. ASK FOR
HERE'S A ON AT WE TALKED NINE.
THEY YOU ARE A- NELMS BARTON. I
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN OF AGAIN
MEMBERS THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR HAVE ME
HERE. MY NAME IS ROB PARTNER I'M
A TRY IN THE STATE MEDICAID
PARTNER THE LAW RECALLING. I'M
HERE TODAY AS A MAN OF THE US
EXECUTIVE OF THE CALIFORNIA
LAWYERS OF PATIENTS SUFFOCATION
ALSO CONTACTS COME TO TESTIFY IN
COURT A BASKETBALL SEVENTY NINE
THE WHICH IS SPONSORED BY
TEXTRON. ON BEHALF OF TAX COME
WITH LIKE THE THANK SENATOR TOLD
VOGUE BRACHER AUTHORSHIP IN
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THE BILL BRINGS MUCH NEEDED
CLARITY IN OVERSIGHT TO THE
GUARDIAN AD LITEM PROCESS. WILL
HELP WHAT AGAINST ANOTHER'S LIFE
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS
AND PARAMETERS FOR THE
APPOINTMENT OF PARTY A LINE OF.
MISTER- AND HOW IT OF THE TO DO.
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE BILL. I
WANTED TO JUST BRIEFLY TOUCH ON
THE OTHER PERSON THE BILL. AND
THE SECOND PART OF THE BILL AIMS
TO REVIVE CLEAR PARAMETERS FOR-
MCCARTY AWAY TO MAKE IT
PLAINTIFF. TOGETHER WITH OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS SUCH AS DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO GET TO
WORK TOGETHER ON A LANGUAGE TO
ENSURE THAT THIS. AND THE CARDIO
ITEM PROCESS SERVES THE
INTERESTS OF ALL IT AGAIN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT THERE MIGHT BE A DIFFERENT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MISS MARTIN%
ALL RIGHT- OTHER IN SUPPORT HERE
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED SEEING
KNOWN APPROACH IN MY PHONE ON
THE PHONE LINE THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF. SB TWELVE SEVENTY NINE. MAR
IF YOU WOULD QUEUE THEM UP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
SEVENTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME BUT AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWELVE SEVENTY NINE IMAGE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THE
START OKAY- ALL RIGHT LET'S
LET'S NOW TURN TO OPPOSITION
ANYONE HERE IN THE CHAMBER IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE WAS HIS
PRIMARY OPPOSITION NO ONE IS
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE LET'S
GO TO THE PHONE LINES. THOSE
OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE SEVENTY
NINE. THANK YOU MR CARE AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME
. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE
SEVENTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT FOR
OUR LINE NUMBER.
ONE SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD ALL RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
BUT WE DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE MEASURE BUT WE DO APPRECIATE
THAT- SENATORS COLLABORATION
WITH OUR STAFF AND- WITH THE
PROPONENTS OF SMALL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO ADDRESSING OUR
CONCERNS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION SB
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN THE QUEUE
OKAY- LET'S BRING IT BACK HERE
THE CHAMBER. CENTER THE RUSSELL
. YES I JUST WANT TO ALSO-
ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA- I'VE DONE A NUMBER
OF BILLS- WITH OUR DISABILITY
COMMUNITY AND SORT OF JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THIS IS. A AND IN
THE RIGHT PLACE ABSOLUTELY
SENATORS I'M WITH YOU 1100% I AM
AND AS SOMEONE WHOSE- AS A NEW
MEMBER I'VE BEEN TRYING VERY
HARD AS I WORK THROUGH POLICY
WITHIN MY OFFICE THAT WE HAVE
ALL STAKEHOLDERS PLACE IN THAT
WE- TRY TO MAKE REYES HAD IS
POSSIBLE SO. I AM COMMITTED TO
THAT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS SIR MOTION.
THE BILL SENT A COUPLE YEAR
ALMOST THE BILL OKAY WOULD YOU
COULD CLOSE. CERTAINLY SB TWELVE
SEVEN I WILL CLARIFY AND
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS FOR
IDENTIFYING WHEN I. G. A. L.
SHOULD BE APPOINTED THIS WILL
ENSURE THAT ONLY THOSE WHO TRULY
REQUIRED A GL WILL BE APPOINTED
ONE AND PROVIDED ESSENTIAL
PROTECTIONS FOR THESE
POPULATIONS BY INCREASING
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ONCE THEY ARE APPOINTED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR-
MENDOCINE IF YOU ALSO. AVAILABLE
WHILE HE WILL BE UP NEXT. THANK
YOU COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL
THE ROLL YES THIS IS SENATE BILL
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE BY SENATOR
WOULD SHOW UP BELOW- WITH THE
MOTION BY SENATOR CAFIERO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED-
BURKE HI I'M BURKE I BORDUAS.
CABALLERO CABALLERO AYE IN THE
RUSSELL THE REST SO I A GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE JONES JONES I LAYERED
LAYERED ICE TURNED. WHY CASKEY.
WINNER WIENER AYE A- GIVE EIGHT
ZERO WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL
THANK YOU- I UNDERSTAND CENTER
PORTANTINO HIS OF AGREED TO HAVE
A- SIMILAR CAFIERO CENTER
COMMUNITY PUSH PRESENT NEXT.
THANK THIS. IS. ONE AFTER SUMMER
CABALLERO THEN CENTERED THE
RUSSELL WELL I'M SORRY THEN
CENTER PORTANTINO IF HE'S
AVAILABLE AND THEN CENTER THERE
ALSO AND THEN WE WILL RECESS
UNTIL. FOR THURSDAY THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB ELEVEN
FIFTY FIVE WHICH REQUIRES A TIME
LIMITED DEMAND SETTLEMENT IN A
PERSONALLY PERSONAL INJURY CLAIM
TO REMAIN OPEN FOR TWENTY ONE
BUSINESS DAYS TO ALLOW INSURERS
ADEQUATE TIME TO RESPOND TO THE
DEMAND- AND IF I COULD HEAR
MISTER CHAIR I APPRECIATE ALL
THE HARD WORK THAT THE
COMMITTEE- DID AS WELL AS THE
DISCUSSIONS I HAD WITH WITH YOU
AS THE CHAIR AND I'M ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE LISTED
IN THE- IN THE- IN THE IN THE
NELSON ANALYSIS YES THANK YOU
CYNICAL HERE EIGHT I'M- AND IS A
SETTLEMENT OFFER MADE BY A
CLAIMANT. TO THE INSURER OF A
DEFENDANT. THIS IMPLIES A
SETTLEMENT OFFER OFTEN COMES
WITH THE TIME LIMIT AND THE TIME
LIMITS HAVE BECOME SHORTER AND
SHORTER SOMETIMES AS LITTLE AS
FIVE DAYS WHICH MAKES IT IS
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR INSURERS
TO PROPERLY INVESTIGATE A CLAIM
WHEN USED CORRECTLY TIME LIMITED
DEMANDS FACILITATE A QUICKER
SETTLEMENT REDUCE LITIGATION
COSTS AND ALLOW INSURERS TO
CLOSE A CLAIM BENEFITING THE
CLAIMANT THE INSURER AND THE
COURTS HOWEVER THE CLEAR CURRENT
PROCESS IS SUSCEPTIBLE TO ABUSE
BECAUSE IF THE INSURER DOES NOT
RESPOND TO THE OFFER WITHIN THE
TIME LIMITS AND ARE GIVEN. IN
THE OFFER IS CONSIDERED REJECTED
AND PUNITIVE PENALTIES MAY
ACCRUE GIVEN THE COMPLEX
INFORMATION NEEDED TO CONCLUDE A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT INSURANCE
COMPANIES NEED AN APPROPRIATE
TIME FRAME TO INVESTIGATE
INVESTIGATE A CLAIM BY GATHER
RELEVANT DATA AND DOCUMENTS
UNFORTUNATELY IT IS BECOME A
LITIGATION TACTIC TO PRESSURE
SETTLEMENT WITHOUT ALLOWING
SUFFICIENT TIME TO FULLY
INVESTIGATE THE CLAIM AND TO SET
UP THE INSURER FOR A BAD FAITH
LAWSUIT. CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
SPECIFY HOW MUCH TIME SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED ADEQUATE IN A TIME
LIMITED DEMAND SETTLEMENT. S. B.
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE WILL CREATE
REASONABLE FEARS AND GUIDELINES
THAT MUST BE FOLLOWED WHEN A
TIME LIMITED DEMAND IS MADE TO
AN INSURANCE COMPANY. THIS BILL
WILL HELP INSURERS MEET THEIR
OBLIGATION TO INVESTIGATE CLAIMS
THOROUGHLY AND PROMPTLY BY
REQUIRING INFORMATION AND
DOCUMENTATION BE INCLUDED IN A
PLAINTIFFS THE- TIME LIMITED
DEMAND WHICH WILL HELP SPEED UP
THE PROCESS. SB ELEVEN FIFTY
FIVE CONTAINS NO PROVISIONS TO
CREATE UNNECESSARY STEPS.
PLAINTIFF TO FOLLOW TO SETTLE
THEIR CLAIM THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL IS WRITTEN CLEARLY FOR THE
PLAINTIFF'S ATTORNEY TO OUTLINE
WHAT INFORMATION IS NEEDED BY
THE DEFENDANT. TO ENSURE ACCESS
TO A TIMELY SET SETTLEMENT
TESTIFYING REMOTELY IN SUPPORT
IS PETER KLAY AN EXPERT ATTORNEY
REPRESENTING SHEPPARD MULLIN.
THANK YOU SIR CABALLERO WE WILL
NOW GO ON TO THE LINE IN SUPPORT
WITH PETER KLAY. PETER FOR THEIR
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN YEAH HERE
CLICK HERE YES. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
SPEAK BECAUSE I HAVE A
BACKGROUND THAT PROVIDES ME WITH
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE A UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE REGARDING THESE
ISSUES I'VE BEEN HANDLING. CASES
INVOLVING INSURANCE CLAIMS
HANDLING ISSUES FOR OVER THIRTY
FIVE YEARS. I'M A CO AUTHOR OF
THE RIDER GUIDE INSURANCE
LITIGATION PRACTICE GUIDE WHICH
IS CALIFORNIA'S LEADING TREATISE
ON INSURANCE LAW. AND SO I HAVE
A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE FROM THE
TRENCHES I LIKE TO SHARE WITH
YOU WHY THIS BILL IS NECESSARY
AND APPROPRIATE. IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS ALONE I'VE HANDLED
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF CASES
INVOLVING THE ISSUES IMPLICATED
BY THE- THIS BILL. IN ALMOST
EVERY ONE OF THOSE CASES. THE
INSURANCE COMPANY WANTED TO
SETTLE WITHIN THE POLICY LIMIT
AND MADE AN OFFER TO DO SO.
REFUSE TO SETTLE FOR THE POLICY
LIMIT BASED ON AN ARGUMENT. THAT
THE- INSURANCE COMPANY HAD AN
EARLIER OPPORTUNITY. TO ACCEPT
THE TIME LIMITED DEMAND BUT
DIDN'T ACCEPT IT. BUT THE TRUTH
OF THE MATTER IS THAT IN MOST OF
THESE CASES. RESENT THAT THE
INSURANCE COMPANY DIDN'T ACCEPT
THE EARLIER TIME WHEN THE DEMAND
WAS BECAUSE AT THAT POINT IN
TIME IT DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION. TO FAIRLY EVALUATE
THE CLAIM OR THE TIME LIMIT WAS.
SHORT IF FOR THE DEMAND INCLUDED
CONDITIONS THAT WERE CALCULATED
TO BECAUSE THE INSURANCE COMPANY
TO TRIP UP AND NOT ACCEPT THE
DEMAND. TO WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ARE CASES THAT COULD AND
SHOULD BE SETTLED FOR THE
INSURANCE POLICY LIMITS. BUT
THEY AREN'T AND THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS THAT
PROBLEM. AND ONE THING THAT THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY NOT
REALIZE IS THAT WELL THE BILL IS
HELPFUL TO INSURANCE COMPANIES.
MOST IMPORTANT BENEFICIARIES OF
THE BILLS AREN'T INSURANCE
COMPANIES BUT OUR POLICYHOLDERS
HEATING THE PEOPLE WHO. CURRENTS
YOU KNOW TECH THEMSELVES FROM MY
BILL. AND TO UNDERSTAND WHY
POLICY HOLDERS ARE THE ONES THAT
BENEFIT FROM THIS BILL YOU HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND. WHY INSURANCE BAD
FAITH LAW EXISTS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S THE LAW THAT REQUIRES
INSURANCE COMPANY JUST TO SETTLE
CASES. WITHIN THE LIMITS WHEN
THEY KNOW OR SHOULD KNOW THAT IF
THEY DON'T THERE'S GOING TO BE
AN EXCESS JUDGMENT AGAINST THEIR
POLICY HOLDERS. IF THAT HAPPENS
IN THE INSURANCE COMPANY CAN BE
LIABLE FOR THAT ACT THIS
JUDGMENT. SO THE LAW OF BAD
FAITH WAS CREATED. BY THE COURTS
FOR TWO REASONS FIRST WHICH TO
ADVANCE CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
POLICY THAT FAVORS SETTLEMENTS.
AND SECOND. TO PROTECT
POLICYHOLDERS FROM BEING DRAGGED
THROUGH LITIGATION AND BEING
SUBJECTED TO ACCESS JUDGMENTS.
THE PURPOSE OF BAD FAITH LAW BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS VERY LAW
THAT WAS DESIGNED TO PROMOTE
SETTLEMENTS AND PROTECT
POLICYHOLDERS. HAS BEEN
WEAPONIZED TO. BE USED FOR THE
EXACT OPPOSITE PER PURPOSE AND
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT. IS THAT
BASED ON THIS LAW ANYTIME THERE
IS A- CLAIM INVOLVING INJURIES
AND DAMAGES THAT EXCEED THE
AVAILABLE INSURANCE. THE GOAL OF
THE PLAINTIFF IS NOT IT SETTLE
FOR THE POLICY LIMIT BUT RATHER.
TO CREATE AN IMPRESSION THAT
THEY ARE TRYING TO SETTLE FOR
THE POLICY LIMIT. SO THAT THEY
CAN ARGUE LATER THAT THE
INSURANCE COMPANY SHOULD BE
LIABLE FOR WHATEVER JUDGMENT
HAPPENS AND THEY DO THAT. BY
MAKING DEMANDS THAT THEY KNOW
WON'T BE ACCEPTED BECAUSE EITHER
THE TIME LIMIT IS TOO SHORT. OR
THE AND FOR IN THE THEY'RE NOT-
ACCOMPANIED BY ADEQUATE
INFORMATION FOR THE INSURANCE
COMPANY CAN FAIRLY EVALUATE WHAT
THE DAMAGES ARE WORTH OR THEY
MAY ENGAGE IN OTHER TACTICS TO
MAKE IT APPEAR THAT THE
INSURANCE COMPANY. HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SETTLE BUT THEN
THEY ARGUE THAT CURRENT COMPANY
SHOULD BE LIABLE FOR ANY
RESULTING JUDGMENT BUT WHO IS
THE TRUE VICTIM OF THIS TACTIC
THE TRUE VICTIM. IS THE POLICY
HOLDER- BECAUSE THERE IS NO
SETTLEMENT IS DRAGGED THROUGH
SOMETIMES YEARS OF LITIGATION
AND SOMETIMES SUBJECTED. TO AN
EXCESS JUDGMENT THAT IS PUT ON
THE RECORD ALL BECAUSE THAT IS
PART OF THE TACTIC THAT IS.
DESIGNED TO TRY- MAKE. COMPANY
PAY MORE THAN POLICY LIMIT AND
LIKE I INDICATED IN IN MANY AND
I WOULD SAY MOST OF THE CASES IN
WHICH- THERE IS NOT A POLICY
MINISTER. BECAUSE YOU SURE AS
COMPANY THANK YOU MR ALLEY
UTILITY. THANK YOU M. I. A. R.
MY FOR MINUTES AT YOUR FOUR
MINUTES ARE UP. SO MAYBE YOU GOT
ONE MORE SENTENCE. I DO I MY
FILES AND IT SIMPLY THAT IS IT
IS SIMPLY THAT THE BILL DOES NOT
PROTECT INSURANCE COMPANIES THAT
DON'T WANT TO ACT FAIRLY THE
CARD RIGHT OR IF INSURANCE IS
NOT ONE ACTUAR LEASES IN THAT SO
THAT SO LET'S A LONG SENTENCE
THANK YOU SIR ALL RIGHT I JUST
NEED YOU SUPPORT THE BILL. SOME
ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT. BEING THAT
THERE'S NO OTHER WITNESSES-
PRIMARY WITNESSES. ANYWAY THIS
IS HERE IN THE CHAMBER. AERIAL
IF YOU PRODUCE A MICROPHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS ALSO
EIGHTY ON BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA VERY HAPPY SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL WE'D LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR I THINK THE CHAIR IN
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE WORK ON
THIS BILL AND WE ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH MYSTICALLY. THANK
YOU. MARKET SEGMEN AMERICAN
PROPERTY CALTRAIN SORTS OF
STATION ALSO SPONSORED BILL AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SHERRIE MCKIE REPRESENT THE
PACIFIC ASSOCIATION OF DOMESTIC
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU OTHERS
HERE THE CHAMBERS SAYING NO ONE
ELSE IN THE CHAMBER ON THE PHONE
LINE THOSE. SUPPORT NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION THOSE ON
THE- ON THE PHONE LINE IF YOU TO
QUEUE UP. OTTERY THOSE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT SB ELEVEN
FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER
TURNER AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE
THE RESULTS ONE AND THEN THERE-
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE MY FIRST ONE
AND THEN ZERO. NINE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MATURE NUMBER THREE ME
UP ON BEHALF OF CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA TRUMP
. THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE NEXT
LINE NUMBER. ONE ONE NINETY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DON'T WANT TO PAY FOR
THE DOCTORS COMPANY WE'VE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT THAT THOUGH GREAT
BY THE SPONSORS RECOGNIZING THAT
THE FAIR CLAIMS PRACTICES ACT
ALREADY GOVERN CHILD MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL LIABILITY CLAIMS
ARE TO BE HANDLED GOOD TO SEE
ANYTHING THANK YOU OR APOLOGY
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE NAME AFFILIATION WE HAVE
NOT. WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
HERE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT. ALL
RIGHT LET'S NOW TURN TO
OPPOSITION- THOSE IN OPPOSITION
MISTER PETERS WE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION- MR HAREL GO AHEAD
MISS PETERS MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M CRAIG PETERS
PRESIDENT OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY THE AUTHOR
THE SPONSORS AND OTHER
INTERESTED PARTIES ON S. B.
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE IN LIGHT OF
THE AUTHOR'S ACCEPTANCE OF THE
CAN AMENDMENTS. HE NOW HAS AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD. LONGSTANDING LAW
REQUIRES INSURANCE COMPANIES TO
ACT REASONABLY WITH THEIR
POLICIES HOPE POLICYHOLDERS
INTERESTS IN MIND WHEN
EVALUATING SETTLEMENT DEMANDS.
IF THEY FAILED TO ACT REASONABLY
AND REFUSED TO ACCEPT A
SETTLEMENT OFFER THE COULD A BIT
PROTECTED THEIR POLICY HOLDER
THEN THE INSURER CAN BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE FULL AMOUNT
OF AN INJURED PARTIES DAMAGES.
THIS IS A SIMPLE STRAIGHT
FORWARD STANDARD THAT SERVED
CALIFORNIA WELL TO ENSURE ONE.
INJURED INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE THE
RECOVER DESERVE TO POLICY
HOLDERS ARE PROTECTED BY THEIR
INSURERS. AND THREE INSURERS TO
ACT REASONABLY ARE PROTECTED BY
THE LAW. THE ORIGINAL VERSION OF
S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE WOULD
HAVE UNDERMINED FIFTY YEARS OF
CASE LAW THE SPONSORS BILL WOULD
HAVE SHIFTED THE BURDEN FROM THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO THE
INJURED PARTIES. ATTEMPTING TO
CREATE A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
LAUNDRY LIST OF CRITERIA THAT AN
INJURED PARTY WOULD HAVE TO
SATISFY OR RISK HAVING THEIR
REASONABLE STATEMENT DEMAND
REJECTED. THAT'S WHAT THE LATE
JUSTICE FOR INJURED INDIVIDUALS
EVEN WHEN. WAS CLEAR AND
REASONABLE DOCUMENTATION THAN I
DID I JUST LIKE TO SAY
PARENTHETICALLY THAT THE ISSUE
RAISED EARLIER ABOUT HOW IT IS
THE SURE THAT IS THE ONE THAT IS
AT RISK HERE THAT'S NOT TRUE IT
IS THE INSURERS PRESTADOS WHY
THEY'RE THE ONES SPONSORING THIS
BILL AND THERE BE A SIMPLE MIDI
. CHIU OF SURE YOU KNOW WHAT TO
DO. BRING THIRD PARTY BY FAITH
ALL THAT. WE ARE THE HARD WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE CHAIR AND THE
AUTHOR AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS MOVING
FORWARD THANKS VERY MUCH NAME
SPEAK MISTER HARRIS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ROBERT TERRELL I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA. I HAVE A THIRTY
MINUTE SPEECH I'D LIKE TO GIVE
ABOUT THE RIGHTS OF POLICY
HOLDER WELL JUST LOOK AT OUR
STUDENTS. RIGHT NOW I AM. WE AT
THIS MOMENT WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL WE DO APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THE- CHAIRMAN THE
CHAIRMAN THE AUTHOR. AND OTHER
INTERESTED PARTIES IN NARROWING
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL. I THOUGHT
THE ORIGINAL VERSION WAS WAY TOO
BROAD. A BIT OF A INSURANCE
COMPANY FISHING EXPEDITION IF
YOU WILL WE APPRECIATE THE
DIRECTIONS GOING WE THINK IT
WILL PROBABLY NEED SOME MORE
WORK WE'RE HAPPY TO PARTICIPATE
IN FUTURE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THAT. BECAUSE THE LAW TO THE
POINT INCLUDING MORE REPENT- OF
THE FARMERS CASE. WAS TRYING TO
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE HERE.
EVERYTHING WILL BE A APPRECIATE
AMENDMENT. AND CONTINUE TO LOOK
FOR TO SPEAK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD IN THE PROCESS THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHT THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
HERE THE CHAMBER IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. I'M SORRY. STRIKE THAT
OPPOSITION S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE COME FORWARD SAYING
KNOWN APPROACH IN THE
MICROPHONE. OKAY LET'S NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES THOSE IN
OPPOSITION S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER TURNER
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF
SB ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION SB ELEVEN FIFTY
FIVE. MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. THE BITNO COMMENTING HERE
ALL RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SEEING NO QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALL RIGHT IS
THERE MOTION. SOME OF THE BILL
THIS HERTZBERG MOWS THE BILL
OKAY- ALL RIGHT- BEFORE WE CLOSE
BEFORE YOU CLOSE CYNICAL REFERS
ALL THANK YOU FOR WORKING ON
THIS- BEAUTY WORKED DILIGENTLY
ON THE BILL- I THINK IT'S BEEN A
LOT OF PROGRESS. YOU KNOW IT IS
UP MY INTEREST IN IT'S BEEN A
LONG STANDING INTEREST TO
ENCOURAGE EARLY PRODUCTION OF
INFORMATION I THINK THIS BILL.
DOES HELP IN THAT REGARD AND SO
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THOSE
AMENDMENTS THAT DO INCENTIVIZE
THE EARLY PRODUCTION OF
INFORMATION ON BOTH SIDES SO
HAVING SAID THAT- COULD CLOSE
MISTER CHIRLA DOT THAT IS MY- MY
CLOSING STATEMENT THAT'S REALLY
THAT THE GENESIS OF THIS IS TO
GET EARLY RESOLUTION EVERYBODY
BENEFITS. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU-
IT'S BEEN MOVED- BY CENTER
HERTZBERG. OUR THANK YOU KELSEY
CALDERON THIS IS SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE BY CENTER COPY
IT ALL WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED- BURKE- BY- BURKE I
BOARD YES. ZERO ZERO I DID ALSO.
THE REST SO I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
I HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG AYE
JONES. JONES I LAYERED. LAYERED
HI STERN STERN I WAKE CAL SKI.
WIENER WIENER HI THAT'S NINE TWO
ZERO WITH A MEMBER WHO'S GOING
TO BE HERE MISSING OKAY LET'S
PUT THAT ON CALL NEXT- CENTER
PORTANTINO WHO'S BEEN PATIENTLY
WAITING IN AND OUTSIDE THE
CHAMBER SIR PORTANTINO. THE THE
I HEARD THAT SO ALL RIGHT. SIR
PORTANTINO I REMEMBER EIGHT SB
TEN SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OBVIOUSLY I'M
PRESENTING SP TEN SEVENTY NINE
WHICH WOULD ALLOW A PILOT FOR
SIX CITIES TO OPERATE A VEHICLE
NOISE WAS ADMITTED YOU DID YOU
ACCEPT THE AT LEAST SOME OF THE
MEMBERS PROPOSE SAN FORTINO
THERE ARE NONE THEY'RE ALL I'M
SORRY. OKAY I WILL I WILL MAKE
SOME UP AT THE END SO OKAY.
THANK YOU. I'M DEFINITELY
WRITTEN IT RIGHT RIGHT. THIS
ABOUT. THIS THE PORTANTINO OF
YOURS THE CAMARADERIE IN COMEDY
IS APPRECIATED- IT IS CURRENTLY
ILLEGAL TO MODIFY FECAL IN
ANYWAY THAT AMPLIFIES THE NOISE
EMITTED BY VEHICLES FOR THE
AVERAGE SIZE CAR THEY CANNOT
EMIT SOUNDS GREATER THAN NINETY
FIVE DECIBELS THERE IS CURRENTLY
NO UNIVERSAL MEANS TO MONITOR
AND ENFORCE THESE LAWS- EXPOSURE
TO LOUD SOUNDS INCLUDING NOISE
FROM VEHICLE EXHAUST SYSTEMS CAN
HARM OUR HEALTH AND WELL BEING
BY CONTRIBUTING TO HYPERTENSION
HEARING LOSS SLEEPING
DIFFICULTIES INCREASE STRESS
LEVELS CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE
CYCLE PSYCHIATRIC DISORDERS IN
CHILD DEVELOPMENT ISSUES
ADDITIONALLY LOUD VEHICLE NOISE
ALSO PUTS PEDESTRIANS AND
CYCLISTS AT RISK WHILE THEY ARE
ON THE ROAD AND OFTENTIMES THIS
LOUD VEHICLE NOISES ACCOMPANIED
BY OTHER RECKLESS BEHAVIORS.
SUCH AS STREET RACING AND SET
ASIDE SHOWS WHICH FURTHER
ENDANGER LIVES I KNOW THERE ARE
CONCERNS WITH THIS TECHNOLOGY
WHENEVER YOU INTRODUCE NEW
TECHNOLOGY IT'S APPROPRIATE TO
ASK THE PROPORTIONS SAYS STOP
AND TAKE A BREATH- AND BE
THOUGHTFUL AND WE'RE TRYING TO
DO THAT AND WE- MANY MANY.
TWISTS THE ACTIVISTS ON ALL
SIDES OF THIS- MY STAFF TELLS ME
ALMOST DAILY MEETINGS HAVE BEEN
GOING ON- ON THIS BILL ARE THERE
ARE SOME FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES
WHERE WE DISAGREE- BUT WE'VE
TAKEN MUCH OF THE CONCERNS WE'VE
GOT. AND HERE'S WHERE I THINK
THE CHAIR- WAS GOING WE ARE
PROPOSING OUR OWN AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS MANY OF
THE CONDITION MANY OF THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED OR REYES IN BOTH THE
NOW ASSISTANT FROM. THE ACTIVIST
AND SO HERE ARE THE AUTHOR'S
AMENDMENTS WERE PROPOSING WE'RE
ADDING A PUBLIC INPUT AND PUBLIC
HEARING REQUIREMENTS. THE
REQUIREMENT TO CREATE A SOUND
ACTIVATED ENFORCEMENT DEVICE USE
POLICY AT EACH PARTICIPATING
CITY. OF FURTHER SPECIFYING THAT
SIGNAGE DETAILS MUST BE PRESENT
WE'RE GOING TO CLARIFY THAT ONCE
A VIOLATION OCCURS THERE IS A
THIRTY WIN THE THIRTY DAY WINDOW
WHEN NO VIOLATION WILL BE GIVEN
AGAIN TO ALLOW TIME FOR
PREPARES. FOR CONTESTING THE
VIOLATION AND REALLY NOT PILING
ON TO SOMEBODY. WE'RE ALSO GOING
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
SPECIFICATIONS FOR THE EQUIPMENT
THAT CAN BE USED INCLUDING THE
IMMEDIATE DELETION AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT IMMEDIATE DELETION OF
ANY DATA THAT DOES NOT CONTAIN A
VIOLATION. AND SPECIFY THE
HIGHLY REVIEWED MANUALLY
ADDITIONAL. REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WILL INCLUDE AN
ANNUAL REPORT AND CONTRACTING
PROVISIONS THAT INCLUDE THE FOR
PROHIBITING OF PAYMENTS ARE
COMPENSATION BASED ON THE NUMBER
OF- VIOLATIONS WE THINK THAT
MAKES IT STRONGER AND FRANKLY
WE'VE HEARD. FROM THE CONCERNS
THAT. SINCE OUR- THE TO WITH AS
MANY. AS POSSIBLE NOW TRUTHFUL
FUNDAMENTALLY WE CAN'T ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF. WHETHER THE SHOULD
BE USED OR NOT THAT'S A
FUNDAMENTAL DISAGREEMENT AND MY
ARGUMENT. TO SOME FOLKS IS YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO CHANGE WITH
TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE TO
APPROPRIATELY CHANGE WITH
TECHNOLOGY BE THOUGHTFUL AND
WHETHER IT'S TODAY OR NEXT YEAR
OR FIVE YEARS FROM NOW- THIS
TECHNOLOGY ISN'T GOING TO. BE AN
WE IS BY LEGISLATORS AND
REGULATORS MUST COME UP WITH THE
APPROPRIATE- PLAN THAT RESPECTS
PRIVACY THAT DOESN'T ALLOW THE
DATA TO BE USED THAT ALSO
RESPECTS FOLKS WHO MAY BE CAUGHT
INNOCENTLY AND THAT'S WHY
THERE'S NO PENALTY FOR THE FIRST
VIOLATION THAT'S WHY THERE'S A
THIRTY DAY RIGHT TO CURE- SO
WE'RE TRYING TO BE AS PRAGMATIC.
AND A POSSIBLE AS WE ADAPT TO
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
TECHNOLOGIES AND SO WE THINK WE
HIT THE SWEET SPOT WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH ALL OF THE
PARTIES AS WE'VE BEEN DOING
THROUGH THIS WHOLE PROCESS- AND-
OBVIOUSLY WHEN APPROPRIATE I'LL
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE BUT I ALSO
HAVE BUBBLE FISH. WHO IS WITH
OUR SPONSOR STREETS WERE ALL
WHO'S GOING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ALL RIGHT
MR BY THE FISH AND FLOWS YEARS.
THANK YOU UNDER PORTANTINO FOR
OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT BILL AND
THANK YOU TO THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE SUCCEEDING THANK YOU
FOR THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE-
AND- CENTER I'M BURKE FOR THE
CHANCE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF IT
TODAY. MY NAME IS BUT THE FISH
L. PLATED ADVOCATE AT STREETS
FOR ALL IN L. A. COUNTY
NONPROFIT DEDICATED TO STATE
ACCOUNTABLE AND SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION. WITH THE PROUD
SPONSOR SB. TEN SEVENTY NINE AND
WOULD LIKE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. LUCIEN IS NOT MERE A
NEWS- IT'S A GROWING. HEALTH IN
OUR- ACCORDING TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN REPORT THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION AND THE U. N.
REPORT IN FEBRUARY HE DECLARED
URBAN NOISE POLLUTION ONE OF THE
WORLD'S QUOTE. MERGING
ENVIRONMENTAL. BUT STUDY IN
TWENTY NINETEEN BY THE PARENTS
REGIONAL. HEALTH AGENCY. FOUND
NOISE WAS CUTTING THE LIFE
EXPECTANCY OF PARISIANS BY TEN
POINT SEVEN MONTHS. LARGE SCALE
STUDIES SHOW THAT NOISE EXPOSURE
OVER MANY YEARS INCREASES YOUR
RISK OF HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE
CORONARY HEART DISEASE AND HEART
ATTACKS OR STROKES DIABETES
DEMENTIA AND DEPRESSION.
CHILDREN SUFFER NOT ONLY
PHYSICALLY BUT BEHAVIORALLY AND
COGNITIVELY AND WANTED TO
READING SCORES OF SIXTH GRADERS
MORE NEARBY URBAN ONLY ALLOWED
NEARLY A YEAR BEHIND THOSE OF
STUDENTS IN QUITE OUR CLASSROOMS
A DIFFERENT A DISAPPEARED ONE
SOUNDPROOFING MATERIALS WERE
INSTALL. ARBIL USES THE NINETY
DECIBEL AMERICAN LEGAL LIMIT BUT
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
DEFINES A THRESHOLD FOR CARDIO
VASCULAR DISORDERS AND HIGH
BLOOD PRESSURE FROM ROAD TRAFFIC
NOISE. AT HIGH DECIBELS OR
HIGHER. I AM EXPERT FROM THE AS
I LIVE ON WASHABLE ONE OF THE
BUSIEST QUARTERS OF CULVER CITY.
AN ILLEGALLY MODIFIED MUFFLERS
DISTURBING UNITY ON A DAILY
BASIS THE PROBLEM IS ONLY
EXACERBATED AS YOU CAN OF COURSE
HAVE SURGED IN POPULARITY. THE
NOISE LEVELS PRODUCED IT ALREADY
LEGAL I DON'T ENFORCEMENT THE
PROBLEM PERSISTS. SB CAN SEVENTY
NINE WILL ALLOW CITIES TO
ENFORCE THE LAW WITHOUT ARMED
POLICE ENFORCEMENT. IT'S
AUTOMATED NOISE IMPORTANT
PROGRAM IS MODELED ON THOSE
ALREADY IN PLACE IN PARIS
NASHVILLE NEW YORK CITY. ANY
DEVICE COULD NOT BE FOUND
ACTIVATED MEANING THE IMAGES ARE
ONLY STATE ON THE TWENTY LEGALLY
LOUD MUFFLER SOUNDS ACTED.
OTHERWISE THAT DATED IMMEDIATELY
DELETED. AND WE TREAT FIVE WORK
CLOSELY WITH OPPOSITION GROUPS
ACLU ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND THE FIRST TO TELL
LIKE. TO ADD MANY PROVISIONS TO
PROTECT. PRIVACY AND- HELP NOT
HARM PERSONALIZED COMMUNITIES
OFTEN DOES. IMPACTED BY ST
RACING NIGHT SCHOOL. FROM EQUITY
PER WE LOOK TO CONCERNS CHANGE
THE TO A STICK MILE PROGRAM WITH
THE FIND THE NOT ADDED A WORN
FOR FIRST TIME BY IT OPPORTUNIST
FOR LOW INCOME ON. ABOUT HER
PERIOD BETWEEN VIOLATIONS WERE
NO ADDITIONAL VIOLATIONS CAN BE
ISSUED IT'S ALSO WORTH NOTING
THAT THE REVENUES OF THIS
PROGRAM ARE EARMARKED TO BE USED
FOR TRAFFIC CALMING MEASURES TO
MAKE OUR STREETS AND COMMUNITY
STAKE BURKE AND WE'RE WORKING TO
SEE IF WE CAN INCLUDE A WAY TO
HELP FOLKS WITH THESE DEVICES
SWAP. OUT FOR A LEGAL ONE ON THE
PRICEY SIDE WE ADDED PROVISIONS
MANDATE PROCEEDED TO DESTROY
UPON THE RESOLUTION OF
VIOLATIONS INCLUDED REQUIREMENT
TO DELETE THE DATA UPON
RESOLUTION OF THE TICKET. AND
THEN MANDATED YEARLY AUDIT OF
THE SYSTEM TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
IT ALSO ADDED INCLUDE DETAILED
REQUIREMENTS EACH VIOLATION
INCLUDING EVIDENCE. IN A CLEAR
DISPUTE. THE SPECIFIED PROGRAM
IS RUN BY TRANSFER. DEPARTMENT
NOT LONG. SIMILAR TO A PARKING
TICKET. AND IT PROHIBITS THE USE
OF THE DATA FROM THESE
VIOLATIONS TO BE USED IN ANY
OTHER MANNER OTHER THAN THE
ISSUING THE TICKETS BY ANY OTHER
AGENCY. I URGE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT BILL
AND HELP US CONTINUE TO MAKE
PROGRESS ON OUR SHARED GOAL OF
CREATING PEACEFUL. I'LL BE URBAN
ENVIRONMENTS FOR EVERYONE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU WAS FISH
IF THERE IS ANOTHER- PRIMARY
WITNESS AND SUPPORT YOU HAVE
FORTY FIVE SECONDS SEEING NONE
NONE OF THE CAMBER ON THE PHONE
LINE. LET'S TURN TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU MISTER
TURNER AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN SEVENTY NINE.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. BUT YOU CAN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IF SUPPORTERS SB
TEN SEVENTY NINE. PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER KAREN MEMBERS FILL THE A
POLICE SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT FOR OUR
NEXT MY NUMBER.
LINE ONE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS MARK THE **** I'M
LIVE IN ORANGE COUNTY AND I'M
REALLY PROUD THAT SUPPORT THIS
BELT THAT TALKING ON THE
IMPORTANT ISSUE CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT FOR
ATTACKS MY NUMBER.
NINE ONE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS ERIKA
DAWN ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
LAGUNA BEACH IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN Q. RT THANKS
VERY MUCH OKAY. LET'S NOW TURN
TO OPPOSITION. I HAVE- BECCA
KRAMER MILDER IN OPPOSITION.
DAVID BECKER KRAMER MATTER ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
HE WENT SEVEN EIGHT TEN SEVENTY
NINE. DESPITE THE AUTHORED GOOD
INTENTIONS AUTOMATED ENFORCEMENT
SYSTEM BUT THOSE OPERATED BY THE
CELEBRATE MEMORY HI THIS AND
EQUITY CONCERNS. I AND FAIRNESS
OF NINE ACTIVE SURVEY TECHNOLOGY
QUESTIONABLE AND HAVE BEEN SHOWN
IN MANY PLACES THAT HAVE NO
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON PORTSMOUTH
FOR REDUCTION OF THE UNDERLYING
. ALTHOUGH FOR EXAMPLE EIGHTY
EIGHT POINT 7% OF THE ALERT FROM
DYNAMITE ACTIVATED SURVEILLANCE
TECHNOLOGIES WERE FOUND HAVE
BEEN INACCURATE WELL REPORT ON
THE TECHNOLOGY FOUND THAT IT HAD
NO SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON GUN
RELATED HOMICIDES OVER TWO
DECADES AND ACROSS. EACH
JURISDICTION. FINEST TECHNOLOGY
TO LOUD VEHICLES REASONS EVEN
GREATER CONCERNS ABOUT ITS
ACCURACY AND EFFECTIVENESS. IT
IS UNABLE TO ACCURATELY
DETERMINE WHETHER A GUN WAS
FIRED IN A PARTICULAR AREA HOW
CAN THIS TECHNOLOGY ACCURATELY
DETERMINE WHETHER A VEHICLE
EXCEEDED THE LEGAL LIMIT A NICE
LEVEL. SPECIALLY WITH VARYING
NOISE LIMITS DEPENDING ON THE
TYPE IN THE YEAR OF THE VEHICLE
LET ALONE WHICH VEHICLE IN A
CROWDED ROADWAY WITH MULTIPLE
LANES IS TRIGGERING THE SOUND
ACTIVATED ENFORCEMENT THAT I.
NOT AND QUESTION PILOT PROGRAM
CAN'T FOR EXAMPLE DEMOCRATS.
COULDN'T TELL THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WORKERS OF NOISE OR
IDENTIFIES. VEHICLES THE
PRECISION REQUIRED BY COURT.
BACK WE MIGHT MONTH PALETTE HI
THE CITY A HUNDRED NINETY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS. BIRKENAU COSTS
AND YIELDED ONLY ONE ENFORCEMENT
OF MY POLLUTION NOT. THE AUTHOR
THAT HAVE TO INCLUDE PRIVATE ACT
PROVIDE. HOWEVER IN THE BILL
FALLS SHORT DEFINITELY THE BILL
RATE IS IMPORTANT PASS A
QUESTION. THE NEED FOR REDUCING
NOISE POLLUTION DOES NOT WARRANT
THE CREATION OF A NEW MECHANISM
FOR GOVERNMENT COLLECTION OF
LARGE AMOUNTS OF DATA ON
CALIFORNIA. REALLY IN LIGHT OF
THE HIGH ERROR AND THEN OF THE
TO. THAT NOT. ACTUALLY I YOUR
BUT THANK YOU PARTY THANK YOU
OTHER ENOUGH. HERE IN THE
CHAMBER SAYING NO ONE IN THE
CHAMBER ON THE PHONE LINE.
MODERATE WE QUEUE UP THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TEN SEVENTY
NINE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN. THE MEAT LET ME
INTERRUPT YOU A MODERATOR- J.
BIEBER. IS ALSO IN OPPOSITION MR
BIEBER ARE YOU AVAILABLE. I AM
THANK YOU GO AHEAD A GOOD
AFTERNOON TO TERMS OF GERMAN
NUMBER AGAIN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SET UP FOR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
SAFE STREETS LA PERSON WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR TO STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US IN GOOD FAITH
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESS MANY OF
OUR CONCERNS. HOWEVER A NUMBER
OF ISSUES ARE STILL OUTSTANDING
SUCH AS LIMITING HOW ANY EXCESS
REVENUE CAN BE USED TO ENSURE
THAT THESE DEVICES ARE NOT USED
AS A REVENUE GENERATING PROGRAM.
AND INCLUDING LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL THE PILOT PROGRAM CANNOT BE
EXPANDED OR EXTEND THE REQUIRED
REPORT BACK TO. YOUR HAS BEEN
RECEIVED AND EVALUATED WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT UNDER A PILOT
PROGRAM THE NUMBER OF DEVICES
FOR SIX P. SIGNIFICANTLY LIMIT.
THEIR OTHER CONCERNS ARE
OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. GIVEN THE GOOD
APPLICATION HOWEVER WE STILL
BELIEVE THAT THIS TECHNOLOGY.
CANNOT WORK UNDER CALIFORNIA
LAW. USE RELATING TO IS AUTHOR
TO ISSUE. AND IN TWO UNIVERSE.
PARTY FOR THIS VIOLATION. IF
THIS BILL BECOMES LAW AS
WRITTEN. TICKET ISSUED BY THE
SYSTEMS WOULD LIKELY NOT BE
ENFORCEABLE. PASSING SUCH A LAW
WOULD BE ILL ADVISED AND IT
WOULD LEAD TO NUMEROUS LEGAL
CHALLENGES AND SEND THE WRONG
MESSAGE TO WILLFUL VIOLATORS.
TRYING TO FIX THESE ISSUES WOULD
BE EXTREMELY CHALLENGING WILL
REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO
THE VEHICLE APPEAL CODE
SOMETHING THAT WOULD IMPLICATE
DUE PROCESS CONCERNS IN GARNER.
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL WELLS
PROPOSITION. THEREFORE WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR
SERIOUSLY CONSIDER AMENDING THE
BILL TO ALLOW THE SYSTEM TO BE
USED FOR INVESTIGATORY PURPOSES
ONLY. AND NOT TO DIRECTLY ISSUE
TICKETS. THIS WOULD RESOLVE THE
FATAL LEGAL FLAWS IN THE BILL AS
WELL AS ADDRESS ANY OF OUR
CONCERNS. ABOUT THE SYSTEMS.
LACK OF ACCURACY. YEAH COMMITTEE
SUPPORTED TAKING THE BILL IN
THIS DIRECT. BARRING THAT WE
WERE. ASK YOUR NEW ABOUT. THE
YOU MR BEAVER OKAY- NOW MODERATE
YOU TO THOSE AND- TO S. B. TEN
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN SEVENTY
NINE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN A
POSITION OF FIFTY SEVEN SEVENTY
NINE. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
BY A ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REMEMBER HEAVILY AT THE END SAID
WITH CORBIN AND HI THERE ON
BEHALF OF ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION WE APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION THE AUTHOR AND
PONDERED HAVE HAD WITH THE F. UP
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
TOGETHER TO HELP OUR WITHOUT
DAY. THANK YOU. LINE ONE SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
IS TRACY ROSENBERG FROM OPEN
PRIVACY WE'VE ALSO BEEN IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
THAT WILL BE CONTINUING AND- THE
AMENDMENTS LOOK COULD BE
ADDRESSING ALREADY SOME OF OUR
CONCERNS ARE YOU IN OPPOSITION
MOMENT OURS. COOPER THANK YOU UP
IF WE COULD ASK THOSE WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
PROVIDE THEIR NAME AFFILIATION
THEIR POSITION. MODERATE TO GO
AHEAD. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS BY
THE COMMITTEE YES BUSTER WAS
CENTER GONZALEZ. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION IN
TRANSPORTATION YOU TOOK A NUMBER
OF AMENDMENTS THAT. REALLY FINE
TUNED- THE BILL MAKING IT MAX
SIX CITIES TO PILOT PROGRAM
VERSUS STATEWIDE- BUT THE ISSUE
OF COURSE STILL REMAINS ON THE
PRIVACY CONCERNS OF COURSE AS
MENTIONED I KNOW YOU'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH IT THE
OPPOSITION'S I'D JUST LIKE TO
HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS IF YOU WANT
TO ADD THAT IN YOUR CLOTHES
THAT'S FINE TOO- THE- EQUITY
CONCERNS BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE. I
I'M IN LONG BEACH AND- IN SOME
PARTS OF OUR COMMUNITY THAT ARE
UNDERSERED IT IS VERY LOUD
NATURALLY AND SO HOW DO YOU
DISTINGUISH WHAT IS WHAT- AND
THIS TECHNOLOGY IS FAIRLY NEW IN
ITS FIRST ITERATION AND I NEVER
WANT TO STOP INNOVATION BUT I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
BEEN VETTED. TO SOME DEGREE THAT
IT DOESN'T IMPOSE ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES FOR FOLKS. THANK YOU
. PAUL HAD A LOT OF MY CLOTHES
OF THAT. ALL RIGHT. AND JUST TO
CLARIFY A POINT THAT I MAY HAVE
- CREATED ACTUALLY THERE ARE NO
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE PROPOSED BY
THE COMMITTEE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU REFERRED TO CENTER
pPORTANTINO REMEMBERS THAT YOU'RE
PREPARED TO TAKE ON THE FLOOR.
AND I THINK THE BILL WAS LARGELY
CRAFTED SO YOU WOULD AVOID THE
PERILOUS PROCESS IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND SO
IT GOES STRAIGHT TO THE FLOOR IS
THAT RIGHT. I THINK IT GOES TO
APPROACH. BUT IT'S GOING RIGHT
TO THE FLOOR YOU'RE RIGHT I
THOUGHT IT WAS COMING TO ME. BUT
IT'S GOING RIGHT TO WE WILL TAKE
THOSE AMENDMENTS ON THE FLOOR ON
THE- OTHER PEOPLE ON APPROACH TO
. YEAH WE CHECK THAT WE'VE TAKEN
AND NOW I AYE BUT- YES
UNDERSTAND THERE MEMBERS TAKEN
TRANSPORTATION THERE ARE OTHERS.
AMENDMENTS THAT ALREADY- SO THAT
ALREADY INTO LEDGE COUNCIL RIGHT
THAT YOU'VE JUST TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER ON. I ASKED THE
QUESTION. THAT MAY HAVE CREATED
SOME CONFUSION JUST TO. MAKE
SURE WE ARE COMPLETELY CLEAR.
THERE ARE NO AMENDMENTS PROPOSED
BY THE COMMITTEE YOU HAVE
SUGGESTED SOME AMENDMENTS. THAT
YOU ARE PREPARED TO TAKE YOU'VE
COMMITTED TO TAKE. THAT'LL BE ON
THE FLOOR CORRECT SO OKAY ALL
RIGHT. AND CLEAR THAT AND AS THE
CHAIR TRANSPORTATION MENTION WE
TOOK A NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS IN
HER COMMITTEE WHICH WE WERE.
VERY HAPPY TO DO AND- THAT
THOUGHT THERE COMMITTEE AS WELL.
ALL RIGHT. BYE ELECTION THANK
YOU CENTER THE RUSSELL. YEAH I
WISH SIX COVERED HELICOPTERS
THE- OVER. OUR COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE THEY'RE LOUDER THAN
ANYTHING ELSE ARE LOUDER THAN.
ANY OF THE- RACERS THE COME DOWN
THE STREET IT IS REALLY
DISTURBING AND IT IS. IT REALLY
BOTHERS OUR COMMUNITY A WHOLE
LOT- HAVING SAID THAT- SOME
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS AND I'M NOT
SURE FROM WHERE HOW YOU MIGHT BE
ADDRESSING THEM- IS THE-
ACCURACY. OR INACCURACY. OF THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE HAVE BROUGHT
UP- THAT'S ONE. WHICH THEN LEADS
TO I THINK THERE WAS A- A RECORD
OF THE SUGGESTION THAT YOU TEST
THE TECHNOLOGY- PRIOR TO
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING GIVING
TICKETS OUT. OF AND I THINK-
SIMILAR DISSENTER GONZALEZ YOU
KNOW THE EQUITY ISSUE. WHICH
COMMUNITIES ARE GOING TO BE. THE
MY- THE NUMBER THINGS THAT
HAPPEN THAT IMPACT FOR
COMMUNITIES MORE THAN THAN OTHER
COMMUNITIES- AND- I TAKES MORE
DETAILED QUESTIONS BUT IF A
MOTORIST GETS A VIOLATION-
RECEIVES A VIOLATION HOW DO THEY
HOW DO THEY FIGHT THAT TICKET
YOU KNOW. IF THEY GET A CITATION
. WHAT IS THEIR WAY OF FIGHTING
BACK- I KNOW I GOTTA TAKE IT
ONCE. AND I TRIED TO FIGHT IT OF
FOR GOING THROUGH AN
INTERSECTION WITH A I WILL GO
ANY MORE DETAILS BUT- THERE WAS
RIGHT DO YOU VIEW IS THAT RIGHT
DOES YOUR LAWYER I'D SUGGEST GO
AHEAD. ANYWAY IT WAS A PICTURE
WITH YOU KNOW THAT IS THAT
CAMERON THE INTERSECTION AND- NO
MATTER WHAT I DID I JUST I JUST
COULDN'T FIGHT FIGHT THAT TICKET
BUT THAT'S OBVIOUS I MEAN THAT
IS CLEAR CUT- I JUST DON'T KNOW
HOW ELSE. SOMEBODY COULD. OF BY
THE CITATION FOR SOMETHING LIKE
THIS- SO THOSE ARE SOME OF MY-
QUESTIONS- WALTZ JUST DO WITHOUT
IF YOU WITH THE CHURCH BELLS AND
SO YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
TRYING TO NARROW THIS TO GET AT
THE HEART OF THE MATTER AND I
WOULD. I WOULD SUBMIT THAT IN
UNDER REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES IN
IN IN SOME OF THE VERY PLACES
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE SOCIAL
JUSTICE ISSUES WHICH WE SHOULD
BE. AYE NOISES ALSO. SOMETHING
THAT YOU KNOW SUBURBAN
COMMUNITIES JUST ON THE NATURAL
QUIETER. AND I THINK WE'RE
TRYING TO HELP THOSE URBAN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE SUFFERING
FROM NOISE POLLUTION SO THAT'S
PART OF WHY WE'RE DOING THIS-
FOR THE SOCIAL INEQUITY JUST ON
THE NOISE POLLUTION ISSUE. AS
FAR AS THE CITATION THE FIRST-
TIME IT CAPTURES YOU IT'S A
WARNING. SO THERE IS NO CITATION
THE FIRST TIME THIS HAPPENS AND
SO ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT FOLKS
HAVE BROUGHT FORWARD AS WELL
WHAT HAPPENS IF A MISTAKE YOU
KNOW SOMEBODY'S PARKED AT THAT
INTERSECTION NEXT TO THE PERSON
WHO ACTUALLY HAS THE LEGAL SO
THE LIKELIHOOD THAT THAT PERSON
WOULD BE CAPTUREDA SECOND TIME.
WHO IS INNOCENT IS NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE THAT THE SAME
CIRCUMVENT THEY BE AT THE SAME
INTERSECTION NEXT TO THE SAME
PERSON WHO WAS ACTUALLY CAUSING
THE NOISE PROBLEM SO WE'RE NOT
GOING TO CAPTURE THAT INNOCENT
PERSON OR THE THIRD OF THE A
RONI IS BYSTANDER WHO GETS. THAT
WE'RE NOT GONNA GET THEM A
SECOND I'M JUST A TYPICALLY
THAT'S JUST NOT GONNA HAPPEN.
FOR THE PERSON WHO HAS.
ILLEGALLY MODIFIED MUFFLER WHO
IS CAUSING THE NOISE POLLUTION
WE'RE GIVING THEM AN OPPORTUNITY
TO CURE THAT. WE'RE GIVING THEM
WE'RE ACTUALLY EVEN LOOKING AT A
AT A AT A AT A MONETARY WAY TO
TRY TO FINANCE THAT- BUT IF
YOU'RE A HABITUAL. PERSON WHO
WHO MIGHT ILLEGALLY MODIFIED
YOUR CAR TO. YOU KNOW EXCEED THE
DECIBEL LEVEL IN YOUR CONTINUE
TO CREATE A SITUATION WHERE YOU
KEEP GETTING CAUGHT- YOU KNOW
THAT'S THE PERSON WE'RE GOING
AFTER SO WE'RE TRYING TO PUT AS
MANY GUARD RAILS AROUND. THE
INNOCENT BYSTANDER AND THE
PERSON. THAT I ANALYZE I SAID
WE'RE EVEN LOOKING AT SOME
FINANCIAL. FINANCIAL HELP SO
WE'RE TAKING ALL THOSE COMMENTS
TO HEART AND WE'RE TRYING AND AS
FAR AS- TESTING IT IS A NARAL
PILOT- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SIX
CITIES. OUT OF FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THOSE CITIES
WOULD HAVE TO OPT IN AS WELL.
AND THE BILL HAS BUILT IN PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION BEFORE SHE CAN
EVEN ENACT. THE POLICY THEY HAVE
TO GO THROUGH A RIGOROUS PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION DISCUSSION. LET'S
SAY THERE'S A COMMUNITY OVW'S
LONG BEACH SINCE HE WAS BROUGHT
UP IF ONE BEACH WANTS TO DO IT.
LONG BEACH HAS TO HAVE A ROBUST
PUBLIC PROCESS BEFORE THEY EVEN
ENACT. THE POLICY WITH DEFINED.
WAYS OF IMPLEMENTING AND
ENFORCING IT AND WITH THE GUARD
RAILS THAT WE PUT IN PLACE WHICH
AS AS BOB MENTIONED WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THIS BEING
ENFORCED BY THE POLICE FORCE BY
IT'S GOING TO BE. YOU. KNOW DONE
BY THAT. PASSED BY OF A CITY NOT
THE LAWN. EFFORTS THE SELF. YOU
KNOW I THINK MAKING SURE THAT
THE CITY HAS THAT ROBUST PUBLIC.
DISCOURSE BEFORE THE IMPLEMENTED
WHERE ACTIVISTS CAN COME FORWARD
AND SAY YOU KNOW WHAT HERE'S WHO
WE LIKE IT WE DON'T LIKE OR WE
DON'T WANT IT. YOU KNOW THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
CITY'S NOT MANDATING THAT ANY
CITY DOES THIS. BUT I SHOULD
HEAR THERE ARE A BUNCH THERE ARE
SOME CITIES THAT WANT TO DO IT.
AND SO WE'RE GOING TO DEFINE
THAT ALTHOUGH SAFEGUARDS WITHIN
THAT PROCESS AND I THINK THAT
MAKES IT STRONGER. PARTY THANK
YOU. BOB THURSTON. THAN CYNICAL
BO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
APPRECIATED THE DIALOGUE SO FOR-
I THINK IT'S JUST WORTH NOTING
THAT WE'RE WE'RE IN JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE- AND THE CREATIVITY.
OF THE APPROACH YOU'VE TAKEN
HERE I THINK IS LAUDABLE AND
THAT- YOU KNOW WE HAVE LAWS ON
THE BOOKS RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
BASICALLY BEING COMPLETELY
IGNORED. AND WE WENT THROUGH A
VERY TOUGH PROCESS TO GET THOSE
BILLS PASSED I WORKED ON. THE
BILL THAT IT INSTITUTED- SOME
EXHAUST SYSTEM IN SOUND. A SOUND
REQUIREMENTS ON MOTORCYCLES AND-
CONSIDER PADLEY KERRY THAT
LEGISLATION THAT WAS. I WAS
SCARY THERE WERE THREATS- YOU
KNOW SHE HAD TO BE. PROTECTED BY
CHP DURING THE PASSAGE OF THAT
BILL WHO CAME TO OUR OFFICE HER
HOME- WE DID WHAT WE THOUGHT WAS
THAT THE HEAVY LIFT ON PUTTING.
THESE REQUIREMENTS ON THE BOOKS
IN CALIFORNIA LAW AND YET.
THEY'RE BASICALLY BEING IGNORED
AND THE QUESTION IN MY MIND IS
WHETHER WE DIVERT. PUBLIC SAFETY
RESOURCES TO TRYING TO MAKE THAT
LETTER OF THE LAW MATTER- AWAY
FROM SAY VIOLENT CRIME OR OTHER
ISSUES THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE
DEALING WITH AND DOWN TO VEHICLE
CODE VIOLATION OR WHETHER WE
TAKE SOME OTHER APPROACH I
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS THE
AUTHORS MADE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S THAT SORT OF ROBUST
PUBLIC PROCESS AND THEN ALSO.
THE CURE RATE I MEAN SO THAT
THEY WERE NOT UNDER CUTTING
ANYBODY'S RIGHT TO DUE PROCESS
HEARING THAT WE'RE WE'RE
ENSURING THAT- THERE'S AN
ABILITY TO CHALLENGE ANY ANY
SORT OF YOUR RONI IS- THE RONI'S
VIOLATION. BUT TO ME THIS IS.
IT'S FISCALLY IMPORTANT POLICY
BUT ALSO AS A MATTER OF SORT OF.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE NOT TO HAVE
THIS BE JUST ON LAW ENFORCEMENT-
TO HANDLE THIS- AND IN MANY
CASES THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT. DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY OR THE ABILITY TO DEAL
WITH- SO I I'D LOVE TO BE ADDED
ON TO THE MEASURE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND I WOULD
MOVE THE BILL- IF IT HASN'T BEEN
MOVED ALREADY. BUT I KNOW YOU
KEEP WORKING WITH ALL PARTIES
YOU'RE YOU'RE THE YOU'RE THE
CONSUMMATE- COALITION BUILDER
HERE AND I YOU KNOW. FOR THE
CONSTITUENTS OUT THERE FOLKS
LIKE MR BIEBER AND OTHERS. IT
SOUNDS LIKE- THE CONCERN THAT
WAS SORT OF QUOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT THE BILLINGE. THE
TO QUOTE SAFER STREETS THEY SAY
THE BILL ENSURES THEY'LL BE ZERO
GOVERNMENT TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY SOUNDS LIKE
THAT'S NOT THE CASE ANYMORE.
THERE'S NO LONGER ZERO- SO I
LOVE YOUR AND WHERE THE BILL IS
HEADED. AND YEAH APPRECIATED.
ARE ALL RIGHT- SUPPORT DO CARE
TO RESPOND AS SINISTER'S COME
ABOUT YOU BEING THE CONSUMMATE
COALITION BUILDER YEAH I AGREE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY ALL RIGHT ALL
RIGHT SENATE CABALLERO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
MOMENTS THAT YOU'VE TAKEN YOU'VE
GIVEN SOME REAL REAL IMPORTANT
FIGHT TO IT- I WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT THE BILL WHEN I. AND I HAD
A WATCH AND TO SEE WHAT
AMENDMENTS FIXTURE WAS GOOD BUT
IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE YOU TAKE
CARE OF ALL OF THEM AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. I'M GONNA SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY THANK YOU A
SENATOR AND I HAVE TO GIVE A
SHOUT OUT TO MY STAFF. THEY HAVE
BEEN ON ALMOST DAILY CALLS WITH.
A BOTH SUPPORTERS AND OPPONENTS
AND REALLY BEEN TRYING TO GET TO
GET THERE AND SO. AND THE WORK
WE DID IN TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE AND THEN THE ANALYSIS
HERE HIGHLIGHTED YOU KNOW MANY
OF THE SAME ISSUE SO. OTHER
QUESTIONS- CENTER STERN I
BELIEVE MOVE THE BILL- ALL
RIGHT- INCENTIVE FOR DINNER
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR TAKING
NOTICE SOME OF THE ISSUES HAVE
BEEN RAISED IN JUDICIARY
ANALYSIS. UP THERE ARE SOME
TECHNICAL CHALLENGE. THAT I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE WILLING
TO. ADDRESS AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD I'M GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
ALL RIGHT. SO- THANK. YOU DIDN'T
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AN
AYE VOTE ALL RIGHT EXCELLENT ALL
RIGHT- THIS IS SENATE BILL TEN
SEVENTY NINE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR STERN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS- BURKE. NUMBER GUY BURGESS.
ZERO ZERO I'D THE RUSSELL THE
REST SO I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG AYE JONES.
JONES NO LAYERED. LAYERED ICE
STERN STERN AYE A WAKE CAL SKI
WINNER WIENER I. THAT'S EIGHT TO
ONE WITH A MEMBER MISSING WHO IS
COMING BACK ALL RIGHT- THANK YOU
SIR PORTANTINO NEXT WE HAVE- THE
LAST BILL I BELIEVE BY CENTER
THE RUSSELL S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
SO. ANYONE WHO WISHES TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE VOTE TALLY NOW
WOULD BE A GOOD TIME TO COME
BACK TO ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED ALL
RIGHT. SIR RUSSELL ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN SB TWELVE SIXTY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS LAST YEAR SB SIXTY TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT A BUSINESS
CONTRACTING HAVE GARMENTS MADE
IS LIABLE FOR UNPAID MINIMUM
WAGE AND OVERTIME- TO THE
WORKERS TO MAKE. SURE THOSE
GARMENTS REGARDLESS OF THE MANY
LAYERS OF CONTRACTING. END OF
SESSION AMENDMENTS RESULTED
UNFORTUNATELY IN A LONGSTANDING
PROVISION OF LABOR LAW IN THE
BIRD AT LEAST STRIPPED FROM THE
LABOR CODE. S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
CORRECTS THIS IS PURELY DRAFTING
ERROR BY INSERTING THOSE
PROVISIONS BACK INTO THE LAW THE
WAY IT HAS BEEN FOR TWENTY YEARS
AS GOVERNMENT WORKER PROTECTIONS
WERE FIRST. ENACTED SPECIFICALLY
IT ADDS LIQUIDATED DAMAGES EQUAL
TO THE WAGES UNLAWFULLY WITHHELD
AND LIQUIDATED DAMAGES EQUAL TO
UNPAID OVERTIME COMPENSATION.
DUE TO PENALTIES APPLY TO CAR
MANUFACTURERS AGAIN THIS HAS
BEEN THE LAW FOR TWENTY YEARS-
TODAY WE HAVE ONE EXPERT
AVAILABLE ON THE WITNESS LINE
MATTHEW THE CARD LIST THE
CARLESS FROM BUT SAID IT OUT
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CARLOS IF
YOU'RE AVAILABLE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN HONORABLE
MEMBERS HI MATTHEW TO CARLESS A
STAFF ATTORNEY AT THAT SPECIFIC
LEGAL SERVICES- WE WERE ONE OF
THE CO SPONSORS OF THE SB SIXTY
TWO. AND ADDS TO SENATOR ALSO
HAVE SAYS- THIS BILL SB TWELVE
SIXTY NEARLY CORRECT THE SAYS IN
BURTON CRAFTING ERROR THAT
OCCURRED IN THE- FINAL MOMENTS
OF THE SESSION LAST YEAR. IT
ALSO CORRECT AND INCORRECT CROSS
REFERENCES- THAT. ADDRESS THE
FINAL AMENDMENTS THAT WERE MADE
BEFORE THE VOTE PARTICULARLY IN
LABOR CODE SECTION. TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY THREE POINT ONE. AND FOR
THIS REASON WE FOR YOUR I. PHONE
. ALL RIGHTY- OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SAYING KNOWN AS THE
CHAMBER APPROACHES MICROPHONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE SIXTY.
THANK YOU MISTER TURNER AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWELVE SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IS THE
COURTS OF SB FIVE SIXTY. IN A
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT-
OPPOSITION I'VE NO ONE LISTENED
PRIMARY OPPOSITION IF ANYONE IS
IN OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
SING KNOWN APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE. LET'S TURN TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE WHO ARE
OPPOSED TO SB TWELVE SIXTY.
WE'LL ALL BE. VERY GRATEFUL.
THANK YOU MISTER TURNER AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHT SB TWELVE SIXTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. BUT AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWELVE SIXTY IN A PRESS ONE AND
THEN THERE ARE NONE. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT-
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING NO
HANDS REYES THOUGH CENTER
GONZALEZ TO MOVING THE BILL.
SAID IT'S ALWAYS MOVES THE BILL-
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO- IN A
MOMENT SYNDROS IS GONNA CLOSE
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE
ROLE ON ALL THE BILLS SO. IF YOU
HEAR MY VOICE YOU SHOULD COME TO
THE CHAMBER IF YOU WISH TO VOTE.
ALL RIGHT SO THE ROSSEL- THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT SIR SENATOR ALSO
S. RELY VOTE. MANAGE YOU COUNSEL
IF YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL THIS
IS SENATE BILL TWELVE SIXTY BY
SENATOR DO THAT SO WITH THE
MOTION BY CENTER GONZALEZ THE
MERCHANT IS DUE PASS- BURKE BY.
NUMBER AYE BURGESS. ZERO ZERO I
DID ASAL. THE REST SO I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I A HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE JONES. JONES NO
LESS. LAYERED ICE STERN STERN I
WAKE CAL SKI WIENER. WIENER I.
THE OF EIGHT TO ONE WITH-
MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT COMING
ABOUT THAT ON CALL WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN HERE FOR ABOUT THREE
MINUTES SHALL WE GO THROUGH THE
ROLE ONE TIME AND THEN- ONE MORE
TIME. SO FOR EXAMPLE. CENTERS
THERE OKAY. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO
THROUGH THE ROLE- ONE TIME AND
THEN- I THINK WE'RE WAITING
CENTER BOARD JUST AS THAT THAT'S
CORRECT ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT
WE'LL START IN FILE ORDER- S. B.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY THREE BY SENATOR
ARE TO LET THAT WITH- SURE
VOTING I. PORTIS STERN. BUT
STERN. SURE IT'S FILE ITEM TWO.
OKAY STERN. HI STERN HI. WHY
CASKEY. WE STILL HAVE ONE MEMBER
MISSING BUT THAT'S EIGHT TO ONE
SO FAR. NEXT IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE BY
SENATOR EGGMAN SP TEN THIRTY
FIVE CHAIR VOTING HI STERN.
STERN AYE A WEIGHT CAL SKI- THAT
IS TEN TWO ZERO ALL MEMBERS
VOTING ALL RIGHT BILLS OUT. NEXT
WE HAVE FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR BY
CAT CENTRE KAMLAGER S. B. TEN
EIGHTY FIVE. WITH THAT CHAIR
VOTING HI BORJAS STERN. STERN
AYE BY CAL SKI. YOU HAVE NINE
TWO ZERO WITH A MEMBER MISSING I
PUT BACK ON CALL AND NEXT WE
HAVE A SENATOR LEE MONTHS BILL
FILE ITEM FIVE SB TWELVE FIFTY
TEACHER VOTING I STE STERN.
STERN I'D WAKE CAL SKI ON THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE TEN TWO ZERO ALL
MEMBERS HAVING VOTED BILLS OUT.
THE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER SIX
SB TWELVE SEVENTY NINE BY IT
WOULD SHOW A BOW- WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING HI. BORJAS BOB BURGESS I
STERN STERN HI QUICO SKI K.
WHITE CASKET SENDIRI CASKEY IS
NOT HERE BUT YOU HAVE EVERYONE
WHO'S GOING TO BE HERE YOU HAVE
OUR HAN TWO ZERO BILLS OUT. ALL
RIGHT WELL NEXT FROM FILE ITEM
TEN. WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI
THIS IS S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE
BY SENATOR CAFIERO TRIGGERING II
BURGESS BURGESS I Y. CASKEY. YOU
HAVE TEN ZERO BILLS OUT. NEXT WE
HAVE FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT S.
B. TEN SEVENTY NINE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO CHAIR VOTING HI
BORJAS THIS IS SB TEN SEVENTY
NINE. A FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO CHAIR
VOTING I- PORTIS. FORTIS NOT
VOTING AND SEVEN TENS SEVENTY
NINE THREE NINE FOUR JUST NOT
VOTING- MY CASKEY. BECAUSE HE'S
NOT HERE. SIX SEVENTY THAT'S
EIGHT TWO ONE FILLS OUT. NEXT WE
HAVE FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN BY
SENATOR DO TO US SO. YOUR VOTING
I. FIVE FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
BURGESS BURGESS NO BY CAL SKI-
THAT IS. THAT'S EIGHT TWO TWO
ALL MEMBERS HAVING BILLS OUT
HERE. OKAY SENATOR STERN YOU'VE
VOTED ON EVERYTHING YEAH THAT I
HAVE HERE HI THANK YOU CENTER
STERN YES- OKAY WE HAVE THREE
MORE TO GO THROUGH OKAY. ABOUT
ITEM NUMBER TWO BY SENATE ARE TO
LET THAT S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
THREE TEAR VOTING I BURGESS
BURGESS NO WAY CASKEY. BUT YOU
HAVE EIGHT TWO BILLS OUT. FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR BY SENATOR
KAMLAGER CHAIR VOTING I. FILE
ITEM FOR BURGESS BURGESS NO
WHITE HOUSE SKI. YOU HAVE. NINE
TO ONE BILLS OUT. NEXT WE HAVE
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE BY SENATOR
LIMON S. B. TWELVE FIFTY- CHAIR
VOTING I HAVE. OKAY BY CAL SKI.
THAT SAID TEN ZERO BILLS OUT.
THAT THAT'S THANKS TO ALL RIGHT
THERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE-
ARE ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
IMMEDIATELY AFTER SESSION WHERE
WE WILL TAKE UP- A BILL. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU
STEP.